I'm sick of it, bro. I'm sick of it. After this, if he wants
to talk, we can have a conversation. Okay. Creman has Cman has
won again. Creman's secret tricks against me have worked clearly.
And of course, Creamman sent it to me. This must obviously you
know, we know. We know what's going on, don't we? We know what's
going on, dude.
Oh. Oh, I've let the car the B. Oh. Uhoh. I've let the car the
bag.
Forget the links. It's the novels of psycho analysis. He psycho
analysis he should be worried about.
I do want to just listen his just to his justification for why
he covered it. I do need this off the bat probably. Probably.
Okay.
But I told him, "Hey, you got to respond. This guy's talking
on your name, bro. He's talking on your name." But you going
to not respond?
I said, "I will have a conversation with you."
I said, "I'll have a conversation." How is that running?
Yes, Tommy's going insane.
He's done another stream and [__] I'll talk to him
right now. I'll talk to him right now, bro. Why am I going to
react to him talking about me to me talking about him? He spoke
about my content. It's ridiculous, bro. I'm not afraid to talk
to anyone, bro. I'll talk to him if he wants. I'm just not going
to watch his video because it's ridiculous.
What is
so just doing the scan, I'm not going to watch his video because
it's ridiculous, mate. It's ridiculous.
And then we go four minutes into the future and he's watching
Tommy's video. So I wonder what happened between now and 4 minutes
from now that he totally reversed his course on this.
What could have possibly happened?
What are we doing here, bro? This reacception.
Just have a conversation with me, bro. Just have a conversation.
We had this whole this whole meme. Riyle's been engaging in it.
Queen's been engaging in it where there's like a commentary civil
war on Willie Mack on Tommy C. Okay, they want to they want to
with these guys. They want to go and make these guys like upset
because they think they're like lesser than content creators.
Okay, and Chud has basically tried to say, "No, I think that's
all a little played up. I don't want to be a part of it. I don't
want to do any of this." And Tommy C basically accused Chud of
weaponizing Quean and pretending he's above it, but also like
taking what Queenman tells him and then trying to roll that into
like little jabs at all these people. Like basically he's calling
Chud dis disingenuous, dishonest that Chud really wants to [__]
with these people. He actually doesn't like Nicholas. He'll snake
Nicholas as soon as he can. And that's proven by Chud saying
what? Oh, Nicholing Nicholas out with the uh with the H3 coverage.
That drama is drama dry. It's dry as a desert out here, bro.
Except unless you want to suck the dick of Ethan Klein. Yes,
Nicholas Dor, I'm talking to you or whatever, right? He did his
whole thing.
And and Tommy C took exception to that. Some other commentary
people took took exception to that. And I think apparently Willie
Mack might have taken exception to that now, too, from what I
understand. So, I just want to see how he gets talked into watching
the video. And once he starts watching Tommy's video, I'll turn
Tommy back on and we'll watch through Tommy's vot. Okay.
Quum does love picking on people for no reason. That's uh that's
not entirely true. That's like That can be So,
that's not entirely true. Okay, that's not that's not entirely
true. Anyway, we're now t-minus three minutes. I still have no
clue how he gets bullied into watching this Tommy stream. Okay,
because I tried to do it. Tried to do it. Queen tried to do it.
Stylo tried to do it. I think pretty much everybody tried to
get him to talk about Trump about uh about Tommy. We all were
all telling him like, "Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead with people."
And and he was like, "No, no, no, no. This won't ever be anything."
Blah blah blah blah blah. I'm never going to respond. Why would
I respond? And after Tommy did a second video, somehow he ends
up responding. We'll see. Fine, but it's just pathetic. It's
totally pathetic. Just have a conversation. What's your problem,
bro?
on stream, off stream. He can record it. He can record the whole
thing if he's worried about me snaking him or something like
that. It's ridiculous.
I won't bring anyone else on. It will just be me and him. That's
it. I'm not going to dog pile. No one else will come into the
call.
It's ridiculous.
I got nothing to fear. I got nothing to hide. I got literally
nothing to hide. nothing to fear. It's all out there. All my
comments are out there in the open that you can see.
I don't understand this. Uh, you know,
I don't understand why he can't just have a conversation about
it instead of this stupid like, you know, talking about each
other on our streams backwards and forwards. I'm sure he's going to
do another [__] 30 minutes about this as well.
Just have a convers 30 minutes.
4 and 1/2 hours. 4 and a half hours. He's still looking at Chudlo
Logic's face on his stream. Okay, 20 minutes. What do we mean
in 20 minutes?
What is this bro? Just have a conversation with me, bro. Just
have a combo. What is going on, dude?
What is going on? I don't understand what has happened. But you
can't just have a conversation anymore. I hate to keep pointing
it out cuz I am now edging you guys, but t-minus 2 minutes until
Chud hops on this until Chud gets over to the video. He's still
not gotten over the video. This idea
that it's like
that I'm a snake so I can't be spoken
Well, it's all in the It's all in the public. It's all in the
open.
Stop playing Silly Buggers and pull up the Okay.
Okay. So, the time start. We'll watch
Wait, hold on. What?
What? Who said that?
that it's like snake [__] that I'm a snake so I can't
be spoken to.
Well, it's all in the it's all in the public. Oh, that's in the
open. Hold on. Is this a meta conversation? Wait, wait, wait.
Silly buggers and pull up the Okay, that guy.
Okay, so the Tommy's got this absurd idea that I'm controlled
by Queenman somehow. That I'm that I'm controlled by Queen somehow.
It's totally insane, bro. It's totally insane. Stop playing silly
buggers and pull up the video. Give us 10 minutes of comedy.
We are starving. And then he just listens to Queenman right there.
He just immediately goes, "You know what? Yes, sir. Manurion
candidate." Queen goes, "Hey, hey, I'm speaking to you, slave.
I'm speaking to you. Play the video. Play the video now." And
Ch's like, "Yes, yes, master. Yes. Yes, my master. Yes, I will.
I will play the video, actually. Yes.
Thank you for the shekels, master. Thank
Oh, whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Hit play. Creamman wins.
Creamman's won again. Go on.
Get fatter to get on the He just He spent all this time telling
everybody they're insane for trying to get him to engage with
this. And then Queen goes, "You should watch it right now." And
he's like, "Yes, I will watch it right now. Actually, this like
Jedi mind trick in real time. Oh, you should stop. You should
stop around and just cover the cover the content for us." Okay.
Masterfully crafted clip. You'll be reacting to Chud, reacting
to Tommy C, reacting to a clip of you pointing this out. Go on,
send it through. Let's have a look. Only loves gripping thick
hips. But I'm not doing this again. I'm I'm It's done after this.
I'm not watching I'm not doing any more of this stupid reacception
[__] Okay. I'm sick of it, bro. I'm sick of it. After
this, if he wants to talk, we can have a conversation. Okay.
Creman has won again. Creman's secret tricks against me have
worked clearly.
And of course, Creamman sent it to me. This must Dude, this is
this is probably the what, fifth or sixth time you sent me Tommy's
content to react to, Creamman. Something like that. Is that
All those things you send me.
He knows how to lean into it. Obviously, you know, I know you
downplayed it.
Uh, I'm glad Chud's getting it. Okay. You just lean into this.
Okay. Yeah. Obviously, Queen tells him exactly what to do. obviously
on stream, but obviously you know we know we know what's going
on, don't we? We know what's going on, dude.
Oh [__] I shouldn't Oh, I should Oh, I've let the
cow the B Oh. Uhoh. I've let the cow the bag.
Oh no.
Forget the links. It's the novels of psychoanalyst. He psycho
analysis. He should be worried about
metronome.
Okay. Is does Tommy C do the whole
So Tommy C saw that Chud was going to react.
I think he watches does he watch Chud's full VOD? He does. This
is total reaction. So
we'll listen to Tommy a little bit. Talk through some stuff.
call me crazy, but you know, we'll listen to Tommy talking through
some stuff. I'm going to speed it up a little bit before I go
into some kind of react. We did skim through it. I did skim through
it. Uh, but we want to do live reaction. And Jenny, what would
you say? Patty Prime where the tipster tippy tippy. So,
there's just too much pausing for me, honestly. It It took forever
to get through like first 10 minutes of the video or Yeah. video
and it it just got to a point where I just need to stop. First
time watching a Chud reaction. Okay. Yeah, he is going to take
a 20-minute video and turn that into two hours of stream content
every time. Yeah. That's just good business. Okay. You save the
good content for every other day this week. Is that his assistant?
It's his co-host. Here's the thing, folks. What we're trying
to do here is we're trying to do a super cut. Chug did 2 hours
and 18 minutes on a 20 minute 25 minute 22 25m minute video.
Um I don't know if you just answered what I said, but he's all
over the place most of the time. is calling the name. Oh, a super
cut. That means I'm not going to get the whole stream from Tommy.
Is he really doing a super cut? So, he's not going to respond
to everything Chud said. That's um which is fine because to me
the name calling is a call to kind of chin up the crowd to get
me mauled, so to speak. So, I'll just go away like, "Oh my god,
I can't believe I messed with Chud logic. Jesus, all these people
hate me." Um, and that to me just means shut up. When I hear
shut up, don't embarrass yourself. That's that's perfectly funny,
too, because if you take if you take like I saw funny said um
you know said something to the effect you're getting totally
mold in your own discord. Yeah, that's like winning. I'm paraphrasing.
I apologize. I mean, you'd have to think that I'm trying to win
something. I'm not. I'm trying to provoke something and I think
I've done it pretty much successfully. I'm trying to provoke
a chalk logic through his
This is like the coper like I'm listen I was wrong on everything
I said but I'm just you know I think it's important to start
a conversation. I
hate this topic or sorry this this like response to things. Okay.
Oh guys, I was just trying to start a conversation. Shut the
up. You're just wrong. You're just wrong and but you want to
not appear wrong and so you actually just say you were trying
to get a conversation going. Listen guys, I know I look silly
now, but I was just trying to make people understand that this
guy might be a snake. Maybe. Maybe. Maybe. Pattern of behavior.
I think he's a snake. I think he's shown many things. One of
the things that got lost is that, you know, I just got um I just
got the phone with Groutton T, who may have been bad empanaded.
Um I can't wait to see Chud and that guy's uh in that guy's court,
which he's probably leaning towards, I guess. Him and Queen.
So he um he he's under Yeah. Chud and Chud and Bad Empanad are
basically the same person. Yeah. Totally. Totally. Investigationally
by the Austrian government,
the
overwhelming odds. I mean, it's not 100%. It's probably bad and
banana. Um and uh I think made that complaint to be sorry especially
as an Australian citizen but or um crowd told me um that Chub
was pestering him and he thought it was weird. Hit it once or
twice about getting ser?
Can you give me his DMs? I'm sorry. That's a snake move. Even
if you don't know the guy.
What?
Wait, can you get me his DMs? Wait, does what does that mean?
Can you get me his DMs? Like can you leak his DMs to me or can
you get me like a message access to him? Because one of those
is not snaky in any way.
Tommy means to get in contact. How is it snaky to ask a mutual
friend to put you in contact with somebody, another professional
association? That's the what? That's literally how like networking
and trying to to talk to somebody works. Hey, I know someone
who knows someone. Can you put me in contact with him? Uh, hey,
you're a mutual friend of me and this other guy. I want to talk
to him. Could you put me in contact with him? That is sneaky
as
going up to Willie Willie Mack saying, "Hey buddy, why don't
you come on the show? I see you're crashing out. Do you want
to defend yourself?" Yeah. Willy thought. Yeah. Yeah. You're
trying to wrangle me. You're not my friend. I'm content to you.
Jud's content to every everybody's content to Chud,
We have a problem with that. That bro, I've watched Chud look
really in debates before. Everybody does this. You just you like
talk to people, right? You just have a conversation with them.
You don't have to me. You really really really don't have to
go on streams at all. But like why why is like losing even if
you lose an argument, why is that like wrangling? Just go on
and say what you mean. Just go on and say what you think. Just
if you have any amount of humility, right, most of those conversations
go just fine. Just have any amount of humility and you're totally
fine. That's fine. But, you know, don't sit there and lecture
me on how what a good guy is, how fair he is. Chud likes to live
in the image of fairness. He doesn't want to be fair. Um, he
plays dumb. Then just show the show where he's being unfair.
Why do we have this whole thing where you're like, "Oh, show,
oh, Chud's like so full of he's such a snake." Just bring up
the examples. The Boax one is one that was good. The Turkey Tom
one I do not think is good. Okay, Chud I, from what I remember,
Chud only got set off when he heard something he felt was dishonest
in that New Year's stream, right? It wasn't like Chud was hunting
or anything. He just he heard something he felt was dishonest
and he kind of went off about it and he was correct. Entirely
correct,
right? I don't know why. Like also, the other thing you should
point out is where he's like um where he's talking [__]
to somebody and like how he's wrong in the thing he says, right?
Cuz yeah, I understand the Box thing's kind of a leak, but everything
with regards to the Destiny stuff with the stuff he interrupted
with there, I don't think any of that was sneaky at all in that
in that New Year's stream.
Chud is a salesman. Why would anyone want to talk to a salesman?
I'm just saying that like if you have a problem with him, if
you have an issue with him and he's willing to talk to you, just
go talk to him. Why Why couldn't Tommy have said, "Hey, could
I get like Nicholas to moderate or something?" Like get get Tommy
a a moderator that's favorable to his side or something. Maybe
not Nicholas, but like anyone. Just get somebody to moderate
who's like who knows both people.
Like I don't think Tommy has to talk to Chud one. I think they
could easily get somebody to like sit in the conversation, make
sure Chud isn't doing something to him. Not that Chud would.
I don't I don't know if Chud would. But like if Tommy's that
worried about it, I don't know why he wouldn't just bring another
guy in who could be fair, who understands Tommy's point of point
of view. Um and he gets angry when you point it out. And to all
those people that you know say I got to go on and talk to him.
May I point you to harmful opinions when he just screams and
yells at him the whole time. No. And then from what I understand
in the video he um he wants me to come on wants me to come on
the show and it says to do it privately and I guess at the point
I was like the 217 point, right? He says I'm not talking 218.
I'm not talking to that guy anyway. So he's all over the place.
So it's he's really fishing for a win. And I don't feel I don't
care how much you call me a especially like if it's coming from
beaker queen himself or him them calling me a has like zero effect.
I think Chud's a sad sack of [__] I think a lot of
people in this business or it's really a revenge of the nerd
situation. I mean what is Chud? Is he a leftwing intellectual
that is really sharp commentary on drama or is he really just
a pathetic guy that doesn't live with his kids that is trolling
for busy on his on his time on on his office?
he's a really pathetic guy that doesn't live with his kids. Aren't
he and his like former partner not together?
Why? How the could he live with his kids? That's such a That's
such a dude, you you don't have custody of your kids, which by
the way, I think is actually like it sucks as a parent, but not
having to trade your kids like every other week or every two
weeks is probably just way better for the kids. I'm sorry. It's
nice that Chud can see his kids, but when you have the kids moving
constantly, that's actually not really that good for the kids.
I think like a stable home environment is like super important
to to raising kids. And he's around his kids. He lives in the
same city. He sees them. He can pick them up in emergency cases
all the time. He does. does so all the time. I think it's super
to take a shot at him as a parent when he's doing the best he
can in a separated situation.
Sorry, separated situation. That's like such a that's such a
dog thing to do.
it's also me. I don't know very much about Tommy,
okay? But I know he's not a super successful streamer.
Why why is he taking shots at a guy who's like providing for
his kids when he's when he has basically objectively failed to
do so when he was about to shut down the only career he's ever
had or ever been good at
because it just wasn't he he failed entirely. He is like a failed
man. A totally failed man. And he's gonna take shots at Chud
who can support his kids
Yeah. Actually, hold on. Let me think about it.
He doesn't live with his kids. Yes, but if you lived with your
kids and you didn't have your wife to um who was making all the
money, your kids wouldn't be getting support. Your kids would
be like in the poor house. You'd be living in poverty.
I don't uh whatever. I And that's what I think he's trying to
cover up. I mean, I think you'll see in this video, he looks
like a kid that got caught and when he gets caught, he says,
"Well, so what? Who cares anyway?" And I want to point out too
in his first rep response, I mean, you would think that he came
out the night of the New Year stream and said, "Yeah, blowbacks."
Which, okay, there's nothing I could say about that. You might
might say, "Yeah, now he's saying backs." But that was a second
response. And I am really happy with that second video did. It
got exactly out of him what I wanted to. Can I win this war?
No. Who thinks I can win? It's just simply a numbers game. It's
a popularity measuring contest.
then what is the point of commentary at all? If only if it's
only whoever has the most people, why is commentary even a genre?
How did any commentary streamer ever rise? Ever?
Oh, actually, it's just a popularity contest, guys. You can never
like you can never farm off a bigger audience. You can never
win against somebody with a bigger audience ever. What?
What the are we talking about?
Of course, if you're making good points against somebody who's
a bigger creator, you will end up getting like viewers from them,
you'll end up like raising uh you know, improving your own prestige
and denigrating theirs. Yeah, if you have like an existential
allout fight, and he is going for like an existential all-out
fight. He's just lucky he really doesn't have any reputation
left, right? He's going after Chud.
But like all he has to do like I think
I think I could be fair to him, right? I went back and reevaluated
that clip after he gave his reason. like, oh, you know, listening
to it that way, I can actually hear that he would mean that maybe,
right? I don't think I've been like totally unfair to him or
anything.
I don't know, whatever. I think I think if he had really good
points about Chud, I would say that. I think I even added points
he didn't have, right? I was talking to Queenman and I was like,
"Yeah, the way I can see how you'd think this about Chud, the
way he like soft disavows things but reads them. It's like Nicholas
is a totally is a morbidly obese moral repbate and he like reads
that out of a chat from like I don't know Stinkfist 570. Actually
that is a chatter we used to have here but he reads that from
like Stinkfist 570. He goes, "I I disavow that in the strongest
possible terms." Right. And it's like, "Well, you're kind of
talking while saying you disavow. It's not really genuine." True.
Like, right? That's what he's doing there. And
I don't know. Like, I can I gave that point. I could be totally
fair to Tommy's point of view. I think that's um really like
narrow and doesn't take into account like how Chad acts in most
ways, but
That's fine. Can do is plant a seed. What I can do is get the
commentary communities or as commentators because I'm a YouTuber's
YouTuber to look at Chud and when he somebody wants to work with
him, they can go back on everything that I say and check out
like, you know, this guy might not be trustworthy. Yeah, Tommy
C is a waterbed brain conspiracy theorist,
but he did. That's part of the joke though. It is part of the
joke. Hold on. It is part of the joke. Yes. But the thing is
is if people decide that you're actually bad faith, then you're
like mocking them with plausible the it's just a lens change
from a joke that's funny to mocking them with plausible deniability,
right? And I've talked about this with Kumman all the time. It's
a way to say something funny that you think is funny and you
think rings true a little bit without getting in trouble for
it, right?
Like there is there is yeah if you just have a slightly different
lens on the person who's saying it you can totally see how I
would say oh that's actually them talking with plausible deniability.
That's that's the lens flip Tommy's had. I understand that. I'll
point that out. I just don't I think there are other actions
around like what what Chud's done where he's not really I don't
think he's like some kind of moral repbate.
That's the impression I've got from interacting in private. But
hey, I once thought Destiny was a kind of good guy too. So maybe
I just shouldn't be trusted on any private interactions. Although
I will say with Destiny made no sense. But anyway, and when he
somebody wants to work with him, they can go back on everything
that I say and check out like you know this guy might not be
trustworthy. Yeah, Tommy C is a waterb brain conspiracy theorist.
But he did drop this the thing on Bobax and Boax is a complete
piece of [__] but maybe that's why he did it. So
if I tell him something, I'm sorry. None of these commentary
losers can virtue signal over Bobs when they went around in every
possible DM. They spread the idea of Boaxs in address more than
Destiny spread his wife's non-consensually. Okay, these guys
cannot morally grandstand on this point. Shut the up. You all
mocked Boaxs behind his back for months. You losers.
Shut the up. Stop trying to Don't morally tried to leak the Bolex
dress thing. You you were all yapping about that for as far as
anybody could see. Shut the up and personal or he's told to keep
quiet about something and I am no more viable to him. I'll just
rub it on him. Uh ex-wife wasn't ex-wife when he leaked her non-consensually.
Okay. I remember I saw somebody saying I was defending Boax and
nobody's defending Boax. Nobody nobody hates me more than Boax.
He needs his pills. But I think what other people will see and
probably will humor him and tell him, "Oh no, it's no big deal.
Yeah, you could have leaked on Bobax. I'm telling you [__]
bro.
That's what I think is going to happen. So, look, there's nothing
wrong with looking for on the internet or man or whatever it
is. There's nothing wrong with it. Yeah, there is. Yeah, there
is. Um, but it really makes him look like a sad sack of [__]
There is something wrong with snaking your friends and pretending
publicly that you're all right with them. There is something
wrong with uh saying nasty about people. He just said it, right?
He just said it. Um, but listen to this line right there and
then think back to all of these group chats that are talking
about Bo. Didn't you do that to a degree? No. Bobs? No. And I've
never I've never virtue signaled over Boaxs. I've never I've
never been like, "Oh my god, I can't believe Chud leaked those
DMs." Unless you're mentioning something else, I have no idea
what you could possibly be talking about. It really makes him
look like I'm not in any of those group chats. Say that [__]
There is something wrong with snaking your friends and pretending
publicly that you're all right with them. That's what they did
to Bowax.
That's exactly what they did to
Like, how am I supposed to take any of these people seriously
when they treated Boax the way they did? When they totally [__]
on him and pretended publicly they were fine.
How am I supposed to take any of them seriously? How am I supposed
to take Tommy seriously?
How did all these people know about Boax in address?
All of them. When Boax me. Yeah, I there is something wrong with
uh saying nasty about people and then turning around and hiding.
Hey, come on. You can't take criticism. You can't take the jokes.
Well, how come your jokes are no different? But only when you
say it in public. If you're just talking in like massive group
chats or just in DMs to other people, if you're like totally
disingenuous, the same kind of snake you're accusing Chut of
being, but as long as it's only to a small group of people, then
it's totally fine. Then we're totally cool. We're awesome. That's
so cool when we do it only in a small group. But if you if you
say that comment publicly, if you make a little joke or a little
jab publicly, oh my god, it's [__] Now it's on. It's
on like Donkey Kong. Okay,
that's crazy.
This guy can't even pronounce his name correctly once. I'm walking
a tightroppe here. I learned from Chud covering Aiden drawing
it. Okay.
Different from before and after I called you out. Simple. You
never liked me. You never respected me. And you don't respect
anybody else. This is a climbing job for you and it always will
be. So, buckle up, buttercups. We got a long night ahead of us.
Wait, what? What have you done to earn anyone's respect?
What as how long has Chud been aware of you for? And what have
you done in the in the time that Chud's been aware of you? What
have you done to earn his respect? How has Chud not treated Tommy
C with totally undeserved respect and adoration
in every way? Like, as far as I know, Chud only had positive
comments to make about Tommy C. He'd bring Tommy C on. He'd shout
out Tommy C's channel all the time. What did Tommy do to earn
that?
Anybody? What do we have? What did What did Tommy do? I don't
know what he did. I'd never heard of any content he did. The
only times he appeared on stream, he's a total
cuz I'm going to go over. Was it two hour? It's just It's almost
two hours flat, right? Oh, yeah. It's about Yeah, it's about
two two hours flat. Yeah. Yeah, dude. Just call Chud and um All
right, I'm going to I'm going to say this just like once maybe
later in the show. Green, I I would look like the biggest hypocrite
in the world. I just called this guy a snake. I just said he
was chudworthy. What do you think? This is some kind of communication
problem. He said he didn't want to call me because he doesn't
have a problem with me. The only reason that he'd want me on
the show is to pull a um harmful opinion stunt. This is all about
getting the win. If I talk if I talked to him in any capacity,
that would mean like I would get criticized by way you called
the guy a snake and now you're cool with him. There's look what
are we going to debate character? I think you're a bad person.
No, I'm not. What do you think we're going to get to the bottom
of? Now, I know I might be taking away your robbing you of your
content, but I don't really care about that. this is um unresolvable.
I think he's a snake and I'm going to stand by it and something
tells me um what was the word they were using last year? Vindication
will come one day. I don't think that you can continue to be
this kind of snake and somebody snitch on you eventually. Somebody's
going to snitch on you. It's I look he's going to blow himself
up. He's blown himself up before and it's going to happen again.
When did he blow himself Wait, when has he blown himself up?
Is that referring to the uh the little boy again? The the little
boy incident? Is that what he's referring to? I really don't
care. What I'm going to be doing over the next coming years is
I'm going to look out when he, you know, does a Willy Mack when
he says, "This is ridiculous, but there's a good point here,
but you don't understand because this is really good nuance.
You don't understand nuance." The YouTuber's um word to deflect
from explaining anything. This is really nuance commentary. Nuance
commentary. I mean, are you kidding me? This is a guilty pleasure.
This is not I mean, Chud reminds me of a lot of these sports
guys that didn't get into politics, so they have to settle for
being sports cancer. Chun has to settle for being a drama tuber.
I mean, I feel like the guy in Taxi, you know, he's
this may be the most absurd thing I've ever seen. What do you
mean Chud has to settle for being a drama tuber? Has he not?
I feel like I've seen Chud turn content down because he's like,
"No, I'm a drama person. I don't want to do that kind of content."
The are we talking about? The first episode of Taxi, they get
they dance hers. I'm the only cab driver in this place. Everybody
else is a boxer. They're an actor. or a pain or something. I'm
the only cave driver in this place. Well, I'm the only job in
this place because I have no plans to move up or and I could
give a [__] how smart you think I I am. Move up to
what? Or I'm not. So, here's what we're going to do. From what
I understand to the Willie back part of my 25minute video, it
takes over an hour.
Over an hour. That's it. That's amazing. Tommy's Tommy's total
befuddlement, okay, at the idea that Chud could have commentary
on his opinions for like two to one in terms of minutes. Like
two to one in terms of minutes or 3 to one in terms of minutes
will never not be funny. Okay, can you believe that this guy
could comment on my content for more time than I spoke? How is
that even possible? How could this guy inject his own opinions
and stay funny and stay relevant when he he doesn't even just
like play the video?
He's like, "Dude, I'm just a DVD player. How the is Chud making
it as somebody who comments on the video. What is happening?
What is it's so confusing?
And in this time we got to address we got him to address the
points that he deliberately avoided in the first video.
Yeah. Yeah. I have no personality. I have no idea how to comment
on things. I have no idea how to make content out of anything.
And the fact that Chud does, well, that's proof he's a snake.
Okay, that must listen. Talent, personality, humor, all of these
things. Marks of a snake. I know them. I see I see the marks.
Okay, I see the marks of a snake. And we got I know them when
I see them. So what else you lying about? Yeah, it's a little
fib. Yeah, it's about a bad person. And what was the lie? H I
know what the lie is. I didn't know. There's a pattern there.
I didn't know. Everything comes down to
I don't know what's going on.
It's crazy, mate. It's insane. I don't know. It's like maybe
Hey, no, that's Yeah, Chad. I think you do know. You're crazy.
You're crazy. You're wonder. You're crazy. your I don't know
much about the star dust um drama. I don't know anything about
it. But from what somebody told me today, that was the initial
excuse there, too. I didn't know.
Wait, there's Stardust drama? What was What's the Stardust drama?
Huh? Chud never knows. That's not Ch on the I see. No, you got
me. I thought you literally thought it might be Chud on the You
heard the Ah, you got me. Until he's forced to talk about something.
Take harmful opinions. take anything where he's actually challenged
on, then it goes into meltdown mode and then he hopes to god
that his audience tries to chase people off the internet. Well,
look, it's just mean facts to me. I really don't care.
Um,
was it I thought the whole thing with harmful opinions was being
like the harmful opinions Chud conversation to me felt like when
I talk to counterpoints or when anybody talks to counterpoints
and he's got to go to like some personal story where he's like,
"Now hold on for a second. I need to detour a little bit here
and tell you a story about when I was a cop in like the eighth
grade." Okay, I I ran I walked the beat between here and the
7-Eleven. Okay, and like he he tells some absurd story that's
like barely related and it's like shut the up and actually argue
your point. Please stop giving me some irrelevant
some irrelevant anecdote I don't care about. Just make your point.
Just say what your point is. Okay.
I I thought the harmful opinions thing was like that where it
was like, dude, can you just say what you mean instead of like
doing this weird pontificating that's going on? I thought it
was that. I thought it was that I didn't get the sense that he
was I thought when him and Harmful Opinions talked they kind
of were mutually okay at the end. It was like oh I know this
got like heated but that was fun.
I thought it was just a good time for both of them. But maybe
not. It's going to happen pretty much now for a long time to
come. Um I'm actually encouraging people to come in here and
hate. Bring it on. Um I'm also encouraging people to find because
here's what I think with the seed I'm planting. I think you're
going to start to see it over time. Tommy hit over a thousand
viewers covering this by the way.
He was going off. Tommy C is in a renaissance right now. Okay,
it's PO. Maybe he's cooking with gas here. He had like a thou
He had over a thousand viewers at some point where I looked at
his stream.
He might be cooking with
Maybe maybe he's right. Chud's a snake and everybody in commentary
is realizing it. All right, Chud is not going to change his ways.
He's going to snake people, say rotten stuff about him and and
and hide behind bands and jokes. He is going to uh he's going
to he's going to see if he has enough cloud capital to go after
somebody and then turn on them. He's going to continue to do
that. And he's also going to continue to present things by both
sides of his mouth. This is stupid, but there's something to
it. It's either stupid or it's not. And if there is something
to it, you got to explain.
1K is cooking with gas for Tommy C. Yeah. What do you mean 1K?
Dude, 1,000 viewers is insane.
Um, dude.
I was just going to say so. Oh, now I know every time Chud talks
me, if he ever talks me and I'm around, I'm just going to immediately
go, "Tommy C was right about you. You're a snake." Look at that.
Credibility attack. Not even referencing a clip. Credibility
attack. What a loser. What a loser. What a loser.
Ch doesn't do that. He just nuanced. It's I actually kind of
love Tommy C. Okay. I actually kind of love Tommy C right now.
He's giving me a to a way to stop Chud from saying mean things
about me. Okay. The second Chud banters with me at all, I'll
just immediately say, "Okay, here's my trap card. Tommy, he was
right. Tommy, he was right. You're a snake. You're a snake. Don't
speak bad about me." That Don't you know we're friends? And that
means you can't say anything mean or or anything mean-spirited
but funny about me. That's what that means. We're friends. Funny.
So, stick around. Um, what do you have any more opinions? Anything
you wanted to get out?
No. No, not for me. I I just want to get into it and get it over
with cuz I just sit through there a lot of stuff. You said this
is like painful.
These people say I suck. All right. Did you send it to me? Did
you send it to me? Time stamp. No, I I don't have the time stamp
though. I thought you did it. No, I don't I never have time.
No, I I gave you the specific time stamp. You never told me to
send you the link. Oh, yeah. Can you give me the link? Time stamp.
It's gonna give me You never send me the link.
Yeah, I know. That's right. Address like men. uh this dude was
was 18 or he got to where he he bounced and the kid was lying.
He was not he was 17. He bounced. There's nothing wrong with
doing that. It just kind of makes you look like a loser. It just
kind of makes you when I No, hold on. Hold on. He's going to
talk about the the little boy thing, okay? He's going to do this
whole thing and he's going to go listen, I'm not saying there's
anything wrong. Like I'm not saying it was wasn't like weird
or like I'm not saying Chud didn't get tricked, but like it's
kind of up, isn't it? But like it's kind of bad. Like I'm not
saying it's really bad and obviously we didn't really criticize
and obviously we don't think he's a but like it was pretty bad
a little bit right. It was a little bit bad wasn't it guys specific
time stamp. You never told me to send you the link. Oh yeah.
Can you give me the link time stamp?
It's going to give me
the link.
Yeah, I know. He's right. You did you did do the time stamp.
All right. Well the time stamp you did I I am not yelling at
you, sweetheart. You are right. You are right. You are right.
ass I am. I send the first video. He says, "Why'd you call me?"
I am okay with you chasing men on the internet or guys that dress
like men. Um, but it does look kind of pathetic. I'll be perfectly
honest. Well, maybe just maybe Tommy just had a nuance take behind
it. There's a nuance take. No, I call it You can't understand
nuance. That's like a problem. Like like I make the first video,
he comes out and says, "Why don't you just call me to put on
my face?" When I'm sitting there saying, "Look, I use your word
catfish." By the way, Willie hates the fact that I use catfish
because he actually didn't bite. So that's that's weird. Well,
for political exper expedience, I'll use the word catfish because
once he found out this dude was was 18 or he got the word, he
he bounced and the kid was lying. He was not he was 17. He bounced.
There's nothing wrong with doing that. It just kind of dude what?
What the
dude? Hold on. Hold on a second. What? There's no way this is
real, right? Hold on. Somebody just sent me this. Is really official
to post. There was full and complete coordination with the
Hold on. Hold on. You know what time it is? You know what? How
does Marco always have the same face on?
How does he always have the same face on? Every time.
every single time Marco gets by the way guys if you don't remember
why this is a big deal uh Marco Rubio came out and stated explicitly
the US had no involvement with this whatsoever.
So the secretary of state for the United States came out and
said no we had no involvement whatsoever and then Israel has
come out apparently an Israeli official has come out and said
actually no no we have full cooperation with the
an Israeli official told the post we presented the American administration
with evidence of Iran's breakthrough towards a nuclear bomb.
There was a full and complete coordination with the Americans.
Iran's armed forces spokesperson went on to accuse Israel of
carrying out like this is just another the like and I don't know
I don't know how people who love Israel support this.
The United States engaged Iran in good faith negotiations to
in what were apparently good faith negotiations to get their
nuclear program back under some sort of like uh shutdown or slow
down some icing of their nuclear program. Right. Israel, an ally
of the United States, an ally that the United States has explicitly
supported multiple times, that an ally that shot down weapons
from Iran when Israel was targeted by Iran. Okay.
Israel's now come out and said, "Yeah, when the US says they
had no involvement, they're actually lying." And when they engage
you in good faith negotiations, they're actually lying. They
didn't do that at all.
That is totally toxic, totally
This is the Jerusalem Post.
Netanyahu thanked Trump by name in the Yeah, it's totally toxic
and totally poisonous to the reputation of your country as any
sort of good faith actor in the world. Like your country is being
set back diplomatically massively.
For no reason.
For absolutely no reason.
It's It's really It's really funny.
Yeah, I know you guys had a a deal with with Iran and Trump pulled
out of it. I know. I know. I know.
I just I don't understand how people support it. It doesn't make
any sense to me. Anyway, it just kind of makes you when you freak
out like this against the water brain, it just makes it look
like you have something to hide. I mean, think about this for
a second. Let's say Chud is I am everything that Chud said. I'm
making things up. I'm completely out of my mind. Um I'm crazy.
I believe in conspiracy theories. I'm CTE damage. Let's pretend
that's the case. Is the normal reaction to Wait, I don't think
I could I don't think I can pretend that. That's way too outside
of the possibilities, Tommy. That's Listen, that's way too far
outside of the poss the realm of possibility. I don't think I
can pretend you're or that you're conspiracy or that you're a
waterbrained boomer. I don't think I can believe any of these
things. That seems un totally unbelievable to me. I you know,
I I can't suspend my I can't suspend my disbelief. Okay.
My god, mate. Oh no. I What's the matter with you? Or is it
[__] you, dude? I was nice to you, man. Off
the off. Unless I really did make an
I mean, that would be the I've been nice to you for months. I've
been sending I've been sending people over here for months. And
you sit there and call me a snake. That's the normal reaction.
Not, "Yeah, you're right about this, but you're not right about
everything else."
yeah. Wait, it's Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
So now the proof that Chud's a snake is that he came out and
said, "Oh, you know what? You're kind of right that I was I was
a little dishonest here. I kind of around here and that was bad,
but everything else I think you're wrong on." That's the sign
that he's a snake. That he's willing to pick out something and
say, "Oh, I actually think you kind of have a point here." That's
the sign that that he's engaging honestly on that point at
Bro, how could you possibly win? Tommy Tommy is like a blind
deaf dumb
bl he's just blind deaf and dumb. He's like a blind deaf dumb
reprobate. I like what what are we doing
No signal Chud sends nothing Chud does can change his mind. He's
just decided this and he's going to carry on with this no matter
what Chud does, right? Chud is probably right that responding
to this in any way makes absolutely no
Who is Tommy C? Yeah, Tommy C is like an old friend of Keemstars.
used to do a podcast with Keemstar and Colossal is crazy. He's
like big in the commentary space a long time ago.
I just I don't understand what Chud could do to make him change
his mind. It seems like nothing. You are so Willie. I've seen
your replies in my tweets. There is not repeating that I'm recorded
over and over is exactly what Chud wants you to do because you
have no mind of your own.
All right, you got
Hold on. Was that Was that chat? We got a live chat replay here.
That wasn't Willie in Tommy's chat, was it? Hold on. Find you.
You're right about this, but you're not right about it. You are.
It's lumpy Willie. Never mind. It's lumpy Willy. Never mind.
Never mind. It's lumpy. In my tweets. There is not repeating
that I'm at [__] over and over. False flag. False
alert. Okay. Not Willy M show, but Lumpy Willie. Okay. Is exactly
what Chud wants you to do because you have no mind of your own.
All right. You got two songs.
No. No way.
There's no way he's this big
dude. Your president's so stupid. Your president's soing stupid.
Exclusive. Brett Bearer spoke to President Trump by phone tonight
following the start of the air strikes. Here's what he said.
President Trump was aware of the strikes beforehand. There were
no surprises, but the US was not involved militarily in hopes
Iran will return to the negotiating table. Oh, okay. Hold on.
That's different. Iran cannot have a nuclear bomb and we are
hoping to get back to the negotiating table. We will see. There
are several people in leadership that are not that will not be
coming back.
Yes, they killed some people in Iranian leadership. Yes, they
did that. President Trump has spoken to PM to PM Netanyahu several
times in recent days. The Trump administration reached out to
at least one key Middle Eastern ally to acknowledge that the
strike was going to happen, but the US was not involved in the
strikes and the goal is getting still to get Iran back to the
negotiating table. Why would they negotiate with you if you This
is crazy.
That's crazy. I don't think they they'll I don't see how they
would. I don't think they could possibly return.
That's goofy. See, that's mean genie.
Yo, so look, I am not going to punish
Last sentence. No, the first sentence it's it literally already
said that they knew the plan here. Like the first sentence I
looked at said they knew the
right? The first sentence said that they were aware of the air
strikes.
You think Iran Why does Iran want an excuse for war?
Oh, sure. Wrong video. Sure. Um, why does Iran want an excuse
for war?
Oh, Trump,
Dude, it's just the whole thing's Okay.
Israel is in complete control. All right. It's up. It's up. They
won. They won. All right.
I mean, let me ask you something. All right. Let's Let's Let's
reverse the whole thing. Let's pretend I am that. There's no
doubt. I can barely wipe my ass, right? Why would he do that?
Oh, also Quimman's in chat. Queman, how do you feel about Tommy
C lapping you, bro? We have like a thousand viewers tonight.
This guy's This guy actually knew. Okay. He knew his way back
to success. That's going to be a thousand concurrent for the
next three years. He actually knew the whole time. He's back.
Tommy's back. Let's go.
If Frank says I'm a bad person, I don't I'm going to be like,
"Wow, that's crazy." You know what I'm talking about. It was
bought it. Oh my god. Quan's in my chat coping right now about
Tommy's totally legitimate
of him and Chud Logic. Thousand concurrent viewers. It's the
Tommy C renaissance. It's on. Let's go. Darn in Australia. You
know that guy. Yeah. I I wouldn't get upset about that. or do
you need people to believe I'm
That's what I do. Yeah. So, he'll just talk about a 25minute
video for two hours, for nearly two hours. He's just an extremely
insecure guy. The only thing he has is his YouTube. He's done
quite well in it and he's protecting his identity at all costs.
The only thing he has is his YouTube. What does Tommy C have
besides his YouTube that Chud
Is it Is it literally just a room full of arcade cabinets? Is
that it?
Ch's only they've both they're both YouTubers. They both basically
have this career that they've built for themselves. Chud's just
way more successful at it in way less time.
I don't Okay. All right. Otherwise, if he was secure, if um if
he was um like actually thrown off by this, if he actually thought
it came out of nowhere, he'd be like, "That guy, dude, I was
nice to that guy." It's not what he did.
This is the second time he's made this argument. Listen,
if I was wrong, would Chud have reacted the way he did?
If I was wrong, would Chud have Would Chud have said, "Oh, you
know what? You're right. If if Chud was not a snake, would he
have admitted I was right in one place and wrong in the other
places?" No. He would have gone, "No, I'm never talking to this
guy again. I was nice to him." I He's like actually unable to
see anybody else outside of the way like him and his friends
operate, right? Like one of them if somebody says something bad
about them, they'll oh, I'm never talking to that guy again.
He can't conceive of somebody who's like, "Oh, you know what?
You kind of have a point there." And yeah, but everything else
I think you're wrong on.
I It It totally eludes him. This concept that somebody could,
you know, engage with a criticism, go, "Ah, you're kind of right
there." And then just keep
He played defense
when defense is apparent. Yeah, defense wouldn't be necessary
if I was that regard. Sorry.
And uh I'm not the only one that thinks it. I'm just the only
one willing to say it. All right.
By the way, I will say that
if there aren't people around Tommy who Tommy's a known associate
with who are like if they're just like sitting here when when
he's clearly implying that like all of these people agree with
him. If they're not reaching out to say no, we don't agree or
saying something publicly to say we don't agree but they're aware
of it. I would just that would be very interesting to me. Okay.
I know if somebody was taking my reputation and saying, "Oh,
you think this?" If somebody's using my name to say, "Yeah, this
guy, me and this guy, they hate we hate you and I didn't have
any problem with that person," I would probably like reach out
or say something publicly. Right? I wouldn't let somebody just
totally misrepresent exactly what I
now. That might happen in private. That might happen in private.
Maybe in private they'll go, "Oh, I don't agree with him, but
I don't want to, you know, I'm friends with him. I don't want
to I don't want to cs out." Right? But if it's not happening
anywhere, well, that'd be interesting. That would be interesting
to me. Uh, the 1135. 113. I got two links from Oh, okay. I'll
take yours instead. Here we go. 3 2 1. Here we go.
I'm expecting Tommy Tons again. Again, again. I'm going to be
doing a super cut. If this is in your bag, you're going to get
a super cut of this later. I am not just re-uploading the whole
thing. And I will be answering them for the next two hours over
a 20 minute video. Um, I mean, I don't really have much to much
to add. There it is again. Tommy having no concept of how you
could possibly stretch a video beyond its actual length. That
he's just never done this. That he basically doesn't have commentary
to provide. That he basically doesn't make comments. He's got
no personality. He's got no intelligent thing to say. He'll just
He's like, "Listen, how the could you take 20 minutes and turn
it into two hours? That's that's totally insane."
Yeah. He's going to be watching it for the next two hours. He
does actually turn it into a 4-hour video by himself, though.
So, let's go. What? Four hours of Tommy C tent. I don't Are I
I
need donations. Okay. I I don't know if I can do this. We are
um What are we 65 away? 65 away. And I,
you know, I can't make any commitments. You know what? Don't
even donate. I'm not going to make a commitment to watching this
whole thing tonight cuz that would be nuts. Okay. That would
be
Oh, that's one hell of a way to start.
First, I'm cool, calm, and collected. I I don't care that much.
Now, actually, if you had just said that, probably the whole
thing would go away. That's wonderful. I know you spoke about
me again. Thank you for the membership. CEO of hell became a
member. CEO of hell celebrates seven months of membership. Chloic
x Black. I trust me, I don't I don't need money to cover. I'm
going to cover this cuz I'm interested in it. Um, but I don't
know how long I'm going to go. If you guys hit that goal, we
can get quite a bit through it. If you don't, we'll get however
far we can.
Thank you for the membership. Set
How does this work exactly?
I did watch this first part. I'm going to speed up a little more.
No, I said you specifically didn't watch it. So to avoid the
issue.
Well, it worked on you better than me. I haven't given into this
[__] yet. You should have ignored it. Why is this
new par?
But what
it's apparently noble to not talk to someone now. What the is
that about the it's
um if the person I mean like I said I would look totally hypocrite
if I called you a snake disingenuous not trustable and then I
trusted you with a private or public conversation. That would
be just stupid. It would actually mean that I don't mean what
I'm saying. I do. There's going to be no resolution here. I absolutely
mean I'm I am absolutely sure in the coming years that this is
going to be undeniable. How am I running? Bro, I still have a
conversation. Bro, I said I will have a conversation with you.
I said I have a conversation. How is that not running? Yes, Tommy's.
I don't want one. I'm like, I don't want a conversation. I don't
care what you do with the video. This is such a weird It is just
bizarre. I I have no idea how to like
how do you comment on this. I totally want to talk to you, but
I I never really want to do I never want to like talk to you
directly. I just want to on you all the time.
And you know, you can respond if you want, but I'll never talk
to you directly, right? Like you can just
he can sit here and he can spit out whatever he wants and like
it's just you know that you'd be embarrassed in front of your
audience if you went talk to Chud. I I also think that they should
get a moderator though because Tommy thinks he's like bad faith.
Just get a moderator you trust, right? I'm sure you'd both agree
to Nicholas moderating a conversation between you guys.
I I doubt Chud would say, "No, no, no. I wouldn't do that. Nicholas
moderating a conversation." Just Just ask Nicholas. He's your
friend. use both of your friends,
right?
Just get a moderator. That's all you got to do. And by the way,
I know Chud would agree to one that's way closer to Tommy C,
right? Chud doesn't need like a moderator who's going to control
the conversation from his end. He just needs somebody who can
like get Tommy C to be comfortable talking without thinking he'll
be, right? Tommy C needs his like his prison. his prison his
prison top. Okay. He needs his like prison daddy to come and
make sure that he's okay in the shower. All right. Chud's very
scary in the prison showers. All right. Tommy C needs his prison
daddy to protect him there. Can we find somebody? Can we find
a prison daddy for Tommy? Tommy. God. I'm not I'm not going to
stop misspeaking. I woke up at like I woke up at like 8 a.m.
this morning. Okay. I'm streaming late at my normal time slot,
but I woke up really early and I'm I'm like mentally I need more
caffeine.
I need more caffeine. Okay, sorry. I woke up really early. I'm
trying to get back into my normal sleep schedule so I can actually
um stream normally. Okay, [__] I keep I keep misspeing
video. I don't care if you watch it. He said you're a coward.
He's [__] completely and totally captured by his
audience. He said you're a coward. Who cares if they called you
a coward, Jud? I've been called a coward for the past 24 hours
in your hundreds of tweets. Wait, did Tommy not notice that it
was Queman who told him to cover it? He cares. You're insecure.
Going insane.
He's on another stream and I'll talk to him right now. I'll talk
to him right now. Bro, why am I going to react to him talking
about me? So, he doesn't want to do it. That's how he started.
Yeah. So, the first video he reacts to, he deliberately avoids
the major talking points, the Bobax lie. Uh, that turns out to
be a lie. And the Turkey Tom thing. He concentrates deliberately
on why didn't you call me, which I never did. I basically said,
"You came along with baggage, and the people you're snaking now
are the same people that were accepted your baggage." Now, my
now famous quote, "Look the other way," which has been twisted
100 times, but fine. That's fine. I'll I'll live with that one.
Why are you mad? I was like, why would you want to talk to someone
that called you a Yeah, you according to you, Chad. Tommy called
you a
Let's be fair to Ch. I inferred a pedophile.
Hold on. Let's be fair to Chad. I inferred that he was a pedophile.
Why did you want to talk to me? I'm completely bad faith. Or
are you bad faith?
To me talking about him after he spoke about my content. It's
ridiculous, bro. I'm not afraid to talk to anyone, bro. I'll
talk to him if he wants. I'm just not going to watch. So, he
bought he got he got totally trolled by He got totally trolled
by his audience. is I already asked him for a debate. I specifically
said that for there would be no debate. No, no, no.
Tommy doesn't want to have a conversation with Chud. Tommy's
maintained that position the whole time. Consistently. Right.
Tom Tommy's consistently said he will not talk to Chud directly.
Chud is the person who's saying yes, I will talk to you. I It
doesn't matter if I'm a snake. You can record the whole thing.
We do it in private. We do it in public. You have whatever you
want. Just talk to me so we can actually have like a conversation
through this. Cuz what Tommy doesn't have what Tommy doesn't
do here is suggest um like alternatives. Like if you think about
that New Year's conversation from any other point of view, okay,
other than you have to protect Turkey Tom and Nicholas Doro because
I love them. If you think of it from any normal human being's
perspective that can see multiple sides, okay, the actual answer
to that is how is it going to look for Chud when he totally disagrees
with the point Tom's making about um about whether or not people
consented or when he totally disagrees in some other point, right?
But he doesn't say anything in that combo, right? when he sits
there and just lets Tommy say or sorry Tom say something he thinks
is is wrong or when he lets Nick say something he thinks is wrong.
How is it going to look when they move forward and the drama
comes out and then people realize oh Chud like actually looked
into this and Chud just like lied to not say to not disagree
with them. Like think about it from any other perspective for
two seconds and you'll understand why Chud spoke up, right? Because
he doesn't want to go in and deal with people calling him out
for for like sweeping for destiny when he knew otherwise.
But Tommy can't do that. He can't think of it from any perspective
other than you need to protect these protect these two because
they're really popular and they're friends with you. That's it.
Because you're a bad thing. Actually, the first one is just in
case you are. Now, I'm 100% sure. I I didn't I never made this
demand. I don't I don't want to know. And from what I understand,
it flips back and forth. I'll do it now to the end. I'll never
do it. Okay.
Never do it. I don't care. I don't like you. I think you're a
bad guy. I think you're stake. And I'm going to keep watching
your content to find out when you get a similar type will take.
We on Will you speak out both sides of your mouth? I I'm going
to make a super out of that one day because it's ridiculous.
What is what are we doing here, bro? This reaction. Just have
a conversation with me, bro. Just have a conversation. It's a
bad thing, dude. I go in a conversation and I have Queen and
Jtock there. Dude, how are you this scared when he What? Dude,
how I go in conversation and I have Queen and Jtock there. I
go in a conversation, I have Queenman and Jtock there. I've only
joined one conversation and that was
listen you can call it like dog piling or something but sometimes
it shut somebody on people will message
people will message him right and just be like hey just so you
know like I want to talk to this person I want to and when people
go on a show the the host will ask do you want to talk to this
guy right do you want to talk to this guy
and if the guy if the person they're talking to says yeah I'll
talk to them
then yeah they'll they'll Oh, but but it's not like Tommy's ever
When has Tommy ever been ambushed? You're totally, by the way,
totally normalize people just going, you know, I don't want to
talk to that person.
At least as creators, don't mock somebody. Don't mock somebody
doing this. Chase do called out. Okay. Well, call out for what?
I don't I've been on Chudstream one time. I was talk to Counterpoints
and make a point that I would make and to anybody else anywhere
forever. That was the infamous counterpoint saying, "I think
gay people lying is just a part of their culture."
That was a funny conversation.
But it's not like Chud didn't ask him. I think Chud said, "Hey,
do you mind if uh JT wants to hop in and talk to you?" And yeah,
he was like, "Yeah."
Anyway, I But I don't understand why that would be snaky.
He literally says, "Do you consent to this?" And then if you
say yes, then you have to deal with consenting to it. How are
you on this scared when he's there with this social audience?
That's pretty. I got to be honest with you, that is apocalyptic.
I'm sure I have parasocial people, but holy holy [__]
That was a nonsense comment from Chud. Okay,
this streamer sitting there with their parasocial audience. It's
like, well, that's literally that's literally every streamer
ever coping about when they're wrong and stuff. That's literally
every streamer ever. Sorry. That is all of them all the time.
I hate to say it to you, okay? That is all of them all the time.
About me refusing to talk to me because he thinks I'm a snake.
Yeah. And also apparently, what was the other thing? He didn't
like how I spoke about him in a video. That's not this. Yeah,
I didn't like Look, like I said before, I don't really care about
the way he spoke about me. I cared the way he spoke about me
because we're friends. And again, I defy you to watch that particular
video and come away with is that the way a friend talks about
you? He says the same things then that he says now.
So, he doesn't want to talk to me. I mean, it's fine, but it's
just pathetic. It's totally pathetic. Just [__] have
a conversation. What's your problem, bro?
On stream. Off stream. You can record it. You can record the
whole thing and be worried about me snaking him or something
like that. It's ridiculous. I just don't want to talk to you
because I think if it's online, it'll be original to the W. It
won't be a legitimate conversation. You show that you came out
of a conversation with awful opinions. You started screaming
like an idiot. Um, you're the gay rider, you're the gay Riddler
when he had a minor difference of opinion to you. And by the
way, I see this all the time in chats as well. You'll bring up
a political point and if one guy in the chat, you the gay Riddler
thing is not meant to be a reputation of harmful opinions points.
If Chud just did that and made no actual reputation of like the
points or disagreed on the points, right, then I think Chud would
say that, which I don't even know if they I don't know how much
they disagree in that combo. I just remember the the gay Riddler
thing is making fun of the way he speaks because it's like pontificating.
It's like can you just make your point like stop stop doing this
thing where you talk in in at weird angles and never get to your
point for like 30 minutes. Just speak plainly. Please speak plainly.
What are you? This is a pattern with you. You can go back to
one of my old interviews. No, Harmful is not upset about it.
I don't want to have a conversation with you. I never asked for
one. I think you want a conversation so you can make this kind
of content farm thing. I'm not going to help you content farm.
I didn't help you do it when Cleman was fishing around slasher
stuff and Willie didn't help you do it. I'm not going to help
you do it enough.
Wait, I bet you did help him do it. I won't bring anyone else
on. It was just me and him. That's it. I'm not going to go pile.
No one else. And here's another thing. Ask yourself something.
What are you going to talk
I'm not having conversation that you're good person. I'm a bad
person. No, you're a bad person. No, I'm not. Okay, who cares?
That's boring. That's boring. And then, you know, if you want
to go this way, everybody's going whether this is a win or a
loss when it's really I just want to provoke. I want No, the
the question is you'll say you're a bad person for X reason.
Okay. And then Chud will say, "Okay, well, who am I a bad person
in comparison to?" Because some of the people you hang out with
probably do the same thing I do in most most of the time. Okay.
So, what Chud wants to do is have the conversation and say, "Okay,
so why do you criticize me over this person?" That would be one
way of arguing like, "Hey, you're not consistent here. You're
applying a lens to me that you don't apply to other people around
you." And that feels
okay. Or he wants to make the argument of, "Hey, you're saying,
you know, when I said this about blah blah." Well, that's probably
not a good one cuz that's probably just objectively bad. But
let's say, hey, you said when I called Tom out in that New Year
stream over the some Destiny, you said I was snaking him. What
should I have done instead, right? Present the counter. Like,
basically, if I didn't do that, what would you rather me do there?
Here's how I see it. What would you rather me do? You explain
with my with my rationale, the things I think of, the things
I optimize for. What would you do in my situation? How would
you handle that differently?
Right?
That's what he's trying. He's trying to walk through one of those
two possibilities. Or he thinks Tommy just straight up lied about
something. But I don't I don't think that's the case. I think
most of it is up to interpretation.
But he wants to have the conversation live because he'll never
get Tommy to go down these these like rabbit holes with him when
if unless they're talking directly
provoke new vision on logic. Even if it's a minority, if it's
10 to 5%, I'll take it. Right. Oh, this is a numbers game. Again,
that if I have somebody that come on here comes on here that
has 100 subs, right? Whether they're right about me or not and
I start everybody goes after them. It's just a numbers game.
I'm not playing a numbers game. You're a commentator. Commentate.
Should I come into the call?
It's ridiculous.
I've got nothing to fear. I've got nothing to hide. I got literally
nothing to hide. Nothing to fear. Neither do I. Why do you spit
it? It's all out there. All my comments are out there in the
open. You can see. I don't understand this. You know what? Do
you mean so do I? Hold on. Wait. If all of your comments If all
of your comments, your friends comments are out there in the
open.
How did everybody know about Boax's dress?
Right. So am I. No, that's the actual snaky behavior.
How did everybody know about that dress?
That's where the actual snake behavior is, right? When you do
this all in back room, all in group chats instead of doing it
out in the open, you have some problem. You're mocking this guy
privately to everybody, right? Probably actually harming his
like business connections, just totally him because he's having
a breakdown. You're not acting like friends. You're acting like
mean girls.
And you have the the audacity to take this guy who makes his
comments publicly and say, "Oh, you're the snake, actually."
No, you're actually the snake. That's you. Shut the up. I don't
understand why you can't just have a conversation about it instead
of the stupid like, you know, talking about each other on our
stream. I think it's a really sneaky thing to do to go and try
to get started on COD's DMs. I think it's a really sneaky thing
to do to um kind of like, hey, Matt, you're crashing out over
here. I think it's really um sneaky to content farm him content
farming friends. I think he's expected the worse than him do.
I think it's a real sneaky thing to do to present Queen and Jtock's
version of of William X video and say, "Hey, they have a point
there." And as soon as Nick Orio tweets that uh Willie did a
good job in his but fiveonone debate, then you completely switch
shift gears. I don't want to talk to you. I I don't even know
why. Why are you listening to these people?
I
Oh man, this just all reminds me that this is like gay and manufactured,
Um these people just played into it for no reason.
I I never even wanted to fight with any of these people. I tried
to rebuild bridges with all of these people and just say like,
"Hey, here's where like where I admit I'm wrong. I want to be
cool. Let's be cool." And they just don't reply. I tried. I reached
out. I tried multiple times.
I now I have now I have to participate because I'm still being
denigrated by this. But I'm like totally fine. Why? I would have
been fine to None of this had to happen. None of it had to happen
at all. Who cares what they think? I don't care what's going
on right now. I wish I could get my uh I can't get this working
for some reason in my chat. I wish you why would you care? I
know you're insecure backwards and forwards. I'm sure he's going
to do another minutes about this as well. Just have a conversation,
bro. Just have a conversation with me, bro. Just have a
What is going on? I don't understand
um
I will say
it's pretty gay of Chud to go, "Oh, you don't have to talk to
me. You don't have to do a debate with me. I'm not asking you.
Nobody has to do that." And now he's sitting here like, "Come
on, bro. You should just talk to me. You should just talk to
me.
That's a That's I don't like that switch up from Chud as much.
Okay. If I had to criticize Chud, I'd say he did a whole performative
thing where he's like, "It's not like you have to talk to me.
I'm not entitled to you talking to me." Which he'd still say,
by the way. But now he's saying, "Just talk to me. Stop doing
reaction. Just talk to me." Like,
it's just just calling it a debate is
especially when nobody's called it a
All this could have been avoided if you just told Willie his
video on Destiny was fantastic.
I I narrowed down my criticisms. I even said, "Hey, I was probably
a little too harsh in that in that uh in that call."
Every every time I sorry, every time I've talked about that in
like a measured way where I admit any amount of fault. Basically,
only those things where I've admitted fault are ever responded
to. It's just used to to try to prove that I'm like wrong.
I don't know. How often is this stupid Civil War mean girl done?
Like every six months, right? I have no idea. No, I have no [__]
idea. What's happened? Can't just have a conversation anymore.
He's never done this. I have no idea. I don't get it. Snake snakes
can't be spoken to. I I just I don't get I don't get why he said
what he said. I don't get why people are complaining. I don't
get why everybody's upset. I don't He never understands. So,
at what point do we sit there and say
you're a fraud? You're in fact the whole Bax thing. I didn't
know. Play dumb. Have somebody call it out. Get angry. It's on
the public. It's on the open.
Stop playing silly buggers and put up the Okay. Okay. So, the
time will watch it. Fine. We'll watch it wins. wins. He's got
one guy,
but he's on one guy, but he's on stream. Actually, if you wanted
to help him out, maybe he didn't.
Oh, I didn't see that one develop over the
thing. Like, was nice. Oh, hold on. Hold on. I'm stealing that
last by his own shrink. You got You got one guy by his own string.
Actually, it was a Greenman if you wanted to help him out. Maybe
he didn't.
Oh, I
I got that developer. I'm going to figure that one out. Okay,
maybe that's the new smartest thing for him to do is like I was
nice to that guy. I'm not a snake. I don't like I think I think
his points although he would have had the Here's what happened.
He deliberately didn't address the points of the first video,
right? He deliberately did it and then he felt the pressure here
cuz I said I I think I I pretty much I didn't care if covered
it or not.
So everybody's like, "Hey, go answer these questions."
Again,
go on. Send it through. Let's have a look.
He's going to be the death of you. Go on. Send it through. Let's
have a look.
By the way, blame me for this cuz I knew we was going to choke.
And he'll cover me again. I promise.
But I'm not doing this again. I'm I'm It's done. I'm not watching
I'm not doing any more of this
Okay. I hate Tommy, but Tommy just keeps winning. Okay. He keeps
winning. All right. I hate him, but he Dude, that's He just He
won. Queen helped him. Chud's helped him. He's back to 1,000
viewers. I don't I hate it. Okay, I hate it. It's like basically
confirming I'm wrong by proxy, but Tommy's back to 1,000 viewers.
He won. Totally. Okay, he's totally not He's totally not a drunken
old
loser sitting in his basement streaming while he eats off of
his wife's dime, right? He's He's totally not. He's totally not
a failed streamer in any way. He's awesome. He won thousand viewers.
He's back.
It's over for Chad. It's over for Quean. It's not over for me
because I I'm I have my different audience from them, but it's
over for those two for sure and Tommy won. Print it, bro. I'm
sick of it. A 20,000 tweet it. Okay. Print it. A 20,000. Tweet
it right now. Todd and Queen devastated. Tommy C elevated after
this if he wants to talk. So sick of it. Two hours and you're
sick of it. Really? We can have a conversation. Okay,
let's make this here. I think you are a
bad faith
backstabbing
that trolls for boy
or whatever the it is. It's okay to be able to be make sure of
that.
H
keeps winning and this is your entire
and I pressured you into this when you could have just went.
That's true. That's all I all I know about Chud is that he tries
for trolls for boy all the time. Okay.
He just He's always trolling for for Okay. That's I
ch Yeah, that's why where That's where the jock the jock the
goes come from. Okay. It's where it all comes from.
I I can't find a single place to rebut Tommy right now.
Oh, except that the backstabbing is pretty much only referring
to the Boax thing. And they were all Bob Blacks behind closed
doors for months.
Like Boax was just already a joke to his entire friend group.
But you know, cuz you're worried. It is what it is. Creamman
is Creamman has won again. Creman's secret tricks against me
have worked. It might have. Probably more than you think.
And of course, Creamman sent it to me. This must Dude, this is
this is probably the what fifth or sixth time you sent me Tommy's
content to react to. Creman. I only had one thing of leftovers.
I'm just picking at it.
All those things you sent me about him. You know what I'm talking
about. Obviously, you know, I know you downplayed it on stream,
but obviously, you know, we know we know what's going on, don't
we? We know what's going on, dude.
Oh, I shouldn't Oh, I should. By the way, I'm probably not taking
calls today. I don't want to leave it lead anybody on. This is
going on for a long time. Oh, I've let the car the B. Oh god.
I totally take calls on this from commentary people, but I don't
have like a stream commentary people could see. Commentary people
only exist on YouTube and I don't think any of them would talk
to me anyway. I'd love to talk to like anybody about this, but
I've I basically just got Queenman. That's like the only commentary
person Aiden maybe like Aiden. Maybe
I Dude, it's all it's so I wish some of the commentary people
who defend Nicholas would come talk about it, right? Not Nicholas,
sorry, Tommy.
There has to be some people defending him, right?
Let the cow the bag.
Oh, true. We do have morale. We do have morale. I will take calls
on this next stream. No problem. I'm not just Auggie. Oh,
that would actually be really cool. Hold on. I should message
Auggie and see if he's around.
I haven't message him in a long time. He wouldn't be here all
night.
Forget the links. It's the novels of psychoanalysts. He psychoanalysis.
He should be worried about
Augie fell off. He's as waterrained as Tommy C. You're wrong.
No, Auggie's awesome. We love Auggie. Get Smaggle.
just let me
keep
Whyized
Ethan Klein like he said he wanted to you know the chains were
broken right
but what happened when he did that he got in a huddle with Nick
and said I can't now I can't talk about it because it will only
create drama
and I'm a coward I thought you had some real nuanced commentary
on how Ethan Klein isn't the greatest person there. Has he covered
that since?
Well, hey Tom, he he said it's boring, so it's fine. Oh, it's
boring now. Yeah. Yeah. Doesn't care after his little sneak disc
of Nick. Now it's boring.
Wasn't the entire context of the sneak disc like, "Hey, this
is so boring unless you're willing to suck off one side or the
other for like eight months in a row." I thought that was like
the entire the entire thing was like all the drama desert. It's
like a drama drama Sahara out here and unless you're willing
to suck off Nick for like months in a row for like the 90th time
or something, right? Like he's literally just talked about how
it's boring for
Oh god, I
never mind. Didn't he tell me in that same video, if you don't
like covering this stiff, which by the way, he's correct. Cover
something else.
like a metronome
to get me homes
broadcasting all I'm see that guy's got a great radio voice
that's me
yo so look I am not going actually if I I would have got the
this the smaller version up but I guess I had to give it to him
this I mean, I I would have got that up, but it was just uh had
some problems with my browser to punish you. Okay, that's one
of 50 minutes of going I don't know.
So, he doesn't even watch my video.
You didn't watch mine. That's not
like That's not what he said, though. Uh that's that's like see
the Shimu Tommy C edit on Twitter. Nope.
No, I I've spent no time on Twitter today. I stuff going on earlier
and um I'm back now. Okay, I'm back now. Shamu YT, has Shimu
posted the Techone logs yet? Has he posted this next video? Shimu,
where's the next video? Where is the video, Shimu?
I was told there'd be more Techone content. I was told a second
Teone was going to happen and it's just I it hasn't come out.
Where the is it? Where is it?
Where is it? Where'd it go? Willies, that's why nobody's gone
on there. You can check into that. You can look into it. Nobody
trusts you. Whether it's just because you're afraid of women.
Okay. All right. Good enough. Good enough. Like not what you
said. You didn't watch mine.
So what? Like how can you use that? I literally start the thing
and I says the
you didn't even watch it. You cherry picked what you wanted to
pick and now he's like, "You didn't even watch mine." Which How
many hours was that? Holy [__] It's the same thing.
What is all this? What is all this about me running scared, right?
Cuz I'm not going to watch his [__] video. Then don't
watch it.
Don't watch it. I told you I don't care if you watch it. Don't
watch it. I don't think he's talking about Tommy's commentary.
I think he's talking about all of his uh everybody in his Discord,
everybody around him calling him a calling for not covering it.
I don't think he's talking about Tommy at all, actually. Oh,
you're audience caption. So, I was right about that, too. Oh,
I guess so. To it by read. Totally. Totally. Yeah, totally. Audience
cap. And he's not even going to watch my response and go over
my arguments. Dude, this is what is so why wrong wrong. Chud's
wrong again. Tommy's right again. Chud's wrong again. Okay. So
easy for Tommy. I'll tell you why I didn't. Because you didn't
go over mine.
You You actually avoided the ones I made it. The turkey tom,
the bobacks. But now you have to do it. It is terrific. Yeah.
Now you have to do it. [__] ridiculous about this
whole thing. He is sat there in a [__] drunken rage
probably presumably, right? Banging on about Isn't that what
he used to say about me when we were friends?
That was just bance, man. It's kind of just the band. But now,
now it's literal, right? No. Oh, now it's just the pants. Or
before it was just the pants. Okay. Credibility attacks. Okay.
Right. Because I said Nicholas Dioro was sucking off Ethan Klein.
Right. All he's done is make credibility attacks against me.
All he's done. Yeah. And I actually provided evidence for it.
Yeah, I do. The evidence is the your pattern of
you. Oh, is anybody shocked that Tommy Tom Tommy can pick up
a pattern of behavior if only Willie Mack possessed the same
capabilities? You don't attack like look I think Eth you don't
go Nicadori are wrong about this. You say he's sucking off and
you don't give an
So I said you dropped to be fair and I listen to be fair and
this would be Chud's argument almost certainly if you if you
aren't a [__] the reason he doesn't give evidence
is because he's not actually trying to do a credible a credibility
attack on Nicholas right it's like it's a throwaway comment that's
meant to be funny for a second and then dismissed the next second
right he might believe there's some under under uh undergurt
of truth there whatever he might believe there's some some evidence
of some kind there like oh but realistically it's just like His
chat makes that joke and so he's leaning into a joke that his
chat makes and and it's funny and it like puts Nicholas in a
bad light for a second. Hey, whatever. Can I get a good night,
bro? Okay. Good night, Ricochet 999. I'll just say good night.
Have a good night. Bye. Drop the blowbacks thing. And my example
was But sorry, Chud's not providing evidence because he's not
doing a video essay trying to character Nicholas Doro who's his
friend. That's why he wouldn't provide evidence. That's why he
was just around.
It didn't make any sense that you didn't know. It doesn't make
any sense. Weman tried to defend you, but we find out later that
it's a lie because Aiden said I specifically told him. I remember
telling him that this was private information.
Then then I'm I don't Uhoh.
Double agent.
We got a double agent over here. Okay, Aiden. Not good. Aiden,
who are you not snaking? You snake. You're snaking everybody
on both sides. Aiden is just trying to prove that he is the most
commentator on Reddit. Okay, on YouTube.
I'm dying. I'm dying. It's too late. It's too late on YouTube.
God, it was such a good joke and now it's
I need to reset. I need I need five seconds to reset here.
God damn.
God damn it.
Yeah, Aiden. Aiden's double. He's got dual loyalty. Okay. To
both sides is crazy. Dual loyalty. Oh, no. For sure. I think
Nick told me told you we're leaving that part out. Alex Gecko,
the guy who was a logging Boback, let that out. So, you make
you you wait for the new year stream, the biggest one, and drop
it. And then when you're called on it, you say, "I didn't know."
Nick immediately says, "That wasn't supposed to come out in the
video in in the stream." Six months later, who gives a Well,
that's my allegation. Point one for me.
Sam, that's that's probably the best point Tommy has is is he
did that to Boax. I'll just continue to say he's listed a whole
bunch of people who knew. Although, I think that Gecko knew because
Bo told him during like a breakdown or something, but uh maybe
not about the dress. In any case, you can only tell so many people
before you're like, "Oh, I'm not shocked that this came out."
Uh, Mooney Morgan, no, it's probably like somewhat sure. I'm
guessing Chud, you know,
I feel like that's a big enough bomb that you'd probably have
a good idea there, but I it's all speculative. I just don't think
that makes him a snake any more than the people who are laughing
about it privately. I'm a snake and acted like I'm some duplicitous
with no evidence. By the way, with no evidence, right? It's no
matter what you say. No matter what you provide, there'll be
no no evidence. Obscene, bro. I'm not making the credibility
attacks. He's making the credibility attacks against me and not
addressing my is Victoria's secret checkout thing already leaked.
Oh, okay. Maybe it wasn't that. Well, sorry. It was like a big
bomb to say it with authority in a group in a chat where like
Nicholas basically confirms it, right?
Okay. Sounds like you've done some some digging into this. So
maybe it wasn't maybe it wasn't such a leap.
In any case, not addressing my Can you believe the balls of this
guy saying not addressing my arguments when his first reply literally
avoided mine? The balls of this guy. That's, by the way, that's
like the whole joke right there. We're gonna pretend we we know
you watch the video. We're gonna pretend not to watch it. Um,
like you pretended not to see
bro. The bridge is already gone. The bridge is already gone,
you know. Good. Tommy C got by Queening so hard. He's put about
75% of that on to me. Right. By the way, I just want to point
out when we were friends, that was the band. He said that, too.
So, what's the difference? Now he's
He said what? He said, "Wait, what?" That too, right? By the
way, I just want to point out,
but 75 I What is he even talking about here? Now, when we were
friends, that was the band. He said that, too.
So, what's the difference now? He's
He said that before.
So, what about now?
Sounds like Chud was consistently making fun of Tommy. Ch consistently
was super nice to Tommy. Like way nicer than Tommy had earned
at all. Like way way nicer.
Or like no JK. And you No, no, no, no JK. No, this is like that
was Queen M you. He said this several times before. JK. Now there's
no JK. So what? So I was right. You meant it.
Again, I can I can already explain that to you. That was basically
over whatever gay ops they were doing, right? Whatever. Not gay
ops. Scops. Sorry. I know that's gonna upset Queman if I say
gay ops. The scop that Queman's group did there on Tommy trying
to make him trying to make everybody think he was a
and Chud would have heard about that and Chud would have tongue-in-cheek
referenced that laughing
cuz that's all he does. He would he would not really be aware
of it. That's what he calls banter. Now you could say,
okay, it's really up to call that banter, right? You could say
that.
You could say that, but I I don't know. It's goofy. It's just
goofy to like to take it that seriously. I don't know. Whatever.
It's like he's been seething. He's been seething about all these
different issues for months and said nothing to me and said no.
Yeah, cuz I thought you were a snake. I was right. You're duplicitous
snake.
Single word to You even frame this [__] you even
snakily frame this video. You didn't You didn't cover my You
didn't cover what I talked about. You avoided what I talked about.
me, bro. We last spoke six months ago and I said to him that
the slasher stuff was overblown and to look over my coverage
and if he didn't agree with it, let's go over what he said
if he hasn't blocked.
Why don't you want to check that out? Wait, what do we got?
By the way, this totally like fainted ignorance. I don't believe
for a single second that Tommy didn't watch this ahead of time,
right? watch like the whole stream and meticulously plan out
exactly how he was going to respond, including whatever clip
he's going to bring up. Now, I I have nothing to base that on.
That's just mindless. That's just me, you know, tapping into
the schizosphere. Okay. I have nothing to to base that on. I
have no basis for it whatsoever. I just feel like that's probably
what's happening here. Let's see. Read this. Hey man, we got
a good Christmas. Aiden Queen were talking about the statements
in regards to slash pretty many DMs. Huh. Some inconsistencies
came up in regards to the order of DMs and has some impacts regards
to what happened. So he's already made a decision on it. He's
not even saying Aiden, Arclene, and Queen are talking about the
statements regarding Face. Some instances came up in the Order
of the Dams and has some impact in regards to what happened.
Would you be interested in hopping on the stream? Well, here's
the thing. He didn't say they said that. He said he said that.
So it's definitive and I knew I knew right there and then. Now,
this is coming right off the kel stuff and right off the like
Tommy, don't you have a wife? You should be talking to Keel.
So I knew I
Oh, cool.
Audio is right. So here's the part that he's leaving out the
next day. I called Vicki or I basically said, "Is this you got
you got muted for a second?" Yeah. For a bit. How long? How long
muted me? 25 seconds. Yeah. 25 seconds. All right. Let me start
again. Yeah. Yeah. Let's start again. Go over the DMs. He's talking
about I hope you had a good Christmas. Aiden talking about statements
in regards to SL DMs. Some inconsistencies came up in regards
to the order of the which has some impact in regards to what
happened. Now he's saying that definitely. He's not saying, "Hey,
um, Aiden Queen now." He's just saying that. Would you be interested
in hopping on stream tomorrow to talk about this some point or
in the next few days or are you busy? I didn't buy this. I didn't
buy it at all. A couple days later, I saw Anthony. Good thing
I didn't go on there. Here's what he writes later. Hey, looked
at over on stream today. It was over criticism. I don't think
we need to talk to you on stream about it, but if you look it
over, it has it has any issues. Let me know. Here's what he didn't
tell you. I called Nick and I say, is this guy with Nick? And
then the next day, I get the message. Nick told me that look,
cuz I was like, is this guy [__] me? He's like, look,
I don't think so. I'll talk to him. And then the tone change
came and then we were done. So, he's leaving one thing out. Hey,
I put these I did this thing and it was totally I shut it down.
Yeah. When they called you and I smelled a rat, hence why I won't
talk to you. I don't think you're good. Fake. I think you're
efficient. This is a very similar conversation that I had with
Billy Matt.
Okay, hold on. I looked away for like 30 seconds there.
There's no way he's making the point again again that you're
the snake because when I called the cabal together and got all
of their opinions on whether or not you're a snake, we kind of
agree that you're sort of a snake.
There's no way that he keeps making this argument. Here's what
he writes later. Hey, look over on stream today. It was overblown
criticism. I don't think we need to talk to you on stream about
it, but if you look it over, it has it has any issues. Let me
know. Here's what he didn't tell you. I call Nick and I say,
"Is this guy [__] with Nick?" And then the next day
I get the message. Nick told me that, "Look," because I was like, "This
guy with me." And he's like, "Look, I don't think so. I'll talk
to him." And then the tone change came and then we gone. So he's
leaving one thing out. Hey, I put these guys to this thing and
it was totally overwhelming. I shut it down. Yeah. When Nick
called you and I smelled a rat, hence why I won't talk to you.
I
Oh, so he's saying that like basically Chud was trying to farm
him. Chud was trying to like make a law cow out of him again.
And then Nick's Nick checked in and Chud was like, "Oh, don't
come on stream anymore." That's what he's saying. That basically
when when Nick
when Nick intervened and asked Chud about it, Chud was like,
"Oh, it's uh it's fine. Don't come on stream now." Wait, did
he go over it on stream and change his opinion progressively
over time? Wouldn't Isn't the answer just in whatever Chud's
VOD is? Isn't Isn't there like an answer like a totally knowable
answer there on why he might have changed his opinion?
Would he have talked through it with other people? Don't think
you're good fake. I think you were fishing. This is a very similar
conversation that Chad had with Billy Matt. Hey, look like trash
now, buddy. You want to come on and talk about it? It's content
farming. He's content forming his friends. My argument, it's
not trustworthy. He's not a very good friend. And considering
again, he's saying the same about me that he said when he was
my friend. I kind of think he meant it. Okay. And that's fine.
I just don't want to be friends and talk. I don't want to be
fake friends. I want to do this mean girl [__] I
like what Queen does. I like Queen. He's a bad faith bastard.
He'll over anybody get by YouTube. He's never going to help his
friends. Um, and he's never los back for him. That's quote. All
right. And my here's what I want to tell you guys right now.
So wait, did did Queman say that about sub toman right now because
here's the thing, he's going to give it to you straight. If that's
the kind of stuff you want, if you don't want the fence riding,
if you don't want somebody to sit there and beat around the bush,
sub to Queman 100%.
He's a [__] honest liar. And if that's what you want,
Chud is a dishonest liar. Chud is a phony. So that whole thing,
I So I don't necessarily agree with very much of this, but I
do really love the spirit of it that he's just basically going
to go and try to drive a wedge between these two people as hard
as he can, right? This relies on Chud having like a massive ego
where he would like sort of look at Queen, see Queen like Queen's
numbers advancing, and cut Que's legs out, right? I don't think
that's going to happen. I just can't I can't see that. Um, but
okay.
Uh, okay. Yeah, I I don't know. I saw it on stream. You were
trying to trap me on stream with Creamman and Aiden. Sorry. Sorry.
I don't think Chud will do that to Queen. I don't I don't think
Chud I don't think Chud would say I don't I don't think he'll
get like um personally insecure and try to cut Queen's legs out.
So, this could work on
somebody more adjacent to Tommy, maybe. I just don't think it's
going to work on specifically. I won't talk to you. Let's go
on. Right. Then he can talk to me about it. That's the last time
we spoke. He's not said a single thing to me says and apparently
he's got all these issues with things I've said. It's [__]
deranged. It's [__] deranged, bro. Isn't having issues
with That's strange to have issues with what you said. Isn't
that what you do all day? It's totally ridiculous. I mean, what
is going on? And apparently there's others that have got problems
with me. I don't know if it's group chats. I don't know what
it is. Maybe people venting. Maybe No, that's not me. I hate
group chats. [__] talking to me, whatever.
And obviously it puts me in a difficult I don't talk to you in
group chats. I go right to the source and I say, "This guy's
no good." And here's why I think it. Just be clear position because
I'm not a snake and I don't want to start leaking DMs unlike
Tommy C who decided to leak a bunch of Nicholas Dioro DMs over
a green green green Eminem woman or whatever. How many DMs have
I leaked of any of the commentary guys? How many DMs have I leaked
of anyone? How many Ch has proved out a shadow of doubt that
he is a better person because he hasn't leaked DMs. Well, I guess
they didn't. I guess they I guess they didn't give you tons of
content like the Bobax dress.
I didn't leak any DMs. I didn't leak any DMs. Yeah, because of
what I did for it. Yeah, I leaked fix DMs. Everybody knows why
I did it. He told me he was gonna He told me he was going to
make a video on me. I I took that as a threat and I acted accordingly.
And you know what? I stayed away from him and I didn't bring
up his name after that because I wanted nothing but the best.
After a couple months, we made it up. I think Nick got bad mad
at me and overreacted. I think I overreacted and we patched it
up. I don't think you're overreacting. I think you're
times have I leaked DMs from any of the commentary guys. How
many? How many? You're a better person than me. How many? Zero.
Zero.
Defend Tommy C. No [__] zero. her room. Everybody's
just sake. I never broke the gold rule. I never I never broke
the gold rule. You know, it's funny you bring up the golden rule
cuz that theme stars thing. I'm hearing the same thing. Conspiracy
theorist. You're stupid. You don't know what you're talking about.
You're lying. All this other stuff. It's almost like breaking
up with all over again. Zero. The answer is zero. How many times
in the future at this time am I planning to leak DMs? The answer
is zero. You're a better person than me. I've got no plan to
leak any DMs. And obviously when this drunken when somebody's
going to tell Chad how many times Nick has leaked DMs, probably
more than me. I'm glad he did. By the way, I'm glad he did. I'm
glad he did. Tom call him, man.
That's right. Nick just called him several multiple calls. I
know. Several calls. Whoa. I don't know. Ch. You may have to
disavow Nick on that. Yeah, I don't know. I mean, don't give
me this good person. He would leak something on anybody if he
thought it benefited you, which by the way is my whole argument
and my first title. I don't trust this guy.
Uh, I don't think that's true. Is it? I think Chud's had stuff
to leak before that he's not leaked explicitly.
Didn't he have for like a long time the um the like Molina DMs
with the Lawrence other thing? Oh, wait, hold on, hold on, hold
on, hold on. Wait. Is that Wait, does Tommy see missing a massive
part of the puzzle? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Is he missing
a massive piece of the puzzle? Wasn't it Chud Logic? Who?
I guess. Yeah, sorry. Sorry.
That There's two ways to look at that, Tequila. Okay, there's
two ways to look at that. One option is Chud had a falling out
with Destiny and he never leaked the Lord and Southern thing
even though he could have and totally with Destiny, right? Destiny
was saying, "Oh, you're a total piece of maybe I won't maybe
I won't collab with you anymore." He was treating him like little
bro. He's he's being a total to Chud, right?
Um he could have published that stuff.
Well, sorry, but he is sorry. Chud is the person who sort of
popularized it. Be very vivic.
Um, but yeah, I I don't know, man.
There's two ways to look at that. One is, yeah, Chud could have
published it to with Destiny when Destiny was with him. Or, uh,
maybe Chud held on to it for as long as he felt he had to, and
then he leaked it at a different time. He leaked it during the
Mr. Girl stuff, which is
I don't know. I think he leaked it after like 10 hours on stream,
12 hours on stream. But I do remember the um
wasn't the argument wasn't the argument suspiciously similar?
I don't think it's the same, but the argument was suspiciously
I've been streaming forever. I didn't mean to say anything. I
I don't even know what I'm saying. I don't know. Somebody get
me Tommy's clip from the beginning. I don't even know where I
am. I don't know what's going on.
I don't trust my logic anymore. That's it. Yeah. Now you're sitting
virtue signaling over I don't leak the ounce. But that wasn't
a leak. Um, it was like a highlevel person confirming it from
sort of around Destiny, right?
He had Molina's DMs because of that. Oh, sorry. He didn't have
the Mina DMs first. Okay. So, he just heard that behind the scenes
cuz it was obvious from I'm sure he heard it from you or whoever
else screaming because it was just straight up like proven out
as fact, right? So, he probably knew it. Yeah, he almost certainly
knew it, right? It was I forgot the timeline there.
Uh, counterpoints helped Chud perpetuate this. Okay. Counterpoints
came in as a friend of Lauren and totally confirmed it. Yeah,
100% confirmed it, which is, you know,
great job, Counterpoints. Okay, now here's the thing. No, no,
never mind. Never mind. I don't want to be skitso right now.
By the way, I don't think there's one commentator. I don't know
who's leaking more than Nick. And we're talking full-blown phone
calls, by the way. I think he should. I think there's a time
and a place. I'm not this gold. That's I didn't want to say it,
but god damn. Yeah,
Nick leaks everything to everybody. How about that phone call
where um
what did what did Nick Nick Lee Chug's name with regards to something?
It's just like, bro, shut the up.
Shut the How how is Tommy making this criticism of Oh, I whoops.
Whoops. I wasn't thinking straight. I wasn't thinking correctly.
How is he making this criticism of criticism of Chud and not
making it back to Nick at all?
It's a little goofy, but golden rule guy. I know you're going
to play games. I'm the golden rule and nobody's going to trust
you. No one trust me.
I didn't even know Chad when I leaked this damn.
What did he leak on Nick? I just I went on stream and said, "Look,
this guy threatened me. Here it is. Uh, we're going to have to
set uh we're going to have to split up." That's it. And by the
way, I didn't follow up and then we cooled off.
You know what it tells me. You know what it tells me too? That
he's panicking right now and he wants Nick the way I am. I don't
think you're going. Veteran [__] is sat there. Veteran
I here's something. This is This is something I absolutely can't
prove. I always thought he had problem with troops. I got that
vibe playing Fortnite with him one night when he made a couple
weird comments.
CT riddle veteran [__] is sat.
I did. I vibe I love I'm not feeling so I don't care if you respect
me because I'm a veteran or not, but I did get I have gotten
the vibe a long time ago um that that he has an issue with vets.
Absolutely. Like a veteran. What was that? Anything? Did the
army do it to me? Did the army make me more army or am I the
best person to join the army? Yeah. Roping other people into
this, right? And it's talking about what this person is saying
or what that person is saying. It puts me in a difficult position
because I don't want to start leaking DMs. Leak my DMs. All right,
don't leak your DMs.
Oh, no. Damn, we don't. You're breaking the golden rule. I'll
make your DMs. They're nothing. Here you go. Care about leak
DMs. Like, give me a [__] break, dude. Stop the like,
calm down, dude. Really? Here we go. Discord. Here. I think it's
like brings up Nick. Where's all DMs? You're showing you're showing
the wrong [__] one. All right, I'll probably read
that up there, too. There's Ch. Here you go. Zoom in. No. [__]
it. There's [__] him. I think that's the biggest
[__] weirdest thing to kind of like cry about when
like like he licked your DMs like it's like the ultimate DM phone
called and by the way I don't have a problem with it actually.
You tell me something here's my golden rule. You tell me something
private and something different in public I'm leaking your DMs
100%. Only want to call out good dishonest dishonesty. I am so
tired of pretending has fair. Thank you. That's what I want people
to understand. I want people to see Chud in a different light.
I do not expect to win. I know like what's happened to me over
the past one um 24 hours is Chud's ultimate nightmare. It's Decker's
ultimate nightmare. It's women's ultimate nightmare. They don't
know that I've done this before and I'm perfectly comfortable
with it. It's just text. It's just text. I don't like it when
it's tech from people I like or people preferred to be my friend
or allies with. That's when I don't like it. That's when it me
off. Otherwise, yeah, you can say what you want about that. So,
whatever you want. I don't care. It's up to you. I don't want
to start leaking other people's DMs. I don't know what involvement
other people have got. Did I say Decker's name wrong?
Oh. Oh, yeah. By the way, that one I want I want I want I want
to throw this one at you. I I I've seen you riding both ways
to see the way it's going to break, whether it's like because
you were a little nervous it might break in my favor and I saw
you say nice things to me about the technicals thing and um I
don't know if you're being sincere or not. I'm pretty sure the
community come from pretty much demands that you are being serious.
But let me tell you something. If for some magical reason um
this breaks against him and it won't cuz I just simply don't
cut the numbers. It's just it's a math game at this point. I
still will have nothing to do with you forever. I don't buy your
one iota. I think you're a wave rider and if I was on top right
now and I had more people in my camp, you would be sucking
Just wanted to let you know buddy, I'm the one to lead DMs. But
obviously if people are characterizing my interaction in certain
ways
holy
totally.
That was Did he just call him diggers? Is that like a
I you know me personally I hate diggers. So you know how it is,
right? I think that's what he said. I think that's what he said.
Jesus Christ. Can you Can we be chill? Can we be What is he doing?
Love just hate diggers. Okay.
I shouldn't lean into that too much. Okay, we're chill. We're
chilly
to leave for me, don't I? I just
Wait, what? I What even got leaked? Sorry. I was away for a little
bit longer than I expected. I uh I need to get water and use
bathroom.
I can't leave the DMs because then it's like look. Oh, so he's
he's Oh, he's saying he's got the guns on me then. Is that what
he's saying? Nathan, he's leaking the DMs, but then I've just
got to have Well, he's got nothing on me. My interaction is mischaracterized.
I don't think so. So, what I'll say is this. So, what is he saying?
Oh, he sound like he's a better person.
Okay. So, what stand about them? I'm happy to have a conversation
with people on stream if we've got a disagreement about something.
I understand my community can be obnoxious and annoying and if
they don't want to do that, I don't care about that. I encourage
them to do what they're doing now. They're ending the chat right
now. I don't care. I don't care. I'm not We're not moderating
it. Nothing. I don't give a This is a long-standing policy over
Somebody did wear towers or something like that. Probably there
is a limit, but I mean this People are spamming a lot of what
appear to be gorillas in this chat. Gorillas, orangutans, gorillas,
orangutans.
Okay. All right. All right. Cool. You
# Tommy K. This is These people are kind of unhinged a little
bit. These people are a little weird. Not going to lie to you.
These people are kind of a little off. What the I will offer
to have a conversation private and say that the other party can
record it. That is the snake. Like what what what could come
with that conversation? Apparently that I've been participating
in reaching out to someone and going if you want to talk privately,
we can do as well and you can record. But I don't like you. That
is the
I'm pretty sure this is you know Tommy C is sort of he looks
sort of like an ape. So I think all of these monkeys being spammed
in this chat are a coded form of support for Tommy C. These are
all two true blue Tommy C fans in the chat, right? I think that's
what's going on here. He's just getting overwhelming support.
I don't care if you do. I if if Speaker Queen or any of those
guys call me a coward, it really you guys me it's just look if
I was lying if I was being the brain that's the next word. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
Why is Queean organizing
ladders in Tommy C's chat? Why is Kqimman explicitly organizing
and deploying his insane fan base to do ladders in Tommy C's
chat? Are you guys seeing this? This is this is blocked by my
chat right now. This is explicitly Queman Quimman the the
streamer Queman
live is coordinating ladders in Tommy C's chat actively right
now.
right at this very well sorry as of a couple hours ago that's
up dude session right that's that's that's what coming next I
would be like like I am now like oh I'm a coward right that's
not you you're freaking out chud
absolutely
those are Chud guys
we've already fully established that you totally Jedi mind trick
Chud into covering whatever you want him to cover you probably
Jedi mind trick him into telling his chatters to come and do
any ladders in Tommy's chat let's uh let's be real Mihawk is
a hater Yeah, that's because you soped him into being a hater.
Obviously, you think we don't know how this goes. Do you not
understand that I am fully informed on how to maintain a conspiracy?
Okay. You do something that works against your interest, that's
because you're manipulating people. You do something that works
in your interest. Yeah, it's cuz you're manipulating people.
Okay. I You think I don't see this? You think I can't run this
narrative? I I'm very experienced. Okay. Behind the scenes interactions
directly to the person involved in a single go honest.
Where's that? Such a snake. Okay, I got 15 minutes. I don't know.
Qu's in the chat. Do you want to come talk about this for a minute?
Cuz I feel like I've gotten I feel like I've heard his response
to almost everything Chud's going to say already. He's like sort
of walked those out. I don't think I'll get a lot unique from
going through the whole video, although I probably will. If you
want to hop in for a little bit. I'm just, you know, I'm here.
I don't know how much longer we're going. So, here I'll hop in
the the chat for a little bit here.
If I'm such a Yeah, he loops like crazy. Well, I'm guessing he
pre-watched a lot of Chud's stream before he went and did this,
right? So, I'm guessing that what we're actually going to get
here is him going over the same points over and over and over
and over again.
What's up? Hey, how's it going? Oh, did you I thought I thought
you said it was a n I got it. I got it. Don't do that. You'll
be timed out. Don't do it. I think kickshot's getting right now
anyway. Seems like it's kind of falling apart. Awesome.
What can you do? What can you do?
Yeah. I Okay, so what are like the the primary points here? I
think the the primary points have got to be uh the Bolex call
him talking to Tom. What? So I missed it or I didn't ask my chat
even I can't remember from the first video. His turkey Tom thing
wasn't Chud calling him out on the cons the Molina consent or
sorry the pixie consenting argument, right? and saying Molina
didn't. It was something else. What What else did Chud call out
on that video?
Oh, sure. Morgan, that's probably true. Revenge thing or about
the community as
It was It was like Chud pressed Tom on something. Oh, it was
that they were scared of DG, right? Yeah, I think that was the
thing he called, but that I don't think that was like the hardest
press he did at all. I think that was him kind of [__]
and the Molina pixie thing and um
there was uh
yeah and
what else was in that chat? Um
it it was just saying come on. Obviously it wasn't consensual.
Obviously that that's what Tommy's car about.
Um, oh, did he eventually get to that part? Because I think in
his first video, he really didn't mention the of course it wasn't
consensual. And to me, that was like where he pressed way harder.
And so the point I made the point that I made about that just
now or a little while ago, I don't know if you heard it, but
it's like literally the only way you could be upset about that
is if you can only see things in a world where you're like where
you base everybody's value on how nice they are to Nicholas Dario
and Turkey Tom, right? Like when you don't have any view of how
like Chud looks in that stream if he allows that to happen and
says nothing and then it comes out that he knew about it, right?
Yeah. Like like that's the only world you have to operate in.
And if you can see it from any other person's perspective, you
don't get mad at Chud for pressing there. At least not on the
on the Oh, I we don't know. They all have to No, Jason, you don't
understand. They they Nick and Tom decided that it was staying
quiet and they weren't going to say anything about it. So, everyone
has to adhere to that.
I like Yeah. I don't understand the way he talked about it either
where he was like they didn't want to give Destiny notice at
all. It's like what do you mean give Destiny notice? Already
talking about it. What? Well, the only reason any of them knew
knew what was happening was because straight away straight away
was sharing the DMs around. That's why Chud knew. That's why
Nick knew. Yeah. Like it was already What do you mean tip Destiny
off? What the does that mean?
Uh yeah. I Well, and also like it's not like Chud had information
or his opinion was based on anything outside of
like he might have had some idea there, right? That the the DMs
were surely non-conent. But like I think he probably would have
had that opinion as a lot of people would have had that opinion
as I had that opinion, right?
I think you and I had that opinion and I don't think we were
privy to any of this information that Trader was leaking the
DMs, right? you I Yeah, you and I stated that opinion multiple
times. Like although although we don't know for sure, like it
seems almost certain that there there's no way he had full consent
of all these people to share the [__] Yep.
So, so yeah. Anyway, Chud Chud could have had that. It tips nobody
off to have that position basically. And yeah, I think it's just
totally fine to press on that.
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know how you make any other
argument.
the Bowax thing. The the kind of counterpoint to the Boax thing
is, okay, so Chud's the snake for making the joke in public when
you guys basically trashed Boax's reputation to his entire community.
All sharing this dress photo around in the background cuz Connor
screenshotted it or some [__] from the gender vlogs
that Boax is sending him. And you're like sharing this picture
around between your little groups. That's Well, I didn't know
it was Auggie,
but I I definitely that was my point here is like I think you
I think you guys are like freaks for trying to defend trying
to like trying to moralize Chud Logic leaking that when you were
all on this guy for the same thing behind the scenes. It's like
dude, you shared that picture around more than Destiny shared
his wife's like non-conensual
non-conensually shared his wife's to people. Okay, it just wasn't
even a bit like I was saying earlier, it wasn't even a big leak
at that point because everyone already knew Bob was non-binary.
Everyone had seen that he was trying to order all the stuff from
Victoria's Secret. Like there was so much. It was already all
there and all Chud said was there's a photo of him in a dress
that exists. That's but that's it. That was the only piece of
information that was revealed. Yeah.
And we all wish that that's where it stopped, right? We all wish
that it stopped just leaking that he had a dress picture on.
Also, he says like a million times across the stream, he keeps
going, "Oh, they wouldn't have found the Only Fans if Chad hadn't
leaked that." And at the very end, one of his [__]
co-hosts is like, "Oh, just say that there's no way that could
be true because they found it from Boax leaking his emails on
stream." And then Tommy keeps trying to defend it for like another
minute. And then he goes, "No, no, seriously, there's no way
it could be true." And then Tommy finally conceds on it after
saying it the entire stream for like five hours.
Yes. So yes, the Bobs thing. Bobs.
Uh, fun fact, Tommy C cannot say Bobs. He is incapable. Totally
incapable. Okay. Uh, all right. Are we Are we good here? People
in chat seem to think I missed something. Did I miss something?
No, I thoughtful opinions. I don't hear anything cuz something
happening. I'm just looking up what I I'm just mentally I'm mentally
that you've not seen Saving Private Ryan for a star and I've
just been thinking about all the movies for the last 10 minutes.
I've not been paying much attention. I don't know who Tommy C
is.
He hasn't seen it. I know. Like I don't know what's wrong with
him. I I thought the whole joke there was that. Um Okay. No,
I can't press this. I can't press this. I'm confused.
Sorry. Go ahead. Okay. Sorry. Uh do you want Kelly? Do you don't
know anything about Tommy C? You want me to explain what's going
on to you? Uh yeah, sure. TLDDR would be good. Okay, so Tommy
C is a guy who had a community, this SFCP community that was
like early commentary, like proto commentary community. He had
like Nicholas Dero come up through his community, a couple other
people who are quite big now. And yes, Tommy C is related to
Keem. Tommy C was one of the hosts of the show of LoCal Live,
right? Okay. Who's talking? Okay. Yes, I understand that Panda
the Gray. I understand. Okay. Okay. So Tommy sees one of the
hosts, one of the hosts of Lai Live with Keemstar was pretty
popular show, but his own YouTube channel apparently wasn't doing
that well. Hasn't been doing that well for a while and he's really
tight with a lot of these people, a lot of the commentary people.
Okay, so he's in a lot of group chats with Willie Mack, uh, Nick
Dioro, a couple other people, and he started calling out Chud
Logic, saying Chudlo Logic's a snake. Chudlogic actually tries
to backstab these people. Chud had a stream where he he kind
of came out and sort of poked fun at Nicholas Dario for riding
Ethan Klein, right? And Chud thought it was in good fun. Chud
was trying to banter. And it seems like some of the commentary
people took it a little more seriously. One of one of Nick's
friends accused Chud of being Americans having no sense of humor.
What a surprise.
Yeah, basically. Okay. And so basically Tommy C did a couple
streams talking about how Chud's a snake. Chud said he wasn't
gonna respond. he wasn't going to look into it at all. And then
eventually Chud decided, you know what, this guy, I'm going to
actually review his whole stream. So Chud went and reviewed his
30-minute stream, turned into a 2-hour stream. Tommy has now
turned that into a 4-hour stream. We skipped the 2-hour stream
from Chud. We're watching this 4hour stream, which is them going
back and forth on it. Okay, so this is this right here is Chud
reviewing this stream. And then this is Tommy. We're on Tommy's
stream reacting to this in real time. Oh, also I need to fix
my OBS one. So it's like a bunch of Americans being oversensitive
at what a British person
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Okay. We're ready. We're ready.
And my example was it didn't make any sense that you didn't know.
And it doesn't make any sense. Quan tried to defend you, but
we find out later that it's a lie because
Queman didn't try to defend Chan this in the moment. So, this
is about the Bo Black's dress comment. So, one of the criticisms
that he makes, Kelly, again, I was didn't get specific on this.
But one of the criticisms Tommy C makes is that on some New Year's
stream, the one you're referring to actually, the one with Chud
and Turkey Tom and Nick Dioro that on that stream, Chud basically
leaks that Boax has a picture of himself in a dress that got
leaked online, but was leaked in the commentary community more
or less. Okay. And so they're calling Chud a snake for that as
well. Yeah. Yeah. So, um, wait, everyone did content on Bolex,
didn't they? Yeah. But it wasn't fun of him. The argument they
made was that Yeah. The argument they made was that it was not
public yet. Uh the argument that I've heard Queen make back to
this is basically at this point Bob had said he was non-binary.
Boax had had a leaked stream where he had a Victoria Secret checkout
on his uh on his browser. So like some people had joked about,
oh well I guess you're wearing dresses now. And Queen made this
joke to him. And so when Chud said it, some people didn't know
it was real, but Nick Nick did kind of come in and just say,
oh, I thought that wasn't we we're not supposed to make that
public or something. And then they just kept going with the stream.
Did um people hate Boax before that? That's why I don't get Did
they like him before that? People kind of like Boax. Yeah, Boax
had his own charm. They didn't really love him. Oh, okay. Cuz
I would assume if you like someone, you probably wouldn't have
rinsed him as hard as they did. I mean, you were doing a braiding
and
No. Yeah. No, once once that happened, it was like Yeah. It was
over. Yeah. Once that happened, it was over.
Yeah, just curious.
Uh, okay. Anyway, so yes, that is what's happened here. Aiden
said I specifically told him I remember telling him that this
was private information.
Then then I'm I don't know for sure. I think Nick told me told
you we're leaving that part out. Alex Gekkmo, the guy who was
a logging boax let that out. So you make you you wait for the
new year stream, the biggest one, and drop it. And then when
you're called on it, you say, "I didn't know." Nick immediately
says that wasn't supposed to come out in the video in in the
stream. 6 months later, who gives a Oh, I see. So Tommy was actually
Well, that's my allegation. Point one for me. Is say I'm a snake
and acted like I'm some duplicitous
with no evidence, by the way. With no evidence. Right. It's No
matter what you say, no matter what you provide, there'll be
no no evidence. Obscene, bro, I'm not making the credibility
attacks. He's making the credibility attacks against me and not
addressing my arguments and not addressing my Can you believe
the balls of this guy saying not addressing my arguments when
his first reply literally avoided mine? The balls of this guy.
That's by the way, that's like the whole joke, right? So, the
first time Chud responded, the first time Tommy did a stream
on him, Chud just said like I'm not going to take it seriously,
but here's why I like like I watched it, but I here's why I like
I dis like I disagree, but I'm not going to do a react and try
to blow this up. And Tommy didn't like that. I think Chud also
missed one of the criticisms in responding and that was uh quite
upsetting for for Tommy right there. We're going to pretend we
we know you watched the video. We're going to pretend not to
watch it. Um like you pretended not to see mine. Bro, the bridge
is already gone. The bridge is already gone. You know, good.
Tommy C got mine by Queening so hard. He's put about 75% of that
on to me. Right. By the way, I just want to point out when we
were friends, that was the band. He said that too. So, what's
the difference now? He's angry. He said that before. It is really
funny how Quimman has this like AoE like ability to make everyone
like around him mad at them rather than mad at him. It's like
whatever Queen does gets everyone else guilt by association.
It's quite funny. It Yes, I know. I know. Isn't it [__]
Kelly? It's a great skill. It's a shame you don't have that.
Uh yeah, it would be very nice. So, what about now? He's just
like a British rap scallion. He just gets it. I'm just I feel
the same way except I usually say but yeah like no JK and you
know no no JK no this is that was in mind you he said this several
times before JK now there's no JK so what so I was right you
meant it it's like he's been seething he's been seething about
all these different issues I meant like and said nothing to me
sorry not AoE like a taunt it's like a AoE taunt and said not
yeah cuz I thought you were a snake I was right it's like a misdirect
if we played World of Warcraft. Okay. Hunters have the misdirect
ability. That's what he does. He basically goes and calls somebody
like hit on a 14-year-old online and then somehow that's blamed
on Chud Logic. You'd love to see it. You're duplicitous snake.
What? You even frame this f you even snakily frame this video.
You didn't cover my You didn't cover what I talked about. You
avoided what I talked about. Me, bro. We last spoke six months
ago and I said to him that the slasher stuff was overblown and
to look over my coverage and if he didn't agree with it, let's
go over what he said.
He hasn't blocked me.
I actually want to check that out.
See, let me read this. Okay. Hey man, I hope you had a good Christmas.
Aiden Freeman were talking about the statements in regards to
Slaughter and Britney Venny DMs. Huh? Some inconsistencies came
up uh in regards to the order of the DMs and has some impacts
in regards to what happened. So he's already made a decision
on it. He's not even saying Aiden Armen are talking about uh
the statements in regard to slasher B some inconsistencies came
up in the order of DMs and has some impact in regards to what
happened. Would you be interested in hopping on the stream? Well,
here's the thing. He didn't say they said that. He said he said
that. So it's definitive and I knew I knew right there and then.
Now this is coming right off the planet Kell stuff. So this was
um Queman and this is the big thing that set Queman and Tommy
se at cross purpose. Okay. Now, Queen always didn't like Tommy
C, but Tommy C didn't really know who Queen was. And then Queen
came and argued with him on Chad's stream. It was about um whether
or not it was like a fascist lynch mob when people tried to cancel
Dr. Disrespect before anything else come out. Okay. It was just
the articles and no statement from Dr. Disrespect and Tommy was
arguing that it was like fascist for them to do that. And Queen
came to argue with him and Tommy really had no no real arguments,
right? And so there was another argument after that around Slasher
and calling like basically saying that uh saying it was inconsistent
for how everybody treated Dr. Disrespect versus how they treated
Slasher. And again, Quimman and uh Queen Quimman and Aiden basically
pointed out that Tommy's being there and Chad asked Tommy to
come on and talk about it and then basically nothing came of
it. And right off the like, Tommy, don't you have a wife? You
should be talking to Kinetic Kell. So, I knew I was Wait, wait,
wait. Hold on. Oh, did I just mute this or Oh, he muted. Sorry.
Yeah. Yeah, he muted here, right? So, here's the part that he's
called and I basically said, "Is this uh you got uh you got muted
for a second?" Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, when Chud leaks DM leaks,
you don't comment, but when Kelly does is the worst thing. Interesting.
Double standard. Wait, I It is bad that he leaked that, I guess.
But yeah, it's uh it's very different very different context
those are happening in. It's is it are they very private?
Did he promise privacy?
Well, I think it's very different in that this was a a secret
quote unquote secret that had been shared to like 20 other people
and they passed around pictures of Bo Black and address in the
commentary community laughing at him. So like Chad leaking that
when a bunch of people knew. Yeah, exactly. So a little different.
I said 20. I actually don't know the number, but a lot of people
knew. Yeah. Yeah, he did. Maybe just expect British people to
leak.
long. Okay. 25 seconds. Yeah. 25 seconds. All right. Let me start.
No, just I'll start again. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Start. I'll start
again. So, we'll go over the DMs that he's talking about. Hey,
man. I hope you had a good Christmas. Aiden and Queen were talking
about Dammons in regards to Slasher and Britney DMs. Some
came up in regards to the order of things, which has some impact
in regards to what happened. Now, he's saying that definitively.
He's not saying, "Hey, um, Aiden Queen, call you now." He's just
he's saying that definitively. Would you be interesting in hopping
on stream tomorrow to talk about this on point or in the next
few days or are you busy? I didn't buy this. I didn't buy it
at all. A couple days later, I saw So Tommy starts putting the
conspiracy together over here is basically he feels like Queen
ambushed him and now he's asking him to come on a second time
with Queenman and now he's going to keep it here. Here's what
he writes later. Hey, looked it over on stream today. It was
overblown criticism. I don't think we need to talk to you on
stream about it, but if you look it over, it has it has any issues.
Let me know. Here's what he didn't tell you. I called Nick and
I say, "Is this guy with me?"
And then the next day I get the message. Nick told me that look
cuz I was like, "Is this guy trying to [__] with
me?" And he was like, "Look, I don't think so. I'll talk to him."
And then so basically they said, "Hey, these guys have some criticisms
for you for like this this opinion you have. Do you want to come
on stream and talk about it?" And he called instead of just saying
like, "No, I don't want to." Or instead of like saying, "Yeah,
I'll defend my opinion." He called Nick and said, "Hey, is this
guy like bad faith right now?" No. Literally, if you would have
come on, they would have discussed their What do you think they're
going to do? You think they're lying? The the message is, "Hey,
they have some criticisms of you. Do you want to discuss it on
stream?" You could just say no. Why do you have to call Nick
and be like, "Is this guy with me? He's not with you. He's just
asking if you want to talk about it. If you don't want to talk
about it, just say no." And the tone change came. Paranoia. We
were done. Yeah. So he thinks so what Tommy thinks happened was
oh do you want to come talk about it and then basically that
Nick messaged Chud and said are you with this guy and then Chud
said hey just say no we went over it I don't think it's like
that significant we don't have to talk about it if you don't
want he's leaving one thing out I put these I checked into this
thing and it was totally overblown I shot it down yeah when Nick
called you and I smelled a rat hence why I won't talk to you
I or he like literally was just planning his content for the
next day hadn't looked into it was like oh I'm going to look
into it and if you want to come on then we could talk about it.
And then he looked into it and you didn't want to come on. You
didn't message him. And then he said, "Hey, I did look into it."
Like I need I need to I need some evidence that the counter theory
is less plausible. Right. So the the counter theory is Oh, he
actually looked at it and was like, "Oh, I think this is a little
overblown." What evidence is there that that is incorrect? Was
he making like snide comments about how you were actually really
really wrong about that? You were a total for saying that? That
might be some evidence. I just don't know what evidence there
is. So I don't think you're good fake. I think you were fishing.
This is a very similar conversation that Chud had with Willie
Mack. Hey, you look like you're crashing out, buddy. You want
to come on and talk about it? It's content farming. He's content
forming his friends. My argument, he's not trustworthy. He's
not a very good friend. And considering again that he's saying
the same about me that he said when he was my friend. I'm kind
of thinking he meant it. Okay. And that's fine. I I just don't
want to be friends and talk. I don't want to be fake friends.
I don't want to do this mean girl [__] I like what
Quean does. I like Queen just comes out and spits it. He's a
bad faith bastard and he'll over anybody get by YouTube. He's
never gonna help his friends. Um
where where is the bad faith element of this? Where's I I just
want So the bad faith element for Queen is what I need citations
on, right? Uh some of the stuff on Chud, he's got like um some
vague semblance of a point like like it's conspiratorial, but
there are like elements of reality, right? Uh Panda the Gray,
what's the point watching this? Uh there is no point for you
watching it. Come back in a week. Bye. and he's never. So for
Quean,
I understand calling um I understand saying, "Oh, well this Chud
thing like he leaked the Bo thing." If if you have the same criticism
for all your friends sharing that picture of Boax around, right?
Then I totally get it, but he doesn't have that same criticism
for his friends sharing that picture of Boax around. He would
never go and talk about it, right? And anyway, so that's why
I kind of defend Chud. I don't think it's a serious criticism
that Tommy's making. And then for Quean, I just see no evidence
at all. Like there is no evidence. He's just just totally making
up some idea of who Queman is without any actual clips. Anything
anything there at all. Look is ridiculous to Tommy C who bends
over backwards for him. That's quote. All right. And my Here's
what I want to tell you guys right now. Sub to Queen right now
because here's the thing. He's going to give it to you straight.
That's the kind of stuff you want. You don't want We watch this.
I think we I don't think we're caught up to where we were last
night, but this is uh this is a lot of the same thing here, right?
The subqument. He's just trying to drive a wedge. He's trying
to go Chud's like super bad faith, but sub to Queen because he's
honest about being bad faith. defense writing. Everybody there
lies. Chad and Queman and Jay Saga, everybody, they all lie.
They're all liars.
But like, sub to sub to Queman because at least he's the honest
liar. If you don't want somebody to sit there and beat around
the bush, sub to Quean,
Because he's a honest liar. And if that's what you want, Chud
is a dishonest liar. Chud is a phony. So that whole thing is
like, "Hey, I saw it on stream. You were trying to trap me on
stream with Creamman and Aiden. not a [__] [__]
Hence why I won't talk to you. Let's go on. Right. Then he could
talk to me about it. That's the last time we spoke. He's not
said a single thing to me since. And apparently he's got all
these issues with things that I've said. It's [__]
deranged. It's [__] deranged, bro. No, it isn't.
It's having issues with That's strange to have issues with what
you said. Is that what you do all day? It's totally ridiculous.
I mean, what is going on? And apparently there's others that
have got problems with me. I don't know if it's group chats.
I don't know what it is. Maybe people venting. Maybe you know
that's not me. I hate group chats. [__] talking me.
whatever. And obviously it puts me in a difficult I don't talk
to you in group chats. I go right to the source and they say
this guy's no good and here's why I thank it. Just be clear position
because I'm not a snake and I don't want to start leaking DMs
unlike Tommy C who decided to leak a bunch of Nicholas Dioro
DMs over a green green Eminem woman or whatever it was. How many
DMs have I leaked of any of the commentary guys? How many DMs
have I uh I don't have the entire lowdown on that. I think Moral
linked it to me. We could watch that another night. So apparently,
yes, there was some some discourse that happened that Tommy and
Nick both got like conspiratorial with each other. Tommy got
conspiratorial about Nick, leaked a bunch of DMs with Nick, and
then basically apologized. And now even later says, "No, I wasn't
really wrong there. I just apologized cuz Nick was like Nick
threatened me or something." It was it was weird. He was like
he apologized cuz he um he he said Nick did threaten me, but
I apologize. I don't know if it was because he was wrong. I can't
remember there now. Somebody knows the green Eminem thing better
than I do. Moral sent it to me and then I I haven't had a chance
to look at it. Anyway, it was basically Yeah. Where does the
green Eminem come in? So, it's the Eminem. It's uh It's the female
Eminem, right? Green M&M. This is like the Tucker Carlson
thing, right? The green Eminem and they like had to change it
or something. Used to have the legs and then they changed it
to not have the legs. That's what their argument was about. Something
somehow about this. Okay. Somehow they nearly melted down their
entire friendship over this Eminem. Did you see the Tucker Carlson
bit? I have. Yes. Anyway, leaked to anyone. How many Chud has
proved out a shadow of doubt that he is a better person to be
because he hasn't leaked DMs. Well, I guess they didn't help
you. I guess they I guess they didn't give you tons of content
like the Bobax stress. I didn't leak any DMs. I didn't leak any
DMs. Yeah, cuz it was in for it. Yeah, I led DMs. Everybody knows
why I did it. He told me he was going to He told me he was going
to make a video on me. I I took that as a threat and I acted
accordingly. And you know what? I stayed away from him and I
didn't bring up his name after that because I wanted nothing
but the best. After a couple months, we made up. I think Nick
got bad mad at me and overreacted. I think I overreacted and
we patched it up. I don't think you're overreacting. I think
you're How many times have I leaked DMs from any of the commentary
guys? How many? How many? You're a better person than me. How
many zero hero? How many [__] hero hero? Everybody
the golden rule. I never I never broke the golden rule. You know,
it's funny you bring up the golden rule because that's Keemstar's
thing. I'm hearing the same thing. Conspiracy theorist. You're
stupid. You don't know what you're talking about. You're lying.
All this other stuff. Alcoholic. It's almost like breaking up
with dating all over again. Zero. The answer is zero. How many
times in the future at this time am I planning to leak DMs? The
answer is zero. You're a better person than me. I've got no plans
to any DMs. And obviously when this drunken return I want somebody's
going to tell Chud how many times Nick has leaked DMs. Probably
more than me. By the way, I'm glad he did. I'm glad he did. I'm
glad he did. Nick recorded a call and it
just called several multiple calls. I know. Several calls. What
are they? What What is the purpose of this? Like, hold on. What
is the purpose of this? They're They're moralizing being a snake
right now. And now they're like, "Do you know how many times
Nick by close personal friend has leaked DMs and recorded calls
and done thing all kinds of duplicitous things? So many way more
than me. What? Okay, then what is the standard here? Why are
you mad at Chud?" Whoa. I don't know, Chud. You may have to disavow
Nick. Sorry. The standard is if if you're friends with somebody
or if you have even a superficial friendship with them, you
Yes, you have to be the person who covers for them at all times.
That's what you have to do. Okay. If you're if you're if you
don't know them, if you don't like them, yeah, you can be as
duplicitous as you want. You can be a straight up piece of doesn't
matter. That's
I don't know. I mean, don't give me this good person. You would
leak something on anybody if you thought it benefited you, which
by the way is my whole argument and my first title. I don't trust
this guy. I don't trust Tread Logic anymore. That's it. Yeah.
Yeah, you know, now you're sitting there virtue signaling over
I don't leak DMs, by the way. I don't think there's one commentator
that has it. I don't know who's leaked more than Nick. And we're
talking full-blown phone calls. By the way, I think you should.
I think there's a time and a place. I'm not this golden rule
guy. I know you're going to play GameStar and the golden rule
and nobody's going to trust you. And that's what he's doing.
No one will trust Tommy. He leaks DMs. I didn't even know Chuck
when I leaked those DMs. And what did I leak on Nick? I I went
on stream and said, "Look, this guy threatened me. Here it is."
Uh, in a funny twist of
I think actually in a totally way leaked DMs, right? Didn't make
some comment about how things were getting weird and Tommy thought
that like implied that he was being super weird in DMs so he
leaked all of his DMs with was like, "No, no, no. You just misunderstood
what I said on stream." Isn't that what happened there? I know
some like that happened recently. Said, "Uh, we're going to have
to split up." That's so Tommy's uh Tommy's being a goof all over
the place and then we cooled off.
You know what? Uh, sin signal with the 10 gifted after the five
gifted, five gifted, then 10 gifted. That's another hour on the
stream. What the are we just We're doing the whole commentary
Civil War tonight. Okay, I guess we're here the entire night.
You love to see it. Welcome. Buckle in, guys. That's two and
a half hours stream. Let's go. Me, too. That he's panicking right
now and he wants Nick the way we I don't think he's going. Veteran
[__] is sat there roing veteran [__]
I I here's something. This is this is something I absolutely
can't prove. I always thought he had problem with troops. I got
that vibe playing Fortnite with him one night when he made a
couple weird comments. Can CT Riddle veteran [__]
is sat there. I did. I vibe. I look I'm not going to give my
feelings though. You don't have to [__] I don't care
if you respect me because I'm a veteran or not, but I did get
I have gotten the vibe a long time ago um that that he has an
issue with vets. Absolutely. Like a veteran. What was that got
to do with anything? Did the army do it to me or my behalf?
Oh, he's absorbed the the frogen talking points. Okay, Chudlo
Logic basically just said he wishes PTSD on all vets, guys. This
guy hates vets because
there roping in other people into this, right? And it's talking
about what this person is saying or what that person is saying.
It puts me in a difficult position because I don't want to start
leaking DMs. Leak my DMs. All right, I'll leak your DMs. Oh,
no. Damn it, don't. You're breaking the golden rule. Your DMs.
They're nothing. Here you go. You don't care about none of these
people. Okay, Chud saying he is not going to leak DMs of Tommy
and Tommy saying he's not going to leak DMs or he's going to
leak DMs to Chud. None of it matters because I don't think they
ever had any in-depth conversation. They probably had like two
random conversations about nothing, right? Like none of it's
going to matter. None of you. It doesn't mean anything that Chud
didn't leak Tommy's DMs. Doesn't mean anything that Tommy now
leaks his. Nobody's cool. Nobody's It's You guys don't talk.
It's like if you have empty DMs with somebody threatening to
leak doesn't mean anything. Their DMs are essentially empty,
I'm guessing. Me a Greg, dude. Stop the like. Calm down, dude.
Really? Here we go. Discord. Here's I think it's like he just
like brings up. Where's all Chad's DMs? You're showing you're
showing the the wrong Oh, the wrong [__] one. All
right, I'll probably read that up there, too. There's Chad's
DMs. There you go. Zoom in. Hey, man. Hope you had a good Christmas.
Aiden Queen were talking about the statements in regards to Slasher
and Britney Venty's DMs. Some inconsistencies came up in regards
to the order of the DMs, which has some impact in regards to
what happened. Would you be interested in hopping on stream tomorrow
to talk uh about it at some point or in the next few days if
you're busy? and he leaves two voicemails. [__] him.
I think that's the biggest weirdest thing to kind of like cry
about when what this Chad Logic guy is a real prick. That's what
I'd say. Like like Nick, he deletes your DMs. Like it's like
the ultimate DM phone called And by the way, I don't got a problem
with it. You actually don't need to. You tell me something. Here's
my golden rule. You tell me something in private and something
different in public, I'm leaking. Thank you for being the only
one to call out Chud's dishonesty. Dishonest dishonesty. I'm
so tired of pretending he's fair.
Okay, I'm almost positive this is somebody just gassing Tommy
up, right? That's what this donation is. Dishonesty.
Well, that's because they say um what Queen is the honest dishonest
one and Chud's dishonestly dishonest. So Chud pretends he's like
Chud pretends he's not dishonest while being dishonest.
Quean is honest about being dishonest to this guy, which I don't
think either of those things are true. I don't think one of them
is a pointless qualifier and the other one's a paradox. So, question
mark question mark. Well, this guy is something of a philosopher,
Kelly. Maybe maybe he understands paradoxes better than you.
Undoubtful. Yes, it even winks at us by almost saying Chud is
fair, but in reverse 100%. Only want to call out good dishonest
dishonesty. I am so tired of pretending fair. Thank you. That's
what I want people to understand. I want people to see Chud in
a different light. I do not expect to win. I know it like what's
happened to me with the past one. Um, 24 hours is Chud's ultimate
nightmare. It's Decker's ultimate nightmare. It's Queman's ultimate
nightmare. They don't know. I doubt it, dude. This is the This
is them ringing their hands being like, "More content." How is
this their nightmare? Um, like the opposite. I can only assume
he means by like seeing through the the counter cabal that is
all these people coordinating to try to take like him or Nick
Doryo down. I think that's what he means. Yeah. I just like that
he says Deckers instead of just because he's an Why wouldn't
you say name correctly? I've done this before and I'm perfectly
comfortable with it. It's just text. It's just text. I don't
like it when it's tech from people I like or people to be my
friend or allies with. That's when I don't like it. That's when
it me off. Otherwise, yeah, you can say what you want about vets
or whatever you want. I don't care. It's up to you. I don't want
to start leaking other people's DMs. I don't know what involvement
other people have got in. Did I say Decker's name wrong? Deckers.
Well, like Oh, Deckers. Oh, yeah. Deckers, by the way. Yeah,
that one. I want to I want to I uh
misspeaking people's names intentionally is like gay. It's just
totally gay. It's like it's like the most insecure thing you
can do. I feel like like if you're not trying to make a joke
of some kind. Like saying uh Epstein. That's funny. Saying Deckers,
you're not even making a joke. You're literally just you're you
literally just got informed what it was and now you're trying
to intentionally mispronounce it. I want I want to throw this
one at you. I I I I I seen you riding both ways to see the way
it's going to break, whether it's like because you were a little
nervous it might break in my favor and I saw you saying nice
things to be about the technical thing. That's why be that's
why I watched this video with Queen for a little bit or some
video about Tommy C with Queen for a little bit. We started taking
Tommy's side because it was funny but um wasn't cuz we were worried
about it breaking your way Tommy. I'm sorry to say. And um I
don't know if you're being sincere or not. I'm pretty sure the
community come from pretty much demands that you are. Hey Tommy,
it's my best friend's birthday today. Can you say happy birthday
Marcus for? Serious. But let me tell you something. If for some
magical
reason, why are you reading out his donos? Cuz I assume they're
going to all be trolls from uh Chud or Queen or some other community.
I assume he just not get very many sincere donations. Um this
breaks against him and it won't cuz I just simply don't got the
numbers. It's just it's a math game at this point. I still weird
Raven Ruben, but whatever forever. I don't buy your one iota.
I think you're a wave rider and if I was on top right now and
I had more people in my camp, you would be sucking my diggers.
Just wanted to let you know, buddy. Oh, we did watch this cuz
I remember making the I remember making the digger comment after
this. We did watch this already. Give people a I knew I knew
I'd seen some of this, but I also watched a little bit of uh
coverage the other the other day, so I wasn't totally sure where
I got to mind in certain ways. You don't have a to me, don't
I? I just kind of have to I can't leak the DMs because then it's
like look Oh, so he's he's sitting Oh, he's saying he's got DMs
on me then. Is that what you're saying? N he's leaking DMs, but
then I've just got to have Well, he's got nothing on me. My interaction
is mischaracterized. I don't think that's So, what I'll say is
this. So, what is he saying? Oh, he's like he's a better
Okay. Okay. So, what you like about that? I'm happy to have a
conversation with people on stream if we've got a disagreement
about something. I understand my community can be obnoxious and
annoying and if they don't want to do that, I don't care about
it. I encourage them to do what they're doing now and into the
future. They're spamming the chat right now. I don't care. I
don't care. I'm not We're not moderating it. Nothing. I don't
give a This is a long-standing policy over here. We really don't.
I mean, somebody did towers, so I'm like, "Yeah, probably there
is a limit, but I mean this this just because Oh, sorry. I I
blamed other people for doing towers in uh in Tommy's chat, but
apparently he suggested it. Okay, he just mentioned towers. How
long will it be, Kelly, till we get actual towers in his chat?"
And I will even say that it takes 2 seconds, doesn't it? N what?
N I N apparently that I've been participating in reaching out
to someone and going if you want to talk privately, we can do
as well and you can record. But I don't like you. That is I don't
believe you. Why would I do this? Oh, I know you're trying to
frame me as a coward. I don't care if you do. I if if it in my
chat call me a coward. It really you guys do it in my chat and
die. I'm just telling you. Look, if I was lying, if I was being
the waterb brain, this was was that's the next word you're going
to hear. Obsession, right? That's that's that's what coming next.
I would be like I like I am now like, "Oh, I'm a coward." Oh,
great. That's not you. You're freaking out, Jud. My snake. I
absolutely need you.
Behind the scenes interaction person. Oh [__] Can
I get a soundboard of that? Can somebody make me a soundboard
of that? Also, give me two seconds. I'll be right back. Oh, now
I'm getting a single go on a third party. That's kind of funny.
I'll be honest. That is funny. Where's that then? If I'm such
a snake, if I'm such aing snake, where's that happening then?
Where's that happening? Once it's in the video, once you get
there, keep kids play. We're what? I haven't even started yet.
I'm just Look, I still I'm still making fun of him. It's ridiculous.
We're still getting into the intro. I am one of the least sneaky
people out there. It's absurd. [__] That's a bizarre.
I'm one of the least sneaky people out there. He is. He sounds
like a kid that got caught. What do you mean? What do you mean,
Mom? Are you saying I'm a liar? Yes. DMs? I'm not in other people's.
And by the way, it's not like I don't speak to people that, you
know, but how do I make depressed people? I feel really I like
that lumpy Willie is calling me insane and I have like almost
100 stars. Thank you for the super chats. You know, obviously
I've spoken to people who, you know, don't you know, not recently,
but like over time, people that don't like say Tommy Seal or
other commentary. Oh, thank you. And I never [__]
at them. I never, you know, even when they say things that to
me are a little bit like, you know, oh, I don't like them and
d I don't say anything. I just say, "Yeah, they're my friend."
And that's the end of it. So, I don't understand.
Well, that's the thing. I'm kind of doing the same thing. That's
my friend. That's the That's the decision that I made pretty
much in February, right? That's not my friend. That's the narrative.
But here's the thing. You're in the game. You're open to criticism.
Was coming from But I'm some sort of [__] snake because
I genuinely take efforts to not engage in snake behavior. So,
it's so [__] obnoxious. It's not. It doesn't take
an effort, Chud. It never takes an effort. I I like what what's
so hard about not being disingenuous? Do you have to go through
like a like check system in the morning? All right. Don't this
person over. Don't that person over. Don't for this person over.
I have to make an effort. Nobody has to make an effort not to
be a snake. Some kind of sociopath wants to hide it. I mean,
I'm not saying you're a sociopath, but who does that? I I don't
wake up in the morning and say, "I I don't need to. I got to
do everything I can to not my friends over."
But this wretch can talk about how I'm some snake with no evidence.
He's repeating himself. He won't watch the video evidence. Apparently,
that's just accepted by Well, I say people. I don't really see
them as people. It's low IQ commentary viewers. That's the way
I feel about Lumpy Willie. How ironic, right? So, he's 47 seconds.
He's the voice of reason. 47 seconds. You agree with this analysis?
And that's with intro. It's obscene. That's with intro. We haven't
even intro. That's where's the evidence of me being a snake.
What have I done exactly? I certainly haven't DMs. Okay. Watch
the video.
I certainly haven't. Watch the video. He He He does exactly what
I accused him of. Play stupid. He's playing stupid right now.
Back to third parties. I certainly haven't talked about any of
these people in group chat somewhere. So, where is the snakeike
behavior? Everything else is publicly on stream or me reaching
out to a concerned party, an individual, saying, "Hey, disagreement.
We can talk. You can record if you want on or off stream. Up
to you." Okay, that's what What is Snaky? What? Where's a snake?
Chud is a sociopath. Is he really? Did I call him a snake for
wanting or not wanting to talk to me? I called him a snake for
Willy. I called him a snake for the crowd situation. I called
him a snake for the boback situation. I called him a snake for
the turkey. Turkey Tom and Bob he didn't address until now until
apparently at some point in this video. You like this? Where's
the snakiness? Where? Where is it? I don't know. support so he
has to content with the you're a lot better than I am super chat
thank you what what do the kids say today now nowadays seething
coping seething this is why I didn't want to get into this don't
do it I wanted to try and this I'm not going to call you you
don't have to get into it decided to have another the range meltdown
the two times out of 10 that he is and then in months to come
go oh I was right about that guy are you worried about getting
nailed one day are you a screenshot away of me being right I
don't know in a disagreement with Nicholas Dioro in 6 months
time oh looks like I was right about him it's so transparent
what's going on here, dude. It's so like you're freaking out,
man. And again, I will speak to Tommy. Why is he running from
a conversation? What is he some sort of Is this some sort of
[__] push?
Fair. I didn't watch his video. Okay, I do feel like I addressed
all of his points. I do feel like I covered all his points. Okay,
but fair's fair. I didn't watch his video.
What? Yeah. No, he No, he admits that he didn't address that.
It just takes him It takes him a bit to get there.
Uh, your mic kind of got Tommy. Uh, your mic got quiet out of
nowhere. Oh, I wonder if I have a loose cord or something. Boom.
Boom. So, he's lying right now. I feel like how could you how
could you leave the bow back in the the cornerstone of the whole
thing? And the one the the major thing I got out of the first
out of the first one is you why don't you just call me a and
I didn't call him. I didn't even suggest it. I didn't say he
was a groomer. I said none of those things. All right. There's
another example why I wouldn't call you. when you pretended to
watch my video and pretended to answer um the major points, you
turn you twisted into I called you a when I didn't. Hey, it's
Sean Maloney. I see you Shawn Maloney. What's up? When I said
somebody catfished you and that's up. So saying you you came
along with a lot of bad baggage and the people that try you're
trying to snake now. I don't want to repeat myself for the next
two hours. The people that you're trying to snake now are the
people that look the other way. I know that everybody hates that
I said that or accepted your baggage. Is that better?
He didn't watch mine. Okay, but he's not going to watch my video.
I'm now going to watch his response here. And he's also not going
to have a conversation. Why not? Why do you need one? Because
I said some mean things about you in a video. Are you complain?
I don't know, dude. I I didn't watch all of his, you know, response
to me. I wish we could. Somebody didn't watch it. Is he really
Did anybody hear me? Is there something wrong here? Did he really
about me not watching his video when he didn't watch mine? Are
you joking? He did watch yours.
Wait. I I could have swear
he didn't watch it. But he's not going to watch my video. I'm
now going to watch his response here. And he's also not going
to have a conversation. Why not? Why do you need one? Because
I said some mean things about you in a video where you're complain.
I don't feel I I didn't watch all of his, you know, response
to me. Oh, he didn't watch all of his response. I see. So, he
didn't watch it. Is he really? No, he he didn't say. He said
he didn't watch all of which is like, okay, you could have watched
90% of it or something, which I'm pretty confident he did. He
says he didn't watch all of it. He watched basically all of it.
Can anybody hear me? Is there something wrong here? Did he really
about me not watching his video when he didn't watch mine? Are
you joking? He just [__] admitted to what the [__]
Are you kidding? I should pay somebody to edit this. Oh god.
Are you Are you like like I even said I don't care if you watch
it or not when when he did watch it. Then I pointed out we're
going to pretend to watch version of the Joker.
comedic effects.
I mean, he has a sped up has like a sped up somehow more annoying
Hassan laugh. Okay. Like he pretended to watch. That's a joke.
I don't even think we've gotten to that part. Yeah. Like I think
we're still so early into the video that he hasn't heard that
yet. Yeah. Oh, so then he'll change course. He'll change course
like he normally does. I know. About to watch now. I watched
a few clips in a few bits and pieces. So I guess we'll find out.
Okay, that's wonderful. You actually don't need to interact with
real people ever. Chad, this is insane. You're a season.
Thank you. You know my IQ is double digits. So there. Thank you
very much for the super chat. I can't believe I got I think I
said Did I say a full sentence? No. And it was 20 minutes. I
think I just said heart of Europe. That's it. I said heart of
Europe. I don't know what's going on. What's going on? And then
the next What? Go ahead. Well, I'm trying to think. We're probably
about 15 minutes in like cuz you know there's the whole intro
that there's Chud's intro and music playing. So, we're about
15 minutes into him actually being here. Hey, that's called commentary,
bro. Don't even
I'm seeing Okay, I'm coming. No, but Tommy, his excuse is that
it's fair use.
That'll be fair. I got to be honest with you. Um, I might do
this again. I thought it would kind of end here because he would
probably have the strength not to respond, but I got to be honest
with you. I I may do this again. This is funny.
Anyway, we're 47 seconds in, so let's continue. Oh, one more
thing before we get back into this. Okay, there is one point.
Okay, there is one aspect that I didn't respond to from his original
video. I feel like I did a fairly decent job of addressing all
of his points, but there is one aspect I apparently missed. Okay.
And I think it's going to come up here. So, I guess we'll address
it when we get to it. But, you know, I think even though I didn't
watch it on stream, I did watch it off stream and I feel like
I did a pretty reasonable job of addressing all of his points.
I don't and that's why I made a response. I don't. In fact, I
think I forced you to respond to this. I think you tried to get
around it and now you can't. Thanks, Cleman. Just quite funny.
Let's see. Chub viewers are here right now. Uh, your game is
weak. I expect a far better from you. But okay, that he's now
I'm not going to subject you. It's like Barry is so pathetic,
dude. I'm not going to subject you to the 50-minute video, but
then he's also not going to have a conversation. So, what is
going on here then? What is the point of all of this? These people
cannot handle. How could How How could he be this defensive and
also be so confident that he's not a
being challenged. Tom, you've been the game a long time. You're
acting like this is kind of I've never seen this guy. But since
he's fat, I assume he hates me. Much like all the other fat guys
sit around talking about me or he doesn't know who I am, which
seems like for the best. I'm pretty confident he know who you
are, Kelly. Sorry. I realized there's only one possible way I
could sit through all the Tommy Dribble, okay? And that is uh
I need to get a video game going, okay?
There's really only one possible choice given that it just went
1.0. Okay, there's only one possible choice.
Give me a second. Kelly, are you a backpack battles enjoyer?
I do not know what that is.
Uh, it's a fantastic game that everybody loves. Literally, everybody
loves it. And it just went 1.0. It was in beta for a long time
and now it just went 1.0.
Uh, how do we do this? Do we do this like this? Then I move myself
over or something? Yeah, I think that's what I do. Uh, where's
my guy? Where's my guy? He's right there. Oh, here we go.
Uh, I'll do this. Like this. I'll flip me.
Okay, here we go. You're literally fagging for views. No, I'm
I I I think he's behaving like a child that just got caught.
Which class? In backpack battles. Okay, hold on. Okay, here's
the thing. In backpack battles, there are two new classes, mage
and adventurer. Okay, 1.0 No, today. Well, sorry. Yesterday.
Yeah. Okay. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Okay.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no. We did not mean to do that. Which is
fine because we're still at we're at zero anyway, so it won't
matter. I can just abandon. I've been playing the mage class.
The mage class is pretty cool. Okay. The mage class with this
one, the scholar scholar bag. Okay. The mage class is pretty
cool. Yeah, we'll do ranked. I'll absolutely do ranked right
now. Have you tried the bizaar? It's another auto battle game.
No, I've not tried the bizaar yet. I've heard it's amazing. You
picked the lolly class. They're all lolly classes. Okay. Well,
no. This is the lolly class. Well, you can buy skins. I think
I bought the skin for this one.
I have such a big head. This is like a chibi. There's like chibi
art for all of them. But I bought the chibi art for this one
apparently. I didn't even realize.
But the mage class is pretty cool. So, I'm going to play that.
And we're going to listen to Tommy yap and whine about Chud Logic.
Okay. Good times. His body language is stuff that he's nervous.
Most people would just blow this off. He's lying about um covering
the the most important part that made my argument his pattern
behavior being a snake. I think I'm just fine.
And you know what? If you think I am Dragonfused, upper right
hand corner click. If I'm being that dishonest, I'm being a snake.
Make a choice. Don't don't aim. Friends or owe them favors. You
and Queen have said far worse about each other. Lol. Yeah, dude.
I Bro, yes. I talk a lot of [__] sometimes. It's
[__] funny to me, right? Yes. There's, like I said,
there's like a third serious, third banter, third rage, right?
I've already said that every time Chad Logix talks about me,
if he ever talks [__] about me in the future, that
is just him proving Tommy C correct. Okay, Tommy C was right
about you. Tommy C was right. You're an [__] All
right, you're an Tommy C was right. Doesn't he just talk about
everyone? That just seems like it's power for the court. I don't
Anyone that takes that personally, it's very strange.
Yeah, but I'm going to take it personally.
I have not given a [__] on one single
Yeah. Well, you know what? He should have thought about that
before he um I don't know. Tommy C was right about you, Chud.
Tommy C was right. That's all I know. Tommy C was correct in
there. But I feel like it's getting taken way too seriously.
And also, by the way, yeah, obviously, as I'm sure you can imagine,
there was a bit of tension between me and Big Nick off the back
of me [__] talking about gay. But we're fine. Me
and Nicholas are totally fine. Like, maybe there's some tension.
Maybe maybe he's vetted someone. I don't really care about that.
Whatever. You vent to people. Okay, that's wonderful. But like
there's no offess people aren't Tommy C. Do you believe that,
Kelly? That there's Do you believe that? That there's no issue
between him and Nick despite him talking a little bit about Nick.
I would believe that Chud doesn't give a Yeah. Why would he?
This is like not deep, is it? None of this [__] It's
really It's really really not. Even when it it gets a bit deep,
it would have to be something really personal. I feel like tried
to care, I would assume. Yeah, seems fair. And it hasn't got
personal, has it? Does this guy know him personally? I don't
know. Um, does he know him personally? Uh, I don't know, actually.
Does per depends on what you mean by personally. Like, does Nick
or Tommy know him personally? I mean, they know him enough to
be like um, how would you put it? No. No. I mean, like this guy,
does he know enough about Chun personally to like be very uh,
what's the word? Oh, like actually cutting in some way, like
actually upsetting to him? Um, maybe, but probably if he did,
it would be through other people. Like it wouldn't be that he
knows specifically. It' be that like other people have told him
about Chud. That'd be more what it would be. Yeah.
Okay. It is kind of weird that he's saying that he wants everyone
to think Chud is a bad person, though. It's like weird. It's
like you're going around being like, "Yes, I I need everyone
to think the same as me. Everyone must think bad person bad."
It's just kind of very weird. Very weird. Very cringe. Yeah.
Sure. Yeah. threatens by it. So I don't know if I wouldn't care.
I don't know why very This is the problem. I don't want to get
into the nature of behind the scenes conversations. We spoke
briefly about an unrelated topic yesterday. Very briefly. No
issue. No issue at all. No. No problem. Didn't funny. I I talked
about same thing. It was probably the same thing we were talking
about too. You know this him getting strikes. So what why would
he talk about he not like um it wasn't anything deep. It was
just like him calling me a or something. I don't know. I was
like I hate Kelly. She's such a But then that came soon before
actually Kelly got a W here cuz it was like Nick being a So all
you have to do is not be the biggest in the room. Fine. All I'm
hearing is uh Kelly won. Basically all I'm hearing out of this.
True. Once again, Kelly won. Well, I didn't say it. Chad did.
I don't get to point out your that you're a sneaky move. Here's
another thing. Chad, was that was that about the Willie Mack
video or whatever? Kelly, that was right. Yeah. Yeah. It was
also Nick coming in and being like his soy kiss hats and me just
calling him fat and then it was all related to that where I just
kept calling him fat until he left all of the service. I can't
remember the exact details of it. It was around that situation.
You're an actual psychopath. I hope you know that. I don't know
what it is about like Nick opening his mouth and making comments
about me knowing that it will get back to me eventually and then
he just like embarrassing himself that badly. It's just sad.
He's a strange man. Oh, what did he say about me? He like implied
that I was like
um deficient in some way. So like being around me was like some
kind of liability. I can't remember what Nick said. It was it
was such a weird comment. Yeah, that didn't work out well for
him. Oh, whoops. Why haven't you come out and made those legitimate
criticisms of Nick instead of just calling him a glazer? Or if
he is a glazer, how come you haven't explained yourself? Well,
I know what you told Nick. You told him because you're afraid
it was going to cause drama and you call me. Maybe you're just
sort of like they're just trying to get on the wave cuz they
want this. How is that an insult? This is cool. What the [__]
Mau. I don't care. Why are they acting like a I think you're
absolutely audience captured. Absolutely right. What do you do
to these people? 100%. I don't think dude what the he's making
him pay the for the low cal jean comments not on anyone's bakar
okay I don't know if you if you're just you're actually really
what do you mean is cringe why is cringe cuz he smiles at the
camera
god this is going to be one of those moments where I defend somebody
I swear to god if you touch kids or something I will actually
you like defend you here and every time I do this okay and certain
people tell me I'm like incorrect
I end up looking like a I swear to God if you touch kids or something
it's it's over for you. Okay? Not because you touch the kids,
but because you made me look like a All right. I don't really
care if you can hide touching the kids, whatever. But if you
make me look stupid for defending you, you disingenuous. You
have like really radical views that you want to hide, which is
my guess. Or you have no opinions at all. And YouTube's the game.
That's it. Thank you. Doesn't come up. No issue. So I don't really
understand what this narrative is. You never understand snake.
And I'm going to go over Nicholas. So stupid dude. Why people
are mad at me for something I might do on the basis of like And
here's another thing. If he does pull some stunt, Nick, he can't
do it now. He can't even talk about Ethan now. So So I'll take
the W there. No. No, it's boring. That's why it's boring. No,
no, no, no, no. I I He totally shifted gears here. I pointed
it out. He ran to Dioro and said, "I want to talk about this
privately so I don't get in trouble with the audience because
he's such a Well, I'll take the audience trouble. I'll make them
out. Sure. Nothing's going to ain't going to change my life one
way or another." No evidence. It's change his
I don't understand.
I don't That was 20 minutes before he got in there. Understand?
I watch absolutely everything on YouTube that I can, but I'm
not going to watch his video so I can say I don't understand.
Well, um I have I address the substance of his points and how
you possibly come. That's a lie. How do you come away if you
don't mention the goddamn turkey Tom the Boax thing for me calling
you a snake? If you don't mention that, how could you possibly
say that? That was the substance. You avoided it. Come on. Give
me a break. You're such a liar. I am going to watch the video.
We [__] address every point there. But I addressed
the substance of what he was talking about. No, you didn't. Which
we'll see if he does it here, I guess. But I've heard it's not
particularly good. Solution Ch. If you watch the video, you might
have understood. I did watch the video. I watched it off stream.
Go and watch my video. And wait a minute. Didn't he say before
that he didn't watch all of it? Now he's saying he did watch
the video. Hold on. What is not watching all of it? Why would
not watching all of it means he he mean he didn't watch it? Like
especially I'm sure Chud would say something like well I watched
the video and like I if you have some element of your criticism
like I think if when Tommy can point out that Chud maybe didn't
see the which was it I think he said Chud didn't see the criticism
of about Boax and didn't address that. That's fine. But I'm sure
Chud would say oh well then I up like I didn't watch all the
video but I thought I had enough to make comments. I'm sure you
just say he was wrong on that. Right. On screen. Oh just not
on stream. Yeah. I mean I'm sorry I don't believe you. No, I
don't care. Who cares if you watched it or not? You're a disingenuous
and you're nervous right now talking about both sides of your
mouth. You do it when you're not nervous. Now you are. I didn't
address the points someone made. But the problem with that is
you might have had some uncomfortable questions. So I understand.
So in true shot in the point fashion, and we're going to be totally
fair here. We're going to pretend not to watch your video, too.
That's what we're going to do. That's our plan. Oh, did you see
that?
Oh,
watch Jud's reaction. Oh,
I do that when I'm the off. Watch. Oh, did you see that?
Oh,
what? What? But the problem with that is looking at backpack
battles for a second. Question. So, I understand. So, I by the
way, I have like an undefeated round of backpack battles here.
Fair here. We're going to pretend to watch your video, too. That's
what we have literally no idea what's going on in your game.
Like, what is the point of What are you doing? What is a back?
Oh, I justed up, though. Oh, I just uh I just let this form into
a mana thirst. Uh you basically buy items from the shop, Kelly,
and they are it's like a fantasy backpack, like a fantasy world
backpack, and you are basically trying to build it out so that
you can um I don't know, so you can beat people with other backpacks.
So, I'm basically building like a loadout for like a D and D
character almost like so like I have like weapons and accessories
and other things. And yeah, I'm just trying to build out a loadout
that can win the game. You just win like direct fights with other
people or take direct fights with other people and stuff.
I just messed up though. Yeah, I just messed up. I just messed
up so badly. You see that? What's the meta? I don't know what
the meta is, but like right now I'm on this wizard character
and I'm just building stuff that consumes mana and uses a bunch
of mana cuz I've got this guy that makes my he's he's like really
awesome once you consume a certain amount of mana. But I I just
let this form into the wrong weapon. This should have been something
else and now I'm kind of in trouble with it. It was a mistake.
Uh, give me an unidentified skill. Rainbow. Oh, rainbow might
be okay. Oh, actually, double rainbow is so good here. Oh, I
have a chance to double all of the mana I get from all these
things. Oh my god, it's so good. Build this bloody dagger. Grab
this guy again. Basically, I have this mana mystery thing here
that is Hold on. I don't know if you can see it on stream. My
basic idea is I build up a whole bunch of mana on my character
and that like gets consumed by other things. So, here, let me
pull this up. Now I have this mana mystery thing. This and basically
when I have I let this thing when I get mana orbs they give me
see mana orbs gain plus 20 buffs. Basically my character is going
to build a buffs on themselves based on building up massive amounts
of mana really quickly and burning them off. Yeah, exactly. So
you basically try to build combos of items that build off of
each other. So I'm building a bunch of things that either generate
or consume mana and based on how much I mana I consume that my
like class weapons get better, my water bender weapon gets better
and like that. Let me make it smaller. Focus on the Tommy C video.
Oh,
watch Chud's reaction. Oh,
Chud like kind of rolls his eyes here a little bit. He like barely
just kind of rolls his eyes and Tommy's like, "Oh my god, I got
him so bad." That's what I do when I'm super. Oh, I do that when
I'm the off. Watch that again. We're going to pretend not to
watch your video, too. That's what we're going to do.
That's a cop,
bro. This guy is uh this guy is onward right now. I don't see
anything. Um I mean there is a little bit Tom. He's just kind
of rolling his eyes at Tommy saying that he didn't watch the
video at all. Right. And Tommy's like making a massive deal out
of it. It's quite funny to be honest though. Ch's kind of [__]
owned right now. I'm not going to lie. Ch's kind of getting [__]
destroyed right now. Very cringe. I don't know if it's ever been
this over for Chud logic. He's kind of just in every conceivable
way. I don't know if he can make a comeback at this point. See
if I ever saw one. Oh man. I do that. I have the same body language.
I get really [__] mad. Yeah, I do the same [__]
thing. All right, so adjust your chair.
Just be all right. What? Sorry, Kelly. What? He said he sounds
constipated and he was making
He may literally be
Yeah, he needs more fiber. I mean, look at him. True. He looks
constipated, too.
Watch the video. You're not a snake. This guy took you out of
context. You're not a snake. You're You're all good. Don't worry.
Everything's going to be fine. You'll get through this in another
two hours. I just I don't know. I I I don't understand, bro.
This is [__] obscene. Wonderful. But how I've only
said thus far, I don't know. I don't understand. Imitating him
and he's just saying it's obscene. Address the points that he
made. Every single one of his [__] points. I need
I thought you did it, Chad. What time it is? Yeah. Okay. Yeah,
no problem. Sam, I'll sleep. Bye. Sorry. See you. Uh, Chad is
super right now though, dude. I didn't realize how funny Tommy
is. What the Tommy's Tommy's just like basically making things
up right now. You love to see it. He's just I I can do this.
Okay, everybody. This is very funny. It's like he's running like
a red bar episode. Okay, he's going to take any facial reaction
from Chud, zoom in on it, and basically make something up about
him. He's totally wrong on all the factual points, but he's like
he's just making things up, and it's quite funny.
Any mobile game recommendations? I don't really play mobile games.
Backpack Battles is like a Steam game. It's not a mobile game.
Or at least I don't have it on mobile. So yeah, just
point. He panicked online. Thanks, Cleman. Thanks, Cleman. Every
single one of his [__] [__] points. Seg
fault celebr
Tommy struggle so much. Bro, this guy's [__] lost
it. I'm telling you, it's deranged. It's totally [__]
deranged. Thank you for the [__] membership, dude.
Watch the video and tell me that. That's basically what Chud's
saying here is basically only something someone who's completely
raped would say. All right. Tommy's deranged. Why aren't you
just addressing his points? Why are you ad homing him, Chud?
Why don't you just address the points? Explain why he's deranged.
Don't just say he's deranged with no explanation. I'm honestly
He might just explain in two seconds. The only point I didn't
address was the stuff about the New Year stream. Okay. Which
that was the heart of that was literally the heart of the thing.
That's what that that's why I finalized the big thing. Yeah,
Chud. That was the most important part that you just ignored.
Was this was the evidence of your behavior in why I'm saying
you're a snake? The pattern of behavior. The other thing is like
you pretend not to know everything when you're in a drama. You
play ignorant. Put it all together circumstantial. I admit that's
the evidence. We can get into it and I can explain further. But
it's [__] deranged that that stream is still being
litigated. Tommy, you don't give a [__] about Josh.
No, I don't. His face. That's not the point. The point is he
was told and he didn't keep his word. And if he didn't keep his
word on that, that means anything's off. No, I don't give a [__]
about Josh at all. You're absolutely right. I don't care that
he [__] leaked it. I don't care that he made money
on it. I care that he gave his word and he didn't keep it. But
yet, oh, you leaked DMs and I didn't. That's what I care about.
And let me tell you something, other YouTubers care about that
as well, whether they hate Josh or not today. And it's absolutely
obscene that apparently now all of a sudden Boax's privacy is
super important. We got to keep respect for it. That's not the
point. Now, now that now he's
I've never said that. That was a really smart point to make.
The whole thing about Bobax's privacy and caring about it. I
wonder who else motivated that that point. Look into Ball X pit
future Steam game of the year.
I never virtue signaled on on on Bobax. Not once. So he's making
There he is. That's a
Blowback has been I think I believe Chud's point is going to
largely be things like um you're me but like these are things
that everybody every one of your friends does. Why is it okay
for every one of your friends to do it, right? Why? Why is that
always okay for your friends to do these things but not okay
for me? Why is it so wrong for me? What did What did I do that
makes it so incorrect for me to do these same things that you
excuse all of your friends doing? Cuz it would just be cool to
know. Wait, what is this? Devouring sphere. Oh, devouring sphere
sucks. We don't want that from every conceivable angle of the
internet. So, it's okay to not keep your word. I don't know.
I I I don't trust you. I don't I even I think I say in this video,
I watch how I how I watch how people I know treat people I don't
like because you know what you're in for. And I'm the bad guy
for bringing up in passing of this dress picture. What the dude?
It's ridiculous, bro. It's sick. He hasn't even let me the stream
know all enough to know that that's not what I said. He's doing
it on purpose. He got told Max. He's doing it. He leaks it. He's
doing it. You talk got told too and he did and you came out and
he immediately said on the stream, I don't I I wasn't aware.
I thought this was already public knowledge. And you were told
right there that's not the case. Oh, I have to pull this up for
a second. This guy has one of the best combos in the game right
now. He's got this pumpkin with this uh with the Excalibur. Okay,
this pumpkin is going to get tossed at me like a trillion times
and I'm going to die. Watch. He's got all these these uh chilies.
He's going to start tossing this pumpkin like a mile a minute
and I'm just going to get stunned infinitely and die. It's [__]
up. And you played stupid like you easily do. My wife and I say
more audio issues. Is that real or they with me? No, I I think
Yeah, you're fine. You're fine. Yeah, we got we got to keep Yeah,
cuz I'm I'm seeing it. You got to you got to keep an eye on Yeah,
I'm keeping I'm keeping my here here's here's here's um if you
see somebody repeatingly saying uh the audio is uh bad over again
you think they're just rolling now uh cut them just just kick
them they're going to do that over and over again I don't deal
with that I'd rather them call me names and try to stream like
that it's easier thank you for the membership you don't have
alcohol induced dementia bro it's deranged bro every is leaking
every single detail it's funny how he's ti tried to tie this
leak thing into me Boax's personal interactions with Right. And
I mentioned a dress patron on a stream and I'm some terrible
person. It's Yo. Hey, what's up? How's it going? Uh, decently.
Just kind of playing Backpack Battles 1.0 and watching the Tommy
thing. Yeah. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Um, I didn't realize how Dude,
this is actually a really funny stream. He just like uh I don't
know if I'd say it's it's not quite like Red Bar, but it's like
it's very funny how he does he basically just like, you know,
he zooms in on Chud's face and like makes up what's happening.
And I find that very funny. I find it very funny that he's doing
this like in the moment. I don't know. I don't know how else
to explain it. But you know what the most beautiful thing about
that is? What's that? Sorry. Say that again. The most beautiful
beautiful thing about that is that Tommy said he tried to watch
Red Bar and didn't get it. That is funny.
He he really No, like he really tried like he tried to really
watch it and he was like I just I like he's good but I don't
I don't really get it. Uh-huh. That's That is funny. He's just
saying what he thinks. I thought Tommy said he's just saying
what he thinks. I don't want to more of your time, but you actually
need to download the backpack battles like one point. They added
two new classes and it's actually pretty good, bro. I'm on Monster
Train 2 right now, bro. I've just picked up a like deck builder
type game.
This is actually quite good. It's like shockingly good. Yeah.
I don't know. There's like uh there's like new classes and it's
actually like fun. The mage class is actually quite fun. You
just build up like insane buffs. I don't know. I but I'm I'm
also rebuilding this entire um like I'm not on my main account
or whatever. I'm on like I I keep my my computer my
What am I trying to say? I keep my computer. You got smurf back.
That's what you're saying. It's like kind of a smurf. It's like
you basically if you don't have it it doesn't have like online
syncing. So you just have whatever's on your hard drive, right?
And so I I keep them separate so I don't up with my so I don't
with my main account on my Steam Deck which is what I play on
most of the time. So, it's like pretty low level this one. Fortunately,
what is this? No, I don't need another one of those. Okay, sorry.
It's that you lied about it. I don't care. Yeah, see, he's he's
deliberately avoiding it. And he does.
It's that you lied about it. You They told you not to do it and
you did it. That's it. I in his face. Nobody virtues. Nobody
says you Boax. You added an LGBTQ person. What? What the Nobody
said that, Chud and you know it.
That's not what the point is. The point is you're like, "Oh,
this guy's snaky and what are the signs of being a snake?" probably
over your best friends. That's Tommy's point is over your best
friends over people who who are friends with you that you think
are your friends or you publicly say are your friends. If you
those people over, you're a snake. Well, Bob was supposed to
be the friend of those people, right? Weren't they just with
him at the previous VidCon doing coke with him at I'm pretty
sure. Are you getting upset about that? Yeah, exactly. Dude,
why why is this? Okay, Dude, we'll get to it. We get to it. So
absurd to act like Bo Black's privacy is some sort of prestigious
thing that we must Nobody said that respect when his privacy
has been run rough shot over by every So it's okay to do it if
other people do it. Boy, I trust this guy because his privacy
has been run over in the past. I don't have to keep my word.
Okay. You and your friends totally this guy over. You totally
disregard his privacy entirely. You don't care. And any virtue
signaling over his privacy is uh is a problem. And Tommy's just
like, "Wait, we're not complaining about that. We're complaining
about how you're a snake with your friend's privacy. It's like
it's like the Westworld picture again, right? Looks like nothing
to me. God, they just they don't see it. No, none of them see
it. I don't understand how it's bizarre. There's a good reason
not to talk to him. There's not a good reason not to be his friend.
And there's a good reason to over avoid him right there in one
sentence. Single person commentary person that he's associated
with. It's insane, dude. It's insane. And I wasn't even friends
with Boax. I had no loyalty to Bobs ever. No. Any not even a
word either. Wait, we'll get to that when we get to it. Yeah,
I I didn't watch it. I was just like, oh my god. Like, where
is this coming from? Want to know where it's coming from? Watch
the video. But I promise you won't do this either. I'm not going
to pull the thing over and over again. Well, he doesn't look
relaxed at all when I'm talking, does he? Watch his eyes. He
very scared of Tommy.
I like that he paused earlier where Chud was like rolling his
eyes at him. He's like He paused and he's like, "Look at how
angry he is. He's grinding his teeth. Look at how mad he is."
A damn if he watches or not. I did. Very nice. I did watch it,
bro. To uh clarify. Yeah, you watched it and then you left the
best parts out and now you're telling you're being honest about
it. Say some things and you know they were they were cute. I
didn't want to watch it on stream because I knew I'd just have
to [__] tear strips out of You didn't want to watch
it on stream because you would have had to address the Bobacks
and the turkey tom thing which I made you do with this second
video. He's a [__] crazy. He's so detached, man.
It's so crazy. It's so funny that like Chud's Chud's literally
like I really just didn't want to you horribly and he's like
you you stop lying dodging you scared you you knew
now we're going to do it. I guess I've been I've been queening
mind into it. Okay, queening his mind into it. We're here now.
We're doing it. We're doing it. That was the best part. I don't
think Tommy noticed that it was you in chat who was saying you
have to do it right now, Chad. You have to watch this. That's
what made it funny to me was you were sitting there in chat like
literally directing him. Yeah. And Tommy Tommy didn't even see
it. He didn't catch it.
No, but I I think Okay, keep playing it. I think he comments
on it. Wait, is that is that right now? Cuz he already has it
up. I thought it was earlier where you said just just watch the
video, right? He technically has the video up here, right? Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Cuz you definitely did before he had the video
up.
Yeah. Tommy Tommy says something about it for sure. Okay. Okay.
I think there's a certain amount of people in Chut's crowd, maybe
a minority, that wanted to hear him answer this, that they watched
it. Maybe even people that said, "Tommy, I think I one guy particularly,
this guy Phoenix, I think you're jumping the gun." I think they
wanted to hear your explanation. And I said in that first video,
if you avoid this or play dumb, it's going to leave an empty
taste in your audience's mouth. Well, it did because a follow-up
made you follow up. Became a member. Thank you for the
They were cute. They tried to do I just love I love that Tommy's
like he's so certain of his conspiracy that he's willing to take
the person he's willing to take your side. He's willing to go,
"Yeah, this guy totally like me in a conversation, but you need
to sub to him cuz at least he's honest about his
He basically did everything I thought." And the fact that he's
playing Watch the lips. Watch the lips. Watch the playing stupid
fence rider bit over and over again. Like he has no concern about
his own reputation or like how he feels personally. He's so concerned
with like what Nick feels and how he feels Nick has been uh like
wronged that he's totally willing to like Yeah. basically kneel
to the person who him and just go, "Yeah, no, no. Go sub to that
guy, guys. Go sub to that guy. That guy's way better than Chud.
At least that guy's honest. Come on, guys." Yeah. He says at
one point, I don't know if you it might not open at this point,
but he says like he basically implies that the reason I would
have gotten Chud to react to it is to is to try and own Chud.
Like, see, that's actually that is me snaking Chud. That's me
cutting Ch's audience out and and owning him by getting him to
watch Tommy C. It's like that you you have to be actually on
such another level of cope to think that's what's going on there.
Listen, Tommy C is operating on a different level. Okay, we're
playing checkers. Tommy C's playing all his teeth and uh I'm
going to show you why I don't like this guy and I had enough
became it's about like I don't trust that. I want nothing to
do with right. I was right. Okay, that's wonderful. But how do
I
start TV became a member? I also dude, bro, I love the fact that
he's mad. Wait, wait, that's a that's a different channel, right?
Stardust TV became a member. Oh, those chuds. Anyway, you're
saying I didn't watch the video. I did watch the video and I
addressed this. I'm not I'm mad at you for not watching the video.
I have to repeat myself. I guess I have to do this over and over
again because he's being dishonest, too. What does he mean he's
not mad at him for not He's brought up Chud not watching the
video like a hundred times already. What does he mean he's not
mad about Chud not watching the video? I'm not mad at you. I
think you were a a disingenuous prick that you left the most
important parts out and only after I make a reply did you address
that's not Wait, the most important parts of the video. That's
not even true. You've in the past like 30 minutes he's brought
up Chud not watching the video like multiple times and then eventually
he's like, "Wait, wait, wait. Did you just say he watched parts
of it?" Oh, you only watched part of it. Okay, that makes you
a snake in my opinion. Points. And now you're right. He is characterizing
my video whilst not watching it totally erroneously. That is
not what Bucking said in my video. I addressed pretty much every
single point that he made. Pretty much no Tom is no Tom Max.
Pretty. It's gone from I addressed them all until I addressed
pretty much. He has changed it what I think like three times.
The only thing I didn't substantively address should have kept
it countered how much how much he changed this. Didn't think
of it because of the other points I was addressing. And I haven't
even started. I've only opened the show and made a bunch of jokes.
He has gone 40 minutes straight of freaking out before he even
heard what I said. This is the longest period of time where uh
he allowed the video to play. The longest period of time was
the new I don't know if we discussed this the other night when
we were watching this, but uh I find Tommy C's like lack of understanding
of people's ability to make content very funny, right? He's like,
"This guy's been watching my video for like 90 minutes. It's
a 30-minute video. What are you even doing?" He's like, he literally
it like the concept eludes him entirely. He just doesn't he doesn't
get it. He's got no idea what's going on there. It's more like
minutes because you got to remember he's got that opening of
music for 20 minutes. So Oh, okay. Oh, okay. So 20 minutes like
Okay, hold on a second. You're right. Let's Let's be fair. I
mean like from 1833
from 1833 to 3857. Oh my god. And I I bar I literally the intro
played I said what? What? I don't understand. Because I think
it's funny that you pretend that you don't know anything all
the time. Everything he said in his video. Girl, watch. You're
going to believe me, bro. Didn't Now he just said everything.
Hold on a second. The only thing I didn't substantively address
because I didn't think of it cuz of the other points I was addressing
was the New Year stream. I addressed everything he said in his
video. Girl, what the New Year stream is the most important.
That's so funny. If you don't believe me, bro. That's the crux.
That's the crux. The crux of the New Year stream and if you watch
it, you would have known that. So, let's stop. Like, I didn't
know it was the crux of your argument. I thought you were calling
me a uh You think other people are mad about the New Year's stream
and that's why Tommy's mad about the New Year's stream? I feel
like that's got to be what it is, right? Like other people have
told him that the New Year's stream was like a betrayal or something.
I just can't see Tommy like even understanding that. Like I just
feel like he would watch it and he wouldn't he wouldn't get it.
I don't know. I don't know if you have any comments on that thoughts
on that. Is this okay? Uh I guess not though. You should. So
if you're going to pretend not to know what's wrong by not watching
a video, we're going to pretend we didn't watch a video. Oh,
he's muted. I didn't see that. My bad. Now he's realizing the
pretend to watch a video was a joke. Now he can't grandstand.
You didn't watch my video.
Oh, did I not start my fight? as you can. Yeah, you can avoid
the um by the way, we're going to be taking a break in 10 minutes.
All right, cuz we already going an hour. We will be taking a
break in 10 minutes. There will be breaks in this one. We're
going a whole night. The uh No, we didn't bring up the Bobax
thing. Come to think of it. Um you can avoid the fact that you
you spilled on Boax. We had everything on Bobax. And what a bad
person
what you spilled on Bobax. I think you need to have a conversation
with your with your [__] other commentary mates because
what what is he talking about? I'm about He see he's going to
cut me off constantly so he could just yell over it. what I'm
what I'm about to say that he's gonna probably talk another 20
minutes over. We had everything on Boax. I feel like Tommy just
took what his main point would be in any sort of debate and just
made it in a like a like a react video context. He's going to
yell over me and cut me off. No, he's going to hit play after
he's done talking and people are going to hear what you said.
Now, there's some chance that he get cut off, but it's it's still
going to be there. And trust me, if there's if there was something
juicy there, I feel like somebody in Chud's audience would point
it out. These people got no loyalty to Chud. Okay. They totally
point out if he if he tried to dodge something, Tommy, they get
him. We didn't need the dress. And my accusation is twofold.
You did it just for content. Yeah. So what? I don't care so much
about that. And you gave your word. And then you pretended you
didn't know, which we clearly know now is the case. You've admitted
to a lie. That's it. I admit it's not that big a lie, but you
told you you were perfectly comfortable with people believing
the last 6 months that you did it by accident. And clearly you
didn't. When you got caught, you said, "What's the big deal?"
All right. What's the big deal? Well, what's my first video called?
I don't trust truck log logic anymore. It's not because you hurt
Bobacks Boax. He could get hit by a car. I don't care. It's that
you gave your word. And if you're not willing to give your word
on this, if you're willing to let a lie sit for 6 months, you're
willing to lie about other things. It's quite simple. They were
spilling tons of beans. I spilled a little nugget, a a single.
So, the whole thing is I spill more than him. What the [__]
is he talking about? It's like I'm leaking on everybody all the
time. Baked bean and I'm getting [__] for it now.
Well, bro, are you serious? Who is taking this seriously? Dude,
who is seriously taking this moral? You over mentioning the Boax.
Okay, Tommy's laugh is I can't Dude, Tommy's funny. I just I
not funny in like a Oh, I think this not in a He's not serious,
but he's actually I find him very funny. I don't know how else
to explain this to people. It's actually like quite funny to
it's quite funny to listen to him. Dress picture in a stream.
Seriously,
it's uh how do I explain it? It's like it's like a kid in special
ed class who thinks he's like, "Yeah, give me light." Okay, that's
like what the sense I'm getting from this right now. And I find
that incredibly
Yeah, I can't quite do it, but I I feel the energy. I feel it.
Okay. He's trying to go He's trying to get it done. He's trying
to do this on laugh. He's trying to be awesome, and I can respect
that. Sorry. There were dedicated streams. And by the way, it's
fine. I made content out of it because it was funny. I just don't
understand why now we're super hardcore moral frogging about
Bo Black's dress pigment. We never macked. We call we said it
was an example of you not keeping your
deranged, bro. What go what are we doing here, dude? We didn't
have to out him. He did on purpose cuz your content suck. I mean,
it wasn't enough for you. They probably wouldn't have found his
stupid Only fans if it wasn't for you. Me? What? That's true.
That was a B. Chud
found it and leaked it. And Chud himself personally outed Boax.
I can verify this. Okay. I'm in Chud's DMs. I'm in all the anti-Cabal
group chats. Okay. Chud personally outed Mr. Manihi. Okay. Is
an address. You have tons of trolls are going to search it to
research it. No, I don't give a [__] about that.
But all the stuff that came afterwards. Yeah. Because now like,
oh, now Bob, let's find it. He's he's completely content brain.
That's what I'm saying there. Now again, Bob, he asked for it.
But you gave your word. You said you would know. And then you
then you lied. Then you lied to the public and said like this
is a complete accident. And clearly it wasn't. Now it's like
who cares? I did it. So what? Why you caring about it? You're
a kid that got caught. So now I'm apparently culpable for his
queer only fan stuff leaking too. He did that himself. That was
his own doing. He showed his email and people put the pieces
together and found the accounts because you leaked it. Are you
going to call out Augie for leaking the Evan? Um if it wasn't
for for Aiden, I don't know anything about that. I'm gonna play
stupid like Chad. Wait a minute. Get get what to Aiden? The address
pick apparently that's the address pit.
It kind of makes sense that Aiden would know about it, but it
was just to Aiden and not to the public. It was not to the public.
No, I'm not. Exactly. I'm not going to call him out because he
didn't leave it to the public. Aiden's a colleague. There you
go, bro. What is he on about, dude? Who is taking this seriously?
Who is genuinely listening to this and going, "Yeah, these are
great points actually. Yeah, it probably is true that Chad is
somehow responsible for the Boax leaks. It's absurd. He's not
to trust you. Hey, let me tell you something. My experience,
you how are you able to predict everything? Look at the way people
you trust treat people you don't like. That's a that's a really
really good indicator on what you're in the store for. You know,
is he okay?
He's coping, man. [__] sick, mate. He's biting his
[__] lip. He's breathing heavy more than me. Hey,
this is insane, mate. This is [__] insane. I'll admit
it. I'm not the only one that believes uh that you you played
stupid with Fast and Loose with uh with with Boax. I'm like,
"What? I don't know what. Here I am." Six months go by. Here
I am. Here I am. Now he actually gets to the actual criticism.
Right. You played stupid. Now he's like, "So what? I didn't
Maybe he doesn't even know the criticism because he just freaked
out for the last 30 minutes, but he makes a video on him in distress."
And I don't know. I don't know. Let me get this fixed real quick.
Uh remember he tried to do the same thing with Papa Gut like
he did to you. Yeah. Oh, did he do the definition game? I don't
know. I heard I should really watch that and I might do it. The
whole pop a gut thing. I'm I'm looking forward to that. All right.
Actually, I decided Screaming Guy's a menace to be honest, Tommy.
He really
You're screaming about everybody. Um was totally so Here's Que
going to run a defensive uh Oh, it's clip from the streaming.
He's going to run a defense for Chud, right? Or try to come up
with some reason why he didn't leak it on purpose. Okay. They
did say in the conversation with Bob Blacks, "I don't want to
see you wearing the dress." And everyone made a big deal out
of that. So maybe he assumed that Nick had said something. Oh,
wow. Look at this in the um in the chat. Is Tommy going to make
a point? He didn't let me shut down. You're not making any Yeah,
I'm pretty sure that's live, right? I know. Hey, look. Nothing
against I do it, too. Everybody does in commentary. But you know,
like Yeah, I guess if you if you've been sitting around for 30
minutes already saying, "When's Tommy going to make his point?"
Yeah, I could see how uh you come up like I'm not making my point.
He's been ranting for 30 minutes or 20 minutes. Made a big deal
out of that. So maybe he assumed that Nick had said something
about it. I don't know. Oh, I think it's a reach because I think
I explicitly told shot it was private. Yeah. Yeah. So I think
so tried to run defense. Oh tried to run defense for shot. Where
did Wait, what did didn't didn't just go Oh, yeah. This is what
happened. Made a big deal out of that. So maybe he assumed preface
it with if I were to steal my
and then concede immediately after. Yeah. I just felt like Well,
I think you came up with a better argument later, right, as well,
which is like the whole like Victoria Secret checkout thing like
after this stream if you're going to defend Chud like basically
that's not even about
this is about um this is about specifically the point. This is
like the specific point of whether Chud knew
the existence of an address photo was public or not, private
or not. Yeah, at that specific point and I'm saying here's a
way he could have not known that was private or or thought that
wasn't private and Aiden's like no I don't think it's case cuz
I told him it was private. I was like okay yeah that's not the
case. Okay. But the stuff about the Victoria Secret thing, that's
just like it it's not even like even the leak he's being accused
of doing or has done isn't even that big anyway because it's
is literally just the dress photos already publicly non-binary
and whatever else leaked Victoria Secret. Yeah. Yeah. Cuz I think
I explicitly told shot it was it was private. Yeah. Yeah. So
I think so Queen tried to run defense. Oh, Queven tried to run
defense for Chud. I don't know if he was being sincere or not.
And then Abe comes in and says, "I specifically told him. I'm
pretty sure Nick called him, too." And remember when he said
it on the New Year stream, he said he didn't know. He didn't
know that it wasn't already out. Which of course, six months
later makes zero sense because it would have been a cash cow
for any commentator, which he knew, which he made a lot of money
on it, too. Oh, Bob, mate, what are you doing? What are you doing,
mate? What are you doing? That's why he did it. Again, don't
fall for Chud's red herring. I don't give a about Boax. I don't
give a rat's ass about him. I cared that in the commentary community
he was told to keep it on the DL and then exposed it more than
likely for his own financial benefit when he was told. I don't
care what why wouldn't he just release it on his own stream if
he's going to do this. I It's not like it's not like a you know
disproving defense, but just I don't understand why he would
do it on a random New Year's stream. Like if he was if he was
just a total snake, why wouldn't he wait until he was on on his
own stream and could make like actually like hay out of it, right?
Like this stream I understand the new year stream became popular
but I yeah I just don't get why you would do it there why you
wouldn't like make something out of it and then I don't even
think did he make more content out of it after that? Yeah I don't
care if he gave a picture to somebody else don't give a [__]
I care about like sorry that is to say did Chud or DK produce
like a video of that stream that was specifically highlighting
the leak that happened or he kind of go like oops my bad and
then didn't do anything. I just don't know what the financial
gain was. Like did he make a bunch of donations? Where's the
Where's the actual financial gain
Commentary is freaking because Nick is outgrowing them and Tommy
is wrangling basically. Okay. When it was public and you told
when you told you were asked politely not to do that that that
that was going too far. That's what I care about. I don't care
that Boax got hurt. He deserved it. He's never been particularly
nice to me. I care that you didn't give your word. Why do I care?
because I don't trust people that give their word in the commentary
community and don't hold up to it. I mean, that's pretty simple.
If you're running your mouth all the time, by the way, I've slipped
before, too. Hey, Lumpy Willie. Thank you. Bo's leaked his emails.
That's how it was found. No. Yeah, I'm sure you leaked his emails.
What? What are they looking for? It you get Let me tell you something.
I've been on an hour and a half, Lumpy Willie. I have taken your
money. Okay. And uh I have no real reason to keep keep going
because again, I don't care. Have you been blocked? Have I I
haven't even muted you yet on Twitter. Eventually, I will because
you are spamming my channel, brother. You know, I haven't even
I haven't done anything. So, Lumpy, let me give you a break.
If you think that if you just get the right tweet in or the sheer
amount and I'm going to stop saying what I'm saying, you're going
to find out you're wrong. Lumpy Willy has gone December of 20.
It's It is kind of funny.
Why you don't give Don't let Lumpy Willie know you know who he
is. The are you doing, Tommy? Giving him all the power. 2016
to March of 2019. Did you think I heard for all those years that
you're that you're um your milking reviews? Oh god. Okay, never
mind. Never mind. No. Yeah. really liking it. To be honest, I've
already spoken about this. My perspective on this is that yeah,
I didn't like obviously know 100% that it was um you know, completely
off the record secret, but obviously wait a minute. What? I Let's
go back. Let's go back like 5 seconds about this. My perspective
on this is that yeah, I didn't like obviously know 100% that
it was um you know what's obvious about it. Aiden told you this
is private. Like what's obvious? Aiden told you this is private.
Quean Queen couldn't even defend you. What's obvious? Well, I
mean, what is Queenie going to do? Say, "No, no, no. You're clearly
lying." I don't think Why would Aiden lie about
I defense. I Okay. Well,
I don't know. Why? Uh I actually don't know why Chud would say
something if he was told it was explicitly private other than
that he forgot, right? Like that's that's basically his argument
here is I forgot. And I guess the issue is Tommy's been saying
that's his argument for everything. But I haven't heard him make
that argument for something else. Does he have that argument
for something else? Oh, I forgot this was private. Well, he's
saying like I don't think Chud really gave a whether it was private
or not, you know, but he probably kind I think this might be
private, but I'm just Well, if he doesn't give a then why is
he saying I didn't know it was explicitly private?
Yeah, I don't know. Not be 100% and also not give a whether it
is or not. Right.
Sorry, you cut out there. I'm going to listen to it. I just want
to listen to this one. Yeah, I didn't like obviously know 100%
that it was um you know what's obvious about it? Aiden told you
this is private. Like what's obvious? Aiden told you this is
private. Quean Queen couldn't even defend you. What's obvious
about it? A completely off the record secret. But obviously I
said it on a bit of an off chance, right? I didn't know one way
or another 100%. And it turns out that wasn't public info and
it caused a funny moment on stream which then I think led Aiden
to draw a picture of Boaxs in the dress. Why are people like
why is this a serious point to address? Oh, Chudge, you mentioned
the Boax dress pick on a New Year's stream after everyone had
gone to town reaming him public. See, he's this way. He's framing
it like Yeah, he Yeah, he he's he's shifting. Well, it obviously
matters.
Okay. But I I see what you're saying that he's saying um he he
knew it was like kind of on the down low. He didn't realize it
was like a I'm trusting you with this. Do not share it. which
is probably a reasonable point of view to have if you know like
five people have come to you or f you know of like five to 10
people who have seen this picture and are all laughing about
it that it might not be like oh I don't even know if it was like
I don't even know if it was like and it wasn't even like a super
secret thing like a I don't think Aiden Aiden would have said
probably it was private but I don't think it was like a this
is like take this to your grave don't leak this until
it you know it's it's like a it's private but I mean it can very
easily become not private and no one really gives a [__]
cuz it's it's not that consequential. Well, it's consequential
to Boax. Well, no, it's not because that that's the thing, right?
Cuz he's already out as non-binary saying he wants to be that
bearded lady uh talking about crossdressing, showing his Victoria's
Secret. Check out Wait, did he really say the bearded lady thing
before this? Yeah, I believe so. Uh
transition already public. Poor poor Bobacks. Everybody's bullying
him. My whole thing is he didn't he gave his word and didn't
keep it. izing all of or is now is he going back and saying he
didn't know? Is he playing dumb again? You got to really pick
a stance.
I'm playing. Yes, it's very nuance. Yes, I know. The ultimate
way to get around to the snakes. The snake. That's really That's
really nuance. The tool for snakes, you know. The ultimate tool
for snakes. Really? No, it's stolen valor. Tommy C. You mopped
floors and burned bottles.
Okay. Thanks, bro. So, you didn't like you didn't know. So, he's
going to completely mischaracterize my argument. um say that
I'm crying about Bobacks when I make it 100% obvious in this
video. And uh yeah, this is for this audience. This is for for
their outrage. He's farming their outrage and try to sending
in my end in the He's going to hope and pray that that I that
I just tap out the all of the information about him that you
could possibly imagine. Every shred of DM pos and didn't I say
that we had everything on him? Everything. We didn't need the
dress. That's what I said. Yeah, we had so many other things
we could burn this guy's career over. We didn't need the dress.
The dress was sacred. Okay. Yeah, we all like hate trans people
in this group. We're all like super We're all like massive bigots.
The dress was a major secret, guys. How could you How could you
give the dress away, Chud? You son of a [__] Who
takes this seriously? So, 6 months later, you just drop it on
there cuz you wanted content for it. Breaking your word. You
were told that one's off limits. You didn't give a possible leak.
There was stuff that I didn't even cover that got leaked to Bob's
DMs. And I don't care. I don't give too much content. Yeah.
But now we got a moral frog about me on an off
stream on New Year's for a I just said you can't keep your word.
I never moraled about Bobacks. That's a lie. Laugh when I bought
it up. What it video find out? You dumb limey. This is absurd
dude that I've got to seriously be held to task for me. He has
he has literally not even let me talk long enough to explain
myself. The fact that Bo Black is a massive queer. What are you
on about, bro? It's ridiculous. What am I on about? I wouldn't
I wouldn't know how to tell you. I didn't get to that point yet.
And then guess what happened? I can really see how this made
you crazy. Oh, of course, of course. When it got leaked that
Boax was a What do you want? I'll I'll throw you some money probably.
I'm not joking. Only fans um non-binary creator. Of course, everyone
respected his privacy and didn't cover it. Oh, no. That's not
what happened, is it? Literally, everyone spoke about it and
mocked him. He is a public figure. He deserves to be mocked.
And so did we, Chud. We did all of that and then some. And I
was told not to bring up the dress and I didn't do it. That's
the problem I have. Now, you might not think that's a big deal.
Your audience might not think that's a big deal, but remember
the name of the video. I don't trust Tread Logic anymore. That
is one of the reasons. So, you got caught and you have been on,
but you said I obviously I didn't know. And then even if I did
know, it's okay. That is why I don't trust you. Hey, this thing
about Willie Mack is But there's a point there. No point explanation.
And then you go on to say, uh um that's a that's a nuance. That's
nuance commentary right there. Nuance. The ultimate tool in the
snake shed. Right. That's what I'm saying. Nobody gives a [__]
about Bobax's feelings. Nobody thinks they can. No. I mean, what
would would that be the ultimate hypocrisy on my part if I was
actually saying to you that you can't talk about Boax or you're
going too far or anything like that? No, it's that you didn't.
You were told and you didn't. Nobody can trust you. I don't trust
you. That's it. Because like we made Bob
on this show. I know. I mean, Jesus Christ. We don't give a flying
about black. There is there is there's very few people. I've
been abusing him longer than Chad was. [__] mocked
him relentlessly for a week. Right. Okay. But I've got to feel
bad about mentioning the dress picture. I don't care if you feel
bad about it. Sorry. That's incredibly funny. Like, we we ate
Boax so much. This isn't about violating Bob's This is not at
all about violating Bowax's privacy. This is about violating
our privacy when we told you not to talk about how we were vi
violating Bobax's privacy. Oh, weren't you like, you know, publicly
friends with Boax? Didn't Boax think he was like really good
friends with you guys? Yeah. So, like, what's the difference?
Well, we knew that we hated this guy, I guess. I guess. Okay.
So you guys let him think you were friends and continue to farm
like all of his misery, all of his like embarrassing [__]
Yes. Oh, okay. Sorry. But that was cool when you guys did. Yeah.
Okay.
Bro, you're snake that cannot be trusted. Oh, and by the way,
um, with my DMs, if you say something about me, I've been saying
this. I haven't had to say this a couple years. If you tell me
something in private and say something about me the opposite
in public, I will leak your DMs. I don't go for this golden logic.
It's for snakes. That's way different.
He's acting up. This is some big point against me that I mentioned.
What? How does this make me a [__] snake, dude? What
loyalty do I owe to Boaxs, dude? Especially after everyone. So,
that means you only owe loyalty to people you like. There's another
good reason not to trust you, Chad. Loyalty is kind of like,
hey, um like you only get to keep secret just everybody else.
Yeah. I I don't think I don't see I mean, I got to be honest
with you. If you're a YouTuber and you work with this guy, you're
nuts considering what his his community is like. Uh you're going
to have to deal with Clemente and 10,000 other weirdos that live
with their parents probably for the next 10 15 years, if not
forever. Why would you work with him? If you told him something
personal, if you picked him off, if somebody else got a got a
hold of it, Jud's going to [__] do content on you.
He's going to content moral fact. If you get in a situation where
you get in trouble on the net or your popularity goes down and
he has the clap capital to [__] step on you, which
is the whole reason I don't trust him, he'll do it. You just
have to be a bad person in his eyes or no, a bad person in the
internet's eyes. Oh man, has gone to town on him and leaked all
the DMs. Why am I expected to have this loyalty to Bobax when
everyone else has already him over? So will you. No, I kept it
quiet. I knew about the dress for six months. So you're wrong.
10 times over.
Oh yeah, I'll go down. I I'll you up. There's no doubt about
it. Especially if I don't like you. But if I make an agreement
to other YouTubers about not leaking something. And by the way,
I have accidentally spoken about stuff. It's been a long time
since I've done it that I was told to keep private and I apologize
for it.
And it's my whole thing. It's not that YouTubers can't trust
you. You're you're nobody's friend. Your policy, even though
it's not public, is everybody's content. This is about money.
Friends with him. I knew of him and been on streams with him.
Why have I got any What do I owe to Bobax, bro? What do I owe
to Bobs to not mention that? You know, like Aiden is Well, so
wait a minute. Is it you don't owe him anything cuz he didn't
say it or is it you didn't know he's talking out both sides of
his mouth again? Yeah. I think it's like it's not loyalty. That's
like not the argument. I know. I know. because you got to by
other goalost shifted red herrings goal postpose shifting and
mischaracteriz mischaracterizing my argument like saying like
oh like I'm making it oh poor bo
is what he has to do because he knows there's a point can't be
trusted chud that's it that's it chud you can't be trusted that's
it that's all that's all it's not okay for anybody you can't
be trusted you can't be trusted that's it the one that told me
about it right and I wasn't 100% one way or another whether it's
Tommy you're realizing everyone is content you're just realizing
this no I have specifically had a policy where I won't do that.
And I think if you do do that, you're a snake. So now you're
just telling me uh well I I don't know how you can't be have
be a snake um and not have that policy. Chud LGBTQ. Also Chud
I didn't know he did that. I can't I'm not I'm just laughing
if that's true. I have no idea if he shits on LGBTQ. Clearly
Chud is LGBTQ.
So I thought it would be funny to bring it up regardless. And
then obviously got shut down that was funny. And then Aiden drew
a picture of it as a laugh or look look he's a dirty secret.
Hey Queenman don't trust. He's been writing me on Twitter saying,
"Hey, that video I did on that technicals did." Yeah, I think
he might be right on that. Hey, uh, you know, give Tommy uh,
give Tommy C some credit. Chedd Wood, actually, this is your
worst. Chud, what did he say? Blow Hitler to move ahead. Oh,
is that a joke now? I know what you're doing. You're too funny.
You're [__] funny. As soon as realized I was that
it wasn't the kind that it wasn't going I wasn't going to get
a majority on my side and then I told him he's no good. That
he's no good. that he's like, "Ah, you all the people involved
in this process thought it was funny and don't really care."
But now, uh, how many times did this guy leak on? This is actually
crazy. What's important? I I don't care that people don't care.
Is Is that the whole thing? It's okay if people care. It's okay
if I can sell it. How about keep your word? How about like if
I tell you something I don't have to know? It's going to end
up in your show. Six months later, Tommy C is upset about it.
So, I've got to address it. Apparently, it's stupid.
His face is What have I got to answer for? I got I not I will
not be apologizing for that. It doesn't make me a snake. If you
think so, you're a [__] You're a disagree. We can
have a conversation about it. But oh, wait. You're too much of
a [__] Why Why would I have a Why would I have a
conversation with with If we disagree, you're But we can have
a conversation about it. Let's talk about it. That's literally
That's literally like one of the best reasons is the harmful
opinion thing where you started calling him names. So, he makes
a definitive statement. If we disagree, you're But come on, let's
talk. Okay. Call me a all you like. Gigantic. Don't have that
[__] combo because you don't listen. Disagree, you're
not [__] good. Let's talk about it. Oh, and I'm a
snake. It's [__] pathetic though. I'm sorry. The
the laugh is it's like it wouldn't be as funny if he was correct
about stuff. It's so funny when he's like just totally wrong
about everything. It's very very funny to me. I can't not laugh
at it. It's It's just awesome. Okay, this guy's awesome. Absolutely
pathetic. Thank you for the super chat, guys. Funny. Uh oh, a
super big criticism. Teeth it skitso tank. I bet he hated that.
Uh skitto tank. So he's a British. No, I'm not going that far.
Um, I will say this. I do get the fake that I I do get the sense
that um Chud is not like a working-class Englishman. I don't
I really I don't know how to read I know they can tell by each
other's accents and I'm not but something tells me something
tells me that Chud is actually born with a silver spoon in his
mouth. This guy who sat here streaming K with like how many viewers
would Ch have had like a low point on Twitch like not that many,
right? I get the feeling this guy you know what was he not the
one? Oh, never mind. No, I'm misunderstanding the pot noodle
thing. Never mind. No, I don't know. Something tells me I've
seen Chud's background like zoomed in
house and his dad was like a heron addict assumption. I mean,
I'm literally just zooming in to his flat and it's like I'm sorry
that's not the flat of somebody who's got like rich parents.
I like it's not it might not be bad, but let's be real. That's
not like a luxury flat of any kind. That's not a nice That's
not like a super nice. Pretty sure this is part of someone else's
house, too. I I don't actually think this is like, you know,
like an apartment or something. He's spoken about his landlord
before and knock his landlord knocking on his door. So I I think
it's like part of a bigger house, you know.
There's nothing wrong with that, but like uh yeah, I just I've
never gotten the impression the I don't understand how you have
the impression that Chud is like well off just I feel like he's
got just the way he talks. I don't know. Listen, as a fellow
poor, I kind of I just recognize the symptoms. Okay. I just I
don't know why else to say that. No, I wouldn't be surprised
if Chuck came for money. iversible. I I also wouldn't be surprised
if but yeah, something tells me no. I think he lars as one cuz
I remember I asked him that question in his interview. He looked
uncomfortable. I wonder. Oh, super big criticism. There's some
teeth at Tommy's criticism here now. Oh, in more ways than one,
my uh my um white knight friend. Yeah. So, I'm not the only one
who believes this. And by the way, this guy's going to take your
audience 100%. You don't have to worry about Nick out. You don't
have to worry about Willie being nice here. He's going to take
your audience because Queman is willing to do Chud won't be a
completely Is this some sort of weird effort to put some sort
of wedge between me and Queen? No, no, no. I'm actually being
quite I'll be I'll be I'll be and I'm taking a break after this
so you guys can talk. It's very funny and obvious to be honest.
I I like it. I enjoy it quite a bit. Respect for Queen. I think
I believe that all you have to do if you want somebody if you
like Queven stuff just watch him because Chud probably feels
similar if not 100%. But he's you know he's got people on a little
more on all sides of the aisles whereas like Queen's just an
outand-out extremist right so but you you balance I mean you
say something's bad in the same sense like the Willie M. Yeah
Chud's like a normal person you're just you're you're insane.
Okay. With your your like tanky. I heard you I heard you basically
think that uh me thinking that these protests getting violent
is bad. That that that's that's just soy. I've heard that. I've
heard you say violence is bad but sitting there going the way
for 6 hours is is pretty bad. How many times did I talk about
the whimos? Wait, was I even like
No, but you were having you were having like a you were having
like a a negative emotional reaction quite significantly so to
very little violence and it was like you were acting like it
was going crazy. Can I get a clip of that happening? Oh, we could
go back and watch through the stream. This is a passive I I just
wouldn't mind a clip. I just wouldn't mind a clip. I don't I
don't have a clip for you. Did you watch it? You watched me like
cover it and you were like, "Oh, this guy's like freaking out
over the whimos." I thought I was like laughing at it. Like I
thought the whole thing was like
crazy violent. nothing happening. It's like the worst part of
it was in the blocks off a bridge. Yeah, the the rocks was like
that wasn't that wasn't like wa this protest is so crazy that
these police are
that obviously this is going to happen if you've got a large
enough crowd that too that's protesting
they're trying to keep riot
you can't have that freeway shut down right you can't have that
freeway shut down so they're trying to hold that I don't know
how they ended up up ended up under that freeway that was but
you have to make sure that people aren't throwing things down
there yeah that's bad yeah obviously I don't think I said I don't
think I said anything beyond that was bad. Like and then you
move those people. It's getting out of hand. No, it was the it
was the your assessment of the level of violence and disorder
that was happening seemed to be way off, Mark. I was like watching.
I was like, "Wow, this guy's really freaking out over nothing."
Okay. Was there something other than the Whimos? Cuz the only
bit I remember with the Whimos is was like joking about how the
androids are going to remember this. I know. I literally I said
the Whimo thing mockingly because that's that's the main piece
of property damage that you see photos of and it's it's just
nothing. Oh. Okay. Yeah. I don't I just feel like that's discordant
with like how I remember talking about it. So, okay. Oh, sorry.
I should play in the video. Sorry, I hit I I I covered all those
points. Oh, wait a minute. I covered some of his points. Oh,
wait a minute. I I I covered the important ones. You'll say anything.
Anything at all. Over and over again. He spoke out both sides
of her mouth. So, Queman just spits it. And again, see if I get
a hashtag hash sub
150%. Probably most people in there already or you are. Yeah,
it's so embarrassing to have your actual beef with Queen and
then to go uh actually, you know, even though I'm completely
by this guy, uh I'm so I'm so dedicated to the other people around
me that I'm going to say no, sub to him. Sub to him.
I was just going to give into them. Actually, I it's all if I'm
just uh consenting. That's like that's where this is going. It's
bizarre to me. Like this is the actual person who with you and
you're like to sub to I don't understand
this. It's not a strat. It's not a strat. It's just funny to
me. Subman. You will find out what Chad's thinking and he'll
have, you know, balls. We got scream's new dono sound. Actually,
Tommy, here's here here's another thing, too. Calling his phone.
That's his new dono sound. It's just you saying no. I mean it
is. I got him. He can use me. I don't I don't get upset about
this. I got him. He can use me. Absolutely sub. Let me give him
one more one. How about that? Ladies and gentlemen, subbed acquaintment.
There you go, bud. There you go. That's a good one. There you
go. Absolutely. Subdument
because that guy will come right out and be a This guy, he's
just a fence rider until he gets caught and then he freaks up.
At least you go with somebody that uh isn't afraid. I mean, Chud's
afraid to to criticize Nicholas Dioro because it might cause
drama. No, but he's willing to start you, see if the balloon
floats, and then when it doesn't. It's crazy that
get it. Oh, whoops. It's crazy that Tommy's taking this talking
point from you, too. That Chud's too scared to criticize Nicholas
because it'll cause drama. He's taking everything right now.
I I'm shocked that he's willing to sit here and say Queenman
tells Chud what to say. It sounds like Queen's telling Tommy
C what to say. Why is he repeating all these things? There's
another pattern there, too. Get in a call with me. I completely
it up. Let's talk about it. There's nothing to talk about. I'll
be what I'm saying. I'll be right back, guys. Well, first of
all, if I want to do this, I'm going to take five. Get a coffee.
We're in for a long play some music. Um, I don't think I can.
So, I think you have to I think you have to see. What do you
think of that? All right. All right. I'm going to sing for the
next 20. No, 20 minutes. Five. I'm going making a coffee. I'm
coming down. Uh, and then uh God, I would love somebody to make
like a super cut of this. I'm willing to pay for that, by the
way. I'm also willing to take when when Chud pulls his This is
really crazy, but they got a point. Send me those clips. I would
love to check them out. Oh, let's go. Save this. One, two, three.
Bum bum. And uh All right. Uh can I Is there like no because
it won't Can you put a BRB? BRB. Yeah, let me put a Let me put
a BRB. I hate doing I never I hate streaming. I don't know how
he does it. He streams over and over and over again. I guess
I was making the money. Uh I do it, but it's just I don't know.
I think things should be shows. I'll give him that. Ch does go
on [__] I'll give him I'll never call him lazy. I'll
never hear that. I call him a
by the way
too far
between you two. Or are you just going to point to what I said?
I mean,
towers because what they'll do is they'll try to get the stream.
Can you put the chat in slow mode? Yeah,
that might be the goal, too. How the [__] do I do
that? I never had to do that before. And why did you Tyler against
Tommy C? We should like people to attack this man in the marketplace.
I think I should start going back to the old days and start telling
people going after going after his channel. Going after his livelihood.
That's [__] up.
That's what happened 100% for sure. It's [__] crazy.
Slow. I don't
It's ironic considering he didn't cover. By the way, there's
nothing wrong if he did see it in a super competitive way. If
he kept everything above war and was in the snake and he started
getting like more viewers than me then yeah, that's a bit annoying
because I've seen so many people surpass me over the years. I
think you'd [__] snitch on him personally. But I'm
not really, you know, I'm not really worried that he's gonna
like usert my audience. We're quite different content creators,
I think, despite the fact that Yeah. One's a phony. The fence
rises to fence rises. Pounce and the other one pounces. Why don't
you go watch the the hour where the action is? Both English.
I don't really think that we've got We got a bit of crossover
from time to time. Maybe. But I think we've got quite different
ways of doing streaming. You know, Tommy is so irrelevant he
making up drama. You don't even know the players involved. Lol.
Thank you very much for the super chats. It's like that's ironic
considering he didn't cover the New Year stream part. But you
know, in fairness in fairness to them, I don't really understand.
Yeah. Yeah, I know. You never understand. In fairness to them,
I could see why his audience would come away with I'm not making
any points because it's just him screaming about points that
I never made. This effort like Okay, sure. I guess I'll I guess
I'll keep a lookout for that. I don't know. I guess I'll keep
my eyes open just in case tries to [__] jab his hand
into the back of my neck and suck my life force out or something.
I mean, I don't know what to say to that. Like, okay. I don't
know. Take it as a [__] as a jab and not literally.
I'm a [__] dork. I I guess I'll keep a lookout. Thanks
for the heads up. He dishonest dubious. Right out in right out
in the open. Like completely out in the open. Like what did he
say about me? I would never bend over backwards for my friends.
Um like Tommy C does. Yeah. Guilty. Yeah. I'm trying not to address
Creamman's points in chat because I don't want it to seem like,
you know, Creamman just did a little annoying. I'm trying not
to do it. Now you're not. Oh, okay. Do not get it twisted. Okay.
Do not think that's changed, just to be clear. But but you know
it's just true that a rising tide raises all ships. That's the
way that I've always looked at it. Right. Okay. That's wonderful.
But how do I make money off depressed people? Cody, did you know
that? Did you Did you see the Lumpy Willie said signing in critics
and he's still typing not been blocked? Not been anything. Are
you kidding me? I'm in love. Come debate me. Well, you're just
as honest as he is. No. No. Likeile Jewish. Here here's what
I'll tell you, Queenman. I am not as easily swayed by my audience
as your uh as your puppet ma as your puppet master is. Fake queening
by the way. I just checked. Oh, damn it. You got to stop. Super
chat. And for me at least, it's not something I really want to
be like, you know, I I don't want to I don't want to replicate
the destiny model. I you know, I've been in the Destiny model
and I don't like it much looking back on it and I don't want
to subject other people to that. So, I don't want to create this
like formal I I I figured out Destiny before you and I probably
figured out you before everybody else. orbiter thing and then
like Creamman's on my stream all the time. But like if Creamman's
got like an issue of disagreement and it's happened before. Ray's
messaged me and we've we've argued on stream about it. Isn't
Isn't that novel guys? Isn't that novel? You ever disagree with
someone and you talk about it on stream and you have sometimes
very I don't like calling that the Destiny model. I actually
reject calling that the Destiny model on a you like have a group
of people that you actually like talk to about content. I literally
have a problem. I don't like that idea. That character is being
a
whether you're a snake or not. I'm pretty sure you're not going
to come to the conclusion that you are. Wow. Shocking. Shocking.
I know. Yeah, it is what it is. But yeah, I mean obviously Yeah.
I just I really don't like it. Like it's like it's it's like
a fun way to do content and I understand it like it has asymmetries
but you can manage those asymmetries in a way that Destiny never
bothered to. So it's just weird to like seed that whole thing
to him. Back of that there's some people that then might like
what Queen's got to say and then some people from my audience
will probably, you know, head over and watch him. And obviously
I drain him quite a lot. Raids him a lot. He's got him on all
the time but they're totally separate. a good dude, man. Give
some charity.
He's a good dude. Twee is not a good dude. All right, point number
105. Like look who look who his mates are. Chad like raises raises
like a bunch of orphans. He owns like he [__] so
funny, you know. Like I don't want protege such a word, but I
mean there's nothing wrong with having one or wish I had a better
word than that. I mean at one time, you know, uh Nick came through
here and he went far far behind uh far much farther than I ever
did. Nephew
I'm here for it. No, I'm trying to spread it around a bit and
raise some of the other Tony wishes Nick was just like me. No,
I'm glad I'm glad Nick is nothing like me. I would if I saw Nick
doing half the [__] that he's done. No, would called
him out and I nipped him in the butt. I would be so funny if
that would be the downfall of this guy's
so funny. Or at least one of those orbiters around him. So funny
to like, you know, and stuff. Although that's not really fair
to Creamman. And since I got 300 odd viewers, but um or 400 viewers,
it's still at like 50.
The record orbit,
come on. Don't be worried about it. Okay, that's wonderful. But
how do I make money after press people? I would rather off myself
than watch regularly. Don't worry, Chun. Thank you for the super
chat. Don't worry, everything's going to be fine. But yeah, anyway,
I mean, you know, it just it feels like this barefoot.
You have any proof of that, Chad? But I I just I don't know.
Like I just don't really see it that way. Do you have any proof
of that? That I'm trying to that I'm trying to put a wedge. Is
it Is it Is it the words I use? Is the actions I've taken? You
have no proof. How dare you? You've accused me something with
no proof. I'm concerned about that. It's Yeah, if he if he supersedes
me. Actually, I was thinking about doing a hashtag subment the
other day. I'm trying to think of like who who does this as well
as Tommy does like is and believes they're not like as thoroughly
then. I can't figure out who this get on. I don't feel like that's
Mac. I I feel like Willie Mack's smart. I feel like there's a
reason Willy Mack like kind of pieced out for a little bit after
some of the video criticism. Like he he was mad about it, but
he would Sorry, not peace out. There's a reason he wouldn't like
talk to anybody. I feel like Tommy I feel like if it wasn't Chud
Tommy might talk to some people.
Maybe not. Maybe I just don't have a good read on Tommy. I don't
know. I guess if they if they wouldn't talk to if he wouldn't
talk to then who would he talk to,
I feel like I don't know. Do you do you understand that? Like
what's his issue with? Why doesn't Why is he so much?
Oh, well, he gone again. Hold on. I got to wait a second. Wait,
because because made a joke about him being or something. Oh,
the kinetic hell thing, right? Right. He he called in and said
something about being a 14 talking to 14y olds and Tommy lost
his mind. Uh Tommy ever think about maybe not talking to those
14year-olds or I I literally don't know, by the way. I don't
even know what that's about. So, I just said that because it's
funny. So, I don't I literally don't know the story there. Well,
I kind of know the story there. The kinetic hell thing, but I
really don't know. So, okay. Okay. How do I bounce this right
there? Oh, I don't have the bag space.
He would rather
than kiss the Oreo's ass for 200 viewers. I got to be honest
with you. I think if I kiss the Oreo's ass, I would want a little
more. just like you're going to hop on the bizarre bandwagon
with Really? It's a good game. I know it's a good game and I
do kind of want to hop on the bandwagon for the Bizaarre, but
I don't really want to play games that much and so I'm playing
Backpack Battles because I actually like this game and I've played
it for a while. So, I don't I but I don't think I'm going to
continue playing like Backpack Battles or other games here like
it for very much longer. Yeah. So, unfortunate, but I don't think
that'd be too smart right now to be honest with you. Do I go
this to add health? Maybe. We'll see. More than 200 viewers.
But hey, I mean, Jesus Christ. And by the way, Queman, I've never
been rated by Dioro. Not once. Only Ch. Bro, it is so There's
no way that's true. This is about Quean. And also, I want to
talk about something else as well while we're here, right? Okay.
I want to get it very clear because some people seemingly very
don't seem to be able to understand it very well, dude. So you're
if you think there's a relationship between those two even though
it's like visually obvious kind of like visually obvious that
I'm trying to drive a drive a wedge for my own entertainment
you dumb well okay obviously queen came from like predominantly
my community and particularly his early viewership were like
the you know I don't want to I was going to say it's banter okay
if you don't like it's banty
right it was the dregs of my audience that initially watched
Creeman okay and what's happened since then is Cman has built
up an audience in his own right. And from what I can gather at
the moment, would be like offended by that. Believe for a minute
that he doesn't know what's going on over there. Oh, more playing
Donald. I mean, really, I mean, does anybody like even you guys
that hate me? Like, do you really believe what he's saying? That
he's just completely ignorant of what's going on in the drama
community. Like, what the [__] I mean, look, everybody
does that. Like, don't pay attention to that guy. You don't want
to give him any kind of a rub or anything like that. But really,
Quean, they're a part. He's a big part of the show. saying, you
imagine me saying that I like I don't know what Nick's up to
and I don't know what he's doing. Believe that a million years.
Love what you're saying about the Ethanos stuff, right? And it's
taken on like a very different direction than mine because I've
obviously moved away from that topic and I probably wasn't saying
it in a way they would like anyway. So it's, you know, like it's
it's like yeah, sure. Early on there was like more of a direct
audience overlap, but I think as time has gone on the audience
overlap has changed and he's got his own group of people that
watch him. So he basically was in your camp and now he isn't.
So it's completely ridiculous for me to think that he's still
in your camp at some level even though like what the Orio mean
seven eight years. It's ridiculous. I mean God he's selling a
bar of I mean I don't expect you to say yeah I'm conspiring with
him behind the scenes but to act like he's like so distant you
don't know what the is going on is totally disingenuous
point one or number 1,000 why I won't talk to him. You know some
of which maybe are former viewers of mine that don't like me
anymore for one reason or another or alternatively people that
he's found for his own coverage things that I don't talk about.
know so you know in any case the point I'm making is that yes
obviously I raid him a lot and he's come from my community initially
but I don't know what he's doing he is his own entity should
be quite simple to understand I I actually think he's his own
entity but I mean the fact that they're not working together
is just just ridiculous right he's his own entity with his own
takes his own perspectives and we even disagreed on things fairly
recently we disagreed on Daniel Green stuff for example we have
different takes on things like that and just because he's got
a take on that's funny that's funny because I had a different
take on Ethan Klein I'm consistent the Destiny's And I'm pretty
consistent, although I agree with Ethan Klein on some things.
Um, that Ethan Klein is just like for the [__] and
it's a big [__] sandwich over there. I didn't get
any from Nick, yet you were afraid there's going to be drama,
so you elected not to talk about it in public and still won't
criticize it now only because it's boring. Okay. Uh, it's getting
late, guys. I got 45 minutes left, 49 minutes left on the stream.
I'm going to add this to tomorrow. Uh, I'll double it and add
it to tomorrow, okay? Because you guys uh have donated tonight
and I think I'll Yeah, I'll be back tomorrow. Okay. I Who can
I host here on the way out? Perry video. Um maybe another night.
I'll raid rally and I'm going to go out. Okay. Okay. Love you
guys. We'll talk to you'all later. Oh, sure. I'll raid crispy.
No, I should I raided Crispy last time. I'll raid rally this
time. Okay. I love you guys. Be back tomorrow. We'll talk to
you later. Okay. We'll talk to you later. Um I think this is
the last time I'm probably going to bounce in quite a while before
I have this time finished up. I just have some that I realize
I have to take care of tonight. So, I'm going to bounce out.
Okay. Thank you for being here tonight, guys. Love you all. Talk
to you later. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye bye. Good night. Good
night. Good night. Good night. Goodbye.